morning everyone welcome to the house
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs we have several
bills noticed for today's hearings and
we'll be getting to those in a moment
but I'd like you to join me in the
Pledge of Allegiance first
foreign
thank you everyone
okay the first bill for us to consider
this morning is the house bill 188 we
have the prime sponsor here
representative Popovich Mueller
foreign
thank you very much Mr chair and members
of the committee I appreciate your
opportunity I'm planning to keep my
remarks as short as possible because it
is a long day for everybody
on the bright side I don't think we need
to spend a lot of time explaining the
intent of the bill it is attempting to
remove one paragraph 14 words from the
physical therapy bill
the intent of the bill is to remove the
requirement to go see a physician within
if there is no documented Improvement in
25 calendars there at the beginning of
the treatment
the reason why I'm advocating for this
is that we are dealing with a primary
physician shortage in many parts of the
state there are people who cannot see
their primary physicians you know
quickly there are people who don't have
health insurance and for which the
burden of having to see a doctor is
significant in material terms those
concerns combined with this law can lead
to people being unable to receive
Physical Therapy which would you know
benefit them
now
of course the law exists for a reason
but I want to point out that we have
about 20 states in the U.S including
Massachusetts and Vermont that do not
have such restrictions in their laws
that allow direct access and allow the
patient and the physical therapist to
decide you know what the proper course
of action will be
trust me I'm not gonna come in front of
this committee very often and ask us to
match the Massachusetts level of
regulations okay
but this is where we are right now we
are more tightly regulated than States
you know that honestly have a reputation
for being over regulated to start with
now to address potential concerns in
terms of you know what would happen if
this restriction would be removed
the concern in this law was that you
know Bad actors may take advantage of
unsuspecting patients and you know offer
treatment that is not needed
I would like to submit to the committee
that
we already have insurance companies that
have really tight rules around how much
treatment you can have without a
doctor's visit physical therapists are
highly trained and they absolutely will
refer the patients who do need to see a
doctor
to see a doctor if that's the best
course of treatment
and also we have the you know licensing
board that is perfectly capable of
handling any you know unacceptable
ethical violations or practice you know
or poor practices
but
the way you see this law it is a law
that no longer has a purpose
and is keeping certain people from
getting treatments so I would urge the
committee to support you know HB 188
which will remove that uh you know
regulation so
this you know I'll stop here and I'll be
happy to entertain any questions
from the committee
I'm seeing none
thank you thank you
I have no other people signed up to
speak on this does anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill 188
.
Mr chairman can I ask a question I'm I
was assuming somebody else was going to
speak
um can he can I ask him a question I
really intended to ask it to somebody
else representative would you mind
taking a question from representative
Nagel
I've never turned the question down in
my life
um thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I think this question
is actually more addressed to somebody
sitting behind you but um
um
I've been fortunate to work with
physical therapists for over 30 years
and one of the things you develop as a
mutual respect for abilities
um I also work with an international
group of people of which I'm happy to um
work with a number of Australian
physical therapists one of the things
that's unique about Australia is they
basically have direct access to care and
that allows for a lot of creativity
um in my mind and I'm just curious and
I'm staring with one eyeball is looking
at somebody else I'm sorry but this is
an important question
my concern is that the way we've done
things is stifled physical therapy in
this country and I'm just curious from
your point of view does that have any
role in why you think this is important
have your professional qualifications
but I should mention that after an
Achilles there and three knee surgeries
and the hip surgery I have a lot of
frequent flyer miles in uh you know
being a patient in an office and it has
been my experience that a lot of the
times and I don't mean that in any
disrespectful way the physical therapist
is really more qualified and more
trained on that specific area of
medicine and they know what needs to be
done because that's what they do all day
I have a huge amount of respect for the
medical profession
but they have to be way broader and you
know don't have the opportunity to delve
into those depths as much and honestly
you know my doctors and physical
therapists generally agreed but frankly
personally and speaking just for myself
if there was a time on my physical
therapist and my doctor disagreed
personally I would lean more towards you
know taking the opinion of the physical
therapist that I spend way more time
with and knows my specific injury and
how I reacted to it and what happens and
you know recovering from one Achilles
took nine months of physical therapy
there was no way I was going to get any
documented Improvement in 25 days and of
course I had a doctor referral because
you know I had a surgeon who sent me to
physical therapy but you can also
recover from a Achilles there without
surgery and just by waiting it out
letting it heal naturally and having
physical therapy
you know so I'm sorry for the long
answer to that question and of course if
anybody else was here would like to
defer in the committee would be willing
I'd be more than happy to yield
thank you
yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
um because of all the um reasons that
you just gave that among which that many
injuries are pretty intractable and
might not see any gains after 25 days
did you give any consideration to
instead of
um eliminating this to extending the
amount of time
yes I have
um the concern that I have in terms of
extending it is that we're just making a
law that's in my opinion right now
harming patients less harmful but we
don't fully eliminate the potential harm
and I think that the experience of the
States you know 20 states in the U.S not
only there are no negative outcomes but
we save money I mean if if a doctor
visit is not necessary we shouldn't
mandate it we stop preventing people
from accessing care
extending the terminal limit the harm
but I think the best policy would be to
eliminate that
thank you
other questions this is a follow-up
question to represent Mr chairman
representative Shapiro's question do you
um believe that physical therapists have
the expertise to know when they need
help from a doctor
I'm not a doctor but I will give you a
personal example
before my Achilles there
I had a Peter in the Achilles and you
could feel a bit of a bump in the
Achilles and I saw my doctor
and he told me you know yeah you have a
printer but you are fine playing two
more games in the season and then come
back to me in the summer and see what's
going on I saw my physical therapist and
my physical therapist told me I would
not play soccer under any circumstances
with that
I went and played my two soccer games
and in the second soccer game about half
an hour Arena I tore my achilles so I
genuinely believe that and the doctor
told me there was a risk of tearing it
he just said you know the risk wasn't
you know huge
I believe that because they do this on a
daily basis and this is the one thing
they do in that area they absolutely
have the ability to recognize and the
intent and please understand if they
don't do it if they make a mistake they
will be sued for you know malpractice if
you look at the insurance premiums
charge for malpractice to physical
therapies they're tiny compared to the
medical profession and that's because
they don't generate the complaints and
that's because they do refer people to
the doctors not as many as
so thank you
other questions
yes representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman for taking my question
um the bill actually says
no documented Improvement so it doesn't
say resolution of symptoms or the
Achilles tear personally I know exactly
what we went through with an Achilles
tendon rupture and that does not get
better in 25 days I agree with you there
but there is oftentimes Improvement so
my question is not so much whether or
not they should be able to continue
treatment if they have documented
Improvement my concern is that they
would get maybe two months three months
down the road and still no documented
Improvement and there's no
um
no obligation necessarily to refer back
into the medical you know or into the to
see a physician about that so my
question I guess indirectly is why not
extend the period of time
um or if not you know
what I'm saying is that
document and Improvement is different
than no resolution and how do we resolve
that because I would like to see
something that if somebody's not getting
better they at least get referred back
into the system or no improvement thank
you Mr representative Murphy
to make a long story short I absolutely
understand the distinction
but I believe that the patient and the
physical therapist and the regulatory
bodies and the insurance companies
provide enough protections right now for
everybody to not get into those
situations that you describe where they
may get excessive treatment at the end
of the day a patient knows you know
whether what they are doing is good up
to a point the physical therapist has a
huge burden professionally and ethically
and in regulation to make to provide
those references you know to the doctor
if needed and if that doesn't happen
there are plenty of mechanisms through
which a patient can seek recourse for
any mistakes that were in treatment I
just don't feel that
and I and I'm looking at the experience
of all the states that have implemented
direct taxes because I recognize that
the concern is you know I can absolutely
understand the concern but if you look
at the experience of the states that
have done this they just don't see that
happening in any way that cannot already
be handled by their existing licensing
boards
follow-up follow-up just a question you
mentioned the protections I'm curious
what are the protections to protect the
patient from
um not being seen in an appropriate
period of time
well first again there is a licensing
board if a patient feels that they
should have seen by a doctor but a
therapist took advantage of them and
treated them forever just to build them
and without providing Improvement they
can you know file a complaint with a
licensing board most patients do have
insurance insurance companies have very
specific regulations about what
Improvement do you want to show at most
times
and frankly again
I just
trust that
the combination of the patient's
self-interest the physical therapy
self-interest and the need to maintain
their professional reputation will
outweigh the Temptation for the vast
majority of them to take advantage of it
and again for the ones that don't there
are other forms of records and one last
comment
I have not in my personal experience
found the follow-up to the doctor to be
you know much more than a well of course
you need more Physical Therapy type of
appointment now of course I don't know
you know I respect their professional
opinion I'm sure they considered a lot
of factors they didn't necessarily share
with me
but it's really hard for a doctor to
deny Physical Therapy anyway so the
outcomes tend to always be a automatic
referral back to the physical therapist
and we seem to create this you know need
for all this and the expense and the
delays without you know providing a
benefit that covers the you know burdens
provided by it thank you
other questions
seeing no other questions okay thank you
thank you
also signed up to testify this morning
is representative Ellen Reed
running representative you have three
minutes please good morning thank you
thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members of the committee for
the record my name is Ellen Reed I
represent Rockingham 10 new market and
new Fields
um I will say that I have been in
physical therapy probably the majority
of the last 10 years I've had three
surgeries on my knee plus other issues
you may hear that for those of you
who've been in the uh in office for long
enough that my voice as of the last year
has not been the same part of that
physical therapy has also been vocal
therapy so I'm pretty familiar with
being bounced back and forth between
doctor and physical therapist one of the
biggest reasons that patients do not see
Improvement is compliance we are
assigned exercises a lot of us do not do
those daily exercises that our physical
therapist tells us in that case the
physical therapist not the doctor is the
one to help us figure out ways to find
how it works with our schedule how we
can remind ourselves to actually comply
with those exercises I want to be very
clear that there's nothing in in this
that says a physical therapist can't
kick a patient back
well before 25 days if they think that
physical therapy is not the solution
regardless if there's Improvement or not
there may be a little bit of improvement
but they're seeing something that they
know physical therapy is not going to
help with and it needs to go back to a
doctor and I have my personal so it's
kind of the opposite of what we're
talking about but my personal example
was one of my knee surgeries I had a
bolt put in my knee
um and then I went to the doctor because
there was a big lump on my knee it was
very very hard the doctor said oh that's
just a bursa go through Physical Therapy
you'll be fine the physical therapist
looked at it touched it like no that's
not a bursa that's a bolt coming out of
your knee had to go back had to have the
bolts removed so that was an example
where the doctor did the doctor did no
less than the physical therapist and the
physical therapist kicked me back to the
doctor long before the 25 days even
though I was showing Improvement the
physical therapist knew that my
Improvement would be limited because of
that bolt coming out of my knee that was
interfering with the building of the
muscle
I did just get the okay from the good
doctor behind me who many of us know and
love on this bill before he even saw
that my name was on it
um in terms of extending the number of
days I think any time you kind of put an
arbitrary number uh very few of us
except for the person behind me very few
of us in here are medical doctors so I
don't think putting an arbitrary number
even if you're extending it is the
solution if you were to amend it and
again because physical therapists can
kick people back out well before 25 days
if they see that it's an issue I think
if you were to amend it you would simply
amend A or B rather to say oh actually
it does it's it falls under a it
literally falls under a so if there's
something that like in my case the
physical therapist sees that even if you
are showing Improvement that you're
going to be limited because there is a
medical condition that a doctor needs to
look at
then they can and shall according to
this take you back to your doctor but I
think arbitrarily requiring that they
take you back to your doctor just
because uh you're not doing your
exercises is expensive and time
consuming for the patient and that's it
perfect timing thank you
our questions for representative Reed
I see no questions thank you okay thank
you
also signed up to testify Maggie Donahue
from NHA PTA
foreign
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is Maggie Donahue I'm a physical
therapist and I've been practicing in
the state for over 30 years I have
served previously on the board of Allied
Health Professions including the
physical therapy governing board and at
this point I am representing the New
Hampshire American Physical Therapy
Association members of this state I
wasn't going to speak because it seemed
to be doing okay but I want to just give
some very specific answers and
specifically representative Murphy the
reason the number doesn't work is that
it is totally arbitrary and it
completely would depend on the type of
condition so if I had a client in front
of me who had a total knee replacement
and I wasn't seeing some changes within
two weeks it would be an unethical move
on my part not to be referring them back
to the physician so on and on the other
hand if you have someone who's being
treated in a school situation where it's
a law it's definitely going to be a
long-term issue 25 days is a drop in the
bucket for how long they're going to be
having Physical Therapy Services so the
the number really does become arbitrary
as far as that's concerned that is why
we count on good ethical behavior on the
part of the physical therapist and why
the licensing board would provide that
that part of the job so hopefully that
would answer your question more
specifically I'd be also glad to have
answer any other questions anybody has
yes representative representative Palmer
sorry
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you for
taking my question so um just to preface
this um I I've worked in a rehab
hospital for years and was a primary
care doctor before that working a lot
with physical therapists and I've had a
bunch of surgeries and I would say one
of my concerns about this bill and I am
asking you if you have the same concern
as it says if if we leave it the way it
is it says that a
uh the physical therapist shall refer a
patient now when I was having problems
with my neck
um my physical therapist did not refer
me back he merely said you know this
isn't working
um and he talked to my primary care
doctor who referred me to a neurosurgeon
but the physical therapist did not
actually make a referral he just told
the doctor my doctor was going on that
might not fit this law that this the way
this law works because it wasn't
technically a referral by the physical
therapist it was simply a call and that
would be one of my concerns here is that
it you know it it makes the it's a
little too prescriptive aside from the
25 days does that is that do you share
that concern or um I I don't and in all
practicality is that that to me would be
making the referral you've you've it's
you've consulted out with the physician
or whoever the appropriate health care
provider is the the language does allow
for that sort of latitude
um and I would document that in my that
you know I've referred them I've talked
to the doc and referred oftentimes uh
depending on on what the situation is so
you know neck pain could be complicated
it could be I I may want the primary
care to make the decision about whether
they're going to the neurosurgeon versus
an orthopedic surgeon so
that's it behooves us to have the
communication and to me the referral
part is to having that communication
that goes with it
thank you representative Palmer
I'm Murphy thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I would agree with you
wholeheartedly that an arbitrary number
of 25 days is not necessarily an
appropriate number nor even the time
frame for many you know you've been
around for 30 years you have had
experience with this and therefore your
experience has taught you a lot
when this this concept came up I
remember testifying here over 30 years
ago when we went to a pt1 pt2
designation are you is that still in
effect right now no as a matter of fact
this compromise came out of the bill
that replaced that with direct
essentially direct access for physical
therapy in the state that was
approximately 15 years ago and I will
since being there for as part of that
this was a compromise with the medical
world at that point because pt2s
who were allowed to have direct access
after 30 days it was a hard number
Improvement or not had to refer had to
go back to the the client who did not
need a referral to see the physical
therapist after 30 days even if they
only needed one more visit and needed to
go back to the physician to get a
referral before Physical Therapy could
continue
so this was a compromise the 25 days
because the Physicians felt that
physical therapists still needed to have
a check-in and have that get back and
forth communication and that's really
not necessary anymore just a quick
follow-up follow-up sure thank you and I
would agree with you with that you have
a lot of experience you would fall into
the pt3 category probably there was one
I guess my concern is always going to be
you know somebody that is does not have
your experience that they're they have a
certain amount of you know
um hubris about their capabilities and
they don't refer a patient back in
because they don't have your experience
or maybe not the skill set to diagnose
another problem that may be present you
know knee pain is not always the knee it
could be the back you know that sort of
thing so I guess that's my concern about
the inexperienced therapist that may not
or may be able to refer back in so so
this is an informational point back back
then physical therapists were educated
at a bachelor's slash Master's level and
they are now at a clear clinical
doctorate level so there is
significantly more education
particularly around differential
diagnosis there is also a significant
increase in that time frame that their
their education around clinical
clinical experience and internships
so which is part and parcel of why all
of the states now allow direct access
for physical therapy in some form there
are still some that have some
limitations but so those go hand in hand
and the ones I would worry about the
most personally would be the ones who
get their degree as a clinical doctorate
and just open up down the street and
just don't do any
you know cooperation with other folks
who work with peers if they're most of
the time they are working with other
peers they're in it oftentimes in a
hospital or private practice and their
colleagues won't
for their own benefit would not do that
as a private has a I'm not retired but
as a private practice owner I can tell
you that that was not going to happen so
thank you
representative Nagel
well thank you Mr chairman thank you Ms
doctor no no I I actually was educated
back in the days of a bachelor's degree
so I wasn't sure if you took that step
or not um
I think my questions kind of the two
questions I asked earlier were actually
for you I kind of got that
um and um
I've been working with you folks for a
long time I'm just curious do you
believe you have the expertise to know
when it's time to ask for help from a
doctor and and put yourself at year one
year 30 or 15 whatever
um I I would my answer would be
unequivocally yes
um and part of that is based on
um recently
um well six years ago that our our
practice had hired a new grad and while
they may not have they were not
necessarily asking a doc at that point
they were very very concerned about
discussing with us as colleagues the the
office had seven therapists and it
discussing with us questions and and
concerns and if any of us had seen
something so there was always a teaching
moment as part of that and then about
three years ago we also had another
relatively new grad and the same
experience so there there really are
taught that and the bottom line is if
they are not able to make a change or
not able to
to discern something that really is
appropriate for physical therapy then
the training is they need to go on to
another health care provider
I'll set representative Weber
so I just want to go back to the issue
of the new practitioners
um am I right in thinking that just as a
new attorney is required ethically and
under the Licensing Laws to either
associate themselves educate themselves
find somebody else to work with if they
are in a situation that is beyond what
they are competent to do and they're the
person who judges
but the malpractice board is always
there over their shoulder so isn't it
true that just as in many licensed
professions
every physical therapist has that same
duty of what I would call collegiality
and consultation
at any time that they are out of their
depth
and so whether they are Consulting with
another physical therapist or
referring somebody to an MD
um they have that obligation from moment
one anyway is that not true that is that
is absolutely true and we also as part
of our Licensing Laws we all are
required to do a continuing education
and take courses on a regular basis it's
one of the good things that came out of
the PT's getting direct access prior to
the that with PT ones and pt2s part of
them did not have to do continuing
education now every physical therapist
has to do that continuing education on a
regular basis I thank you for that
question
other questions
seeing no other questions so thank you
very much you're welcome
I have no one else signed up to testify
on House Bill 188 does anyone else wish
to testify
seeing no one I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 188 and
I'll put open the public hearing on HB
554 FN and welcome my fellow London area
resident representative David langman
the prime sponsor good morning
representative Lundgren thankful
is that a pink card representative yes
if you could pass that up please
yeah
okay
here's the switch to finish circulating
sorry it stopped circulating the ones
for this bill earlier so it didn't feel
awesome
whenever you're ready representative
sorry
um I would like to especially thank
representative Merchant for his hard
work this past summer regarding
258 putting together the Forefront of uh
bringing to the Forefront the opioid
crisis
thank you I would also like to thank
representative Dr David Nagel for his
assistance on this bill
um before I get started I'd like to
share a brief story about
the opioid crisis I a woman that I had
met was suffering of back pain
I was prescribed opioids for for pain in
which she continued to take them for as
long as permissible
uh when those meds stopped working she
turned to heroin
she lost her family her business and
almost all her life
due to the grace of God she was able to
recover and get back with her family
the reason for the story is that she had
related to me had she known about
Alternative Care for back pain she would
have given it a try
HB 554 deals with evidence-based
treatment of chronic pain utilizing
Alternative Care
I believe the opioid crisis in large
part the consequence of the absence of
effective affordable Alternative Care
available to residents of New Hampshire
for the treatment of pain
every leading medical profession in this
country including the Joint Commission
on opioid abuse has recommended
Alternative Care is cost efficient
effective means of dealing with this
opioid crisis
Alternative Care is only performed by
duly licensed practitioners in the state
of New Hampshire
uh regarding Insurance there would be no
increase in Insurance costs as long as
these practitioners are already
prescribers for participating insurance
providers
this bill is giving the patients the
choice
whether the seek Alternative Care
or rather than prescribed medications
in closing
this bill
the reason this bill is necessary is due
to the over-reliance on Pharmaceuticals
specifically opioids
it is a condition that has been created
by over prescription and or abuse of
opioids within the medical community
I realize we do need to have medications
available but I also think that the
opportunity to
let the patient choose how they want to
get their care
and with that
I conclude my testimony because I know
you folks are really busy I've included
in the pack a unapproved amendment to
which is eliminating a few
sections in the bill
mainly on page
one
six and seven would be eliminated
on page
125-29 would be eliminated
um
on page two number 31 and eliminate yoga
therapy and replace it with physical
therapy
um and on page three
number five uh eliminate the yoga
therapy replace it with physical therapy
same page number three uh number nine uh
eliminating when awarded by health care
for practitioner
and that
would take care of the amendment
um
the letters that I sent around to are
from a couple patients of mine at uh
were have it heavily into opioids
uh and have
realized that their Alternative Care has
helped
um
and if I have
the ability to answer any questions I'd
be happy to right now thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for bringing this bill to us my question
is about the insurance coverage sections
in this bill and if those are
essentially the same as House Bill 303
which is in Commerce because I I know
that insurance coverage is a little bit
different than health policy so I was
curious if you were we would be willing
to remove the coverage section and defer
to the bill that's in Commerce
I I'd I'd be willing to look at that I
don't know about 303 so I'd have to look
at that but yes thank you thank you
other questions
yes uh representative Weber
thank you and and if you could I'm
having a little trouble meshing
this bill with what I'm seeing in the
current statutes
um I I add I see that you've
added
if if there are definitions and I
haven't looked them up in 126a
I think by uh this
by inserting after section 88 the
following new subdivision you are
getting rid of all the definitions that
are in the current
126 a colon 89 because they have the
same number
unless I'm in the wrong place
um and
then
so you're going from the definitions
that are already there which are
extensive just down to two
and then 126 a 90 appears to me to be to
replace in its entirely the controlled
prescription
health and safety program and I'm I'm
assuming that was not your intent and
this is perhaps a numbering
issue correct so but but that was not
your intent so we need to figure out
about the numbering is that correct
that'd be good okay thank you and I was
going to ask with your Indulgence yes
with with two different indulgences Mr
chairman if could you go over your your
quick walk through of the amendment
again and just tell us again which lines
it omits absolutely so thank you very
much and thank you for the
on page one uh it's eliminating six and
seven
under um
so the definition of health care
practitioner okay yep and then it's
eliminating uh number 25 through 29
at the bottom
okay
um and then on page two
it's eliminating on number 31 uh no
number 29 I'm sorry when ordered by
health care practitioner to treat
conditions
on line 29 of page two yeah
and then on uh
I'm not seeing those words on page okay
29 online 29. uh it's under section
three
no page two of the bill that I have is
um
oh it is it it's section three Roman
three and then it's then I have a
numeral two
okay and I'm in under that uh on number
29.
you see where it says ordered by health
care practitioner to treat conditions oh
I see yep okay thank you very much no no
problem eliminate that and on number 31
uh eliminate yoga therapy and replace it
with physical therapy
and and then
you okay yep okay
um on page three
number five
eliminate yoga therapy replace it with
physical therapy
and number nine
uh
eliminate when ordered by a health care
practitioner
and I think that's I think that's it
thank you very much no no problem at all
it's very helpful
representative
uh yes thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative
um
first of all I I have a an amendment
that came around but it I have one page
oh and it stops abruptly so I'm assuming
that there's more that we don't have or
at least that I don't have no I'm sorry
um
and while you're handing that to the
representative I will ask you another
question it appears that the and again I
may be wrong but it it appears that the
amendment adds rulemaking Authority
whereas the original bill as introduced
does not
include rulemaking Authority am I do I
see that correctly uh
you know I mean I I brought that to
um legislative Services okay and told
them that I wanted to have a few things
removed so I don't know how to answer
that okay I'll and and I'll have to
having just got the amendment I'll have
to read it more more thoroughly and do a
comparison
um in in uh just a a note of
appreciation to our committee researcher
Who provided a a wealth of information
in the memo here cool thank you
okay uh representative Palazzo
uh-huh thank you Mr Chen thank you for
taking my question uh uh I like the idea
of giving a choice to patients my
concern is uh so the main premise we are
trying to solve with some uh pain
management doesn't work there's a risk
that patience will turn to things like
heroin
but my concern is like it can happen
with this alternative chips too if
alternative pain management doesn't work
there's still a risk that patient
will turn to some still drugs and my
question is like is a mechanism to
quickly switch like if like Physical
Therapy doesn't work uh can a patient
quickly switch to
some
pharmaceutical options for pain
management thank you uh yes
the intent of the bill would be for the
treating physician to offer Alternative
Care
at a maybe a
10 visit
uh
treatment period
I'm just throwing that number out uh
and then
reporting back to the physician as to
how things are going
so yeah yes representative McLean thank
you Mr chair and uh thank you for taking
my question
um and my question is just kind of
stemming out of a little bit of
ignorance and trying to understand some
of the sausage making so the back end of
the bill deals a lot of with the
insurance and the coverage and those
kind of aspects of it so once you
accomplish that
um
is I'm I'm going back to the the
voluntary non-opioid directive form once
you incorporate the the coverage what is
what is the necessity for that and and
what would it look like um because once
you have the coverage I would assume
doctors would already be allowed to
um go forward with this so just trying
to put everything together
I'm sorry I really don't understand the
question so let me see if I can answer
it uh if possible so if if a patient is
referred to an another uh Alternative
Care and the coverage is uh provided by
the insurance that they have
they're obviously being treated
without having to pay for it other than
the normal deductible
did that answer that well no um so I
understand that because the the bill
introduces coverage so now things which
maybe were not covered in the past are
now covered so having accomplished that
in this bill
at the very front end of it is talking
about real rule making and the
establishment of a voluntary non-opioid
directive form
um so I'm just wondering why is the
establishment of that form necessary
what would it what what would it look
like having allowed for the coverage why
not just go forward why do you need to
have the rulemaking and the form so that
was my question
good question and I I think that that
probably should be worked on again with
other things that are popping up uh I'm
sorry
okay representative Weber
so and I'm I'm I apologize for sort of
nitpicking here but I think that there's
very good
Concepts behind this bill and I'm just
trying to pick out
how to deal with them
um
it the bill is about non-opi directives
and the first
paragraph just talks about treatment and
then it says the health care
practitioner shall honor the non-opioid
directive but you haven't talked about
the non-opioid directive yet
and if I'm understanding the
commissioner is supposed to adopt rules
uh
starting with a standard form but you
took the standard form out if I have
crossed out the right thing so I guess
my question is is there somewhere here
that I have missed that actually has the
words that create the non-opioid
directive before we start either
honoring it or making rules about it no
that okay you're right
thank you no I'm sorry
other questions
okay I'm seeing no other questions
thank you thank you representative
also signed up to testify on House Bill
554 is representative Tom Dolan also
from Londonderry
welcome representative Dolan
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
colleagues for hearing my testimony uh
this is I'll be very brief
uh and I want to give a special thanks
to Dr David Lundgren for following this
issue for now it seems like several
years trying to get it uh through the
various wickets this is very important
and I have uh some anecdotal information
about
things called narcam parties if you
haven't heard that term yet uh I'm not
sure how germane it is to this bill so
I'll I will
offer those that story if you so
requests but I won't uh go down that
road yet
uh I wanted to discuss uh testimony of
third third hand from uh
from Dr Paul Reynolds who is a 1978
graduate of West Point in a special
doctor of pain management he resides in
California so the the drive to come
testimony was a little long today so I'm
kind of subbing for that uh that
opportunity he wrote I passed around a
short article to his local Knights of
Columbus on this topic and I wanted to
read it to you
apparently people cannot avoid using
narcotics for longer than is good for
them
also apparently not if doctors are aware
of the prescribing drug drug habits can
be a major problem many of us can look
at our own medicine cabinets
and find
representative of you just reading the
testimony you've given us sir yeah we
can we can do that if you just want to
summarize and that would be you know
that'll be okay this the summary is that
that people have uh what I'll call
leftover pain medicine that's been
prescribed uh usually hanging around
their medicine cabinets and they end up
taking these medicines uh
inappropriately and long after the the
need for them is uh as subsided and what
this particular doctor has pointed out
to me is that
something I didn't realize is that the
body when it needs pain relief makes a
opioid-like substance and uh and kind of
takes care of itself so by taking these
opioid opioids it actually suppresses
the body's own ability to produce these
substances and therefore care for itself
and and
various things can happen like get it
getting hooked on these things and
having to deal with another doctor to
help wean them off or prescribe
something else and many folks are not
aware that over-the-counter
anti-inflammatories like Motrin Advil uh
Aleve and so forth do quite well to
relieve some of these pain instances so
we need to make sure the doctors focus a
little bit more on on those Solutions
rather than the the opioids that are
prescribed so uh with that Mr chairman I
I I'm open for questions and if you want
to hear about those Narcan parties I'm
prepared to talk to that too it showed
itself in the Manchester fire department
recently
Mr chairman if I may yeah my suggestion
is that I think that all the people on
this committee being the Health and
Human Services committee are aware that
there is a very severe crisis with
respect to opioids and that the the real
issue that we that I would want to hear
about is uh as is this bill suggestions
for remediating it rather than the
depths the crisis which we all know
about okay representative Nagel
um a little you kind of stole my thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
cloud you kind of stole my thunder I
think we really need to get back to what
the bill is about
um but I did have some important things
that I think need to Enlighten and I
just have a I'm curious do you know and
I'm I don't mean to put you on the spot
but I am
um do you know what the likelihood of
developing an addiction to
um
um opioids if you prescribe them for the
diagnosis of chronic pain I don't know
can I answer the question
and you know what the likelihood that
you're going to develop an addiction
when you're prescribed opioids for acute
pain no and do you know what the like
I'm not I'm not a physician it's all
right I I just think these are important
issues that I needed to raise because I
think we did lose focus thank you other
questions yes yes I can answer them what
time you see no other questions
okay thank you representative thank you
Mr chairman
say it and then exact
also signed up to testify this morning
is representative David love from Derry
foreign
Mr chair mining committee um thank you
for taking my testimony my name is
representative David love from Derry
Rockingham 13.
um I I just uh I'd like to give you some
personal experience you know back in my
late teens and early 20s uh I had uh
like three three knee reconstructions
and eventually ended up having a a knee
replaced but uh in the middle of that uh
there was a lot of back injuries because
I was nursing the knee and and what have
you everything was getting thrown off
and I was off of pain meds often uh I I
had two opioid addiction uh problems you
know in my in my in my life uh the the
their held to get to get off of
um
I've been a member of Alcoholics
Anonymous and Narcotics Anonymous for 32
years I've seen a lot of a lot of
families destroyed
um you know I've seen uh you know six
four 275 pound bikers were reduced to a
puddle of Tears uh because of this uh
I've seen doctors I've seen lawyers I've
seen CEOs uh you know coming coming out
of surgery and uh you know they they get
shut off from their opioids and uh the
next thing you know that they're chasing
things on the street and uh you know
it's it's a serious problem you know
um
to have a doctor you know uh just all
that's pretty much what this is in the
beginning was uh you know just just tell
people that you know there's alternative
therapies rather than going right to
opioids you know uh a couple years ago I
broke my back I fell out of a tree stand
while I was hunting it was an icy tree
stand it wasn't my brightest move
getting in it in the first place but but
uh you know I uh you know I went to the
hospital and and they prescribed opioids
for me you know the next day I went to a
an orthopedic surgeon and they gave me
stronger opioids you know and and having
my experience uh you know I know I
didn't didn't want to go down this road
uh I had to take them for a few days you
know but uh I uh I ended up going to my
chiropractor you know and um you know we
uh he did uh like electrical muscle
stimuli stimulation on the area that was
broken and uh he uh he gave me a a TENS
uh unit they call it and uh it's a thing
about the size of the pink cards you've
got there and uh you know runs on a nine
volt battery and uh gives you know small
areas of electrical muscle stimulation
trust me that that saved me for another
saved me from another opioid addiction
okay uh it's just a little Alternative
Care thing you know and if a if the
orthopedic surgeon had said you know
instead of the opioids try this you know
or I'll give you a few days worth of
opioids you know uh uh I would have been
a whole lot more comfortable you know I
don't ever want to be you know that that
that blubbering guy sitting there you
know crying and doing wanting to die you
know my my family uh you know deserting
me you know my my kids don't want me all
that kind of stuff that's that's the
kind of stuff that uh you know that
opioids do and uh anything we can do to
uh to to avoid that uh is is
I think we have to do it you know
naturally it gets tied up in all kinds
of complexities here you know who's
going to pay and all the rest of it but
uh I know for me that uh that little
TENS unit probably saved my insurance
company uh you know a a 30-day stay in a
rehab uh maybe some additional rehab uh
we're talking to over a hundred thousand
dollars you know for a hundred dollars
um you know uh we're not we're not
talking big big charges on the insurance
company here uh just an alternative to
sure to disaster thank you sir any
questions for representative love
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
going back to representative McLean's
question about
um section one of the bill or
sorry
two
um about the rulemaking and the advance
the non-opioid directive form
versus just having Insurance be mandated
um do you believe that we need the
directive form do you think that there's
a
um that there's value to having the
physician get in the habit of offering
um the non-opioids first
by having them have this form
as far as the form goes a lot of a lot
of medical practitioners now uh practice
cover you but medicine that a form like
this which would save
any lawsuits from from happening you
know you you know yes you have been
informed and here's your signature on it
um you know I think it's a great idea
thank you other questions
see your hand down here
other questions I see none okay thank
you representative love thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
uh former representative Jerry can Eric
foreign
welcome back to what I understand is
your former committee representative
yes thank you very much it is nice to be
back for the record Jerry Canuck
um former has been representative
and uh I also uh am a orthopedic spine
surgeon retired and uh serve as the
chair of the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board
um I'm going to deviate a bit from my
written testimony because I haven't
heard a lot of this stuff HB 554 is
essentially the same as HB 247 from 2021
which we was retained and then went to
interim study and I chaired the room
study subcommittee on that
um there are a lot of structural issues
that have already been brought up in
this hearing by representative Weber and
others a couple of things I would just
say and those uh the amendment I had a
chance to see it but eliminating yoga is
probably reasonable we had concerns
about nine licensed providers being
included as being mandated to be
reimbursed
um
regarding representative Leon's comment
I wouldn't recommend itl on this bill
and just going with HB 303 because I
think a policy committee should weigh in
on the importance of coverage
um not just leaving it to the people
that are looking at it as a business
because this is actually taking care of
people
um also the last thing is regarding the
conversation about does offering
coverage make a change providers are
often very slow to change and we saw how
long it took us to get providers to come
on board just dealing with the opioid
epidemic to begin with
um one important change in this bill is
on page one line ten when the word may
is used because in HP 247 the word shell
was used and that was a problem because
that then was directive and and
basically was legislating the practice
of medicine that's again page one line
ten and uh those of us who've been in
this committee for more than four years
remember a hour-long discussion of the
importance of May and shell on an elder
abuse bill so anyway but the real reason
I came though to testify in this was to
request that therapeutic cannabis be
added to the non-opioid alternatives for
the management of pain
I brought this up during the routine
Bill hearing but it didn't get in here
so again I serve as the chair of the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board that is composed of 10 medical
providers from different Specialties a
uh patient representative the head of
the medical director of HHS and also a
clinical representative from an ATC and
we're charged with the statutory
oversight of the medical aspects of the
therapeutic cannabis program
a cannabis has been shown to be a
therapeutic value in a number of
different things such as pain and PTSD
but the strongest evidence we have is
indeed in the management of chronic pain
there's a landmark study and by the
National Academy of Sciences in 2017
that concluded that there's substantial
evidence that cannabis is an effective
treatment for chronic pain in adults
period so it's got good evidence and the
key is it has a lot fewer risks than
opioids cannabis does not cause
respiratory depression that's the
mechanism of opioid overdose death
even a short course of opioids may lead
to dependence and addiction as many as
one in four people receiving
prescription opioids long term in a
primary care setting may become
dependent or even addicted to answer
that question that was sort of alluded
if he could start wrapping up and then
we'll ask may I have a little bit more
time than that I'm sorry I would not
have
how much do you think you'll need a
couple more minutes okay I'll do my best
can you make it one I'll make it as fast
as I can but um anyway the bottom line
is risk cannabis use disorder is very
small in therapeutic cannabis and
therapeutic cannabis we are using
cannabis at a low dose uh trying to get
a therapeutic effect without
intoxication because that is a side
effect which is not desirable we have in
the therapeutic cannabis program uh over
70 percent of our patients are certified
for treating pain with over 55 percent
certified for treating chronic pain
which allowed us allows them to lessen
the use of opioids 82 percent of our
therapeutic cannabis patients in New
Hampshire report that therapeutic
cannabis has allowed them to decrease
the use of prescription medications
I saw this in my own practice as well I
retired just before therapy cannabis
came in as a spine dock I saw a lot of
back pain and I saw patients I inherited
on opioids I tried to wean them down
rehab program everything couldn't get
them off when they went on therapeutic
cannabis they were able to go off they
did not need it anymore they wouldn't
kept up with some of these patients or
neighbors and this person was able to
just occasionally use a little bit of
cannabis when he had an episode of pain
and didn't fall back into that cycle of
dependency again
but one of the major barriers that our
therapeutic cannabis patients face is
affordability because it's not covered
by Insurance patients can access opioids
cheaply with all of their risks
and but they cannot afford that
therapeutic cannabis so some of them
resort to Black Market cannabis which
then they lose the safety of testing and
labeling and the counseling of the ATC
and that's of course the factors that
make it more expensive out of an ATC
the so I would really strongly urge the
addition of uh to HB 554 of therapeutic
cannabis is an alternative to opioids
given the proven effectiveness of
therapeutic cannabis and relieving
chronic pain and a risk profile which is
better than opioids and I have a little
list in the bottom of my testimony it
talks about where you might do this to
add therapeutic cannabis to the list of
things that are offered to be done and
then also for the coverage also
important to realize as written Medicaid
Medicare and VA are not included we
can't do anything about Medicare and VA
but we should include this for Medicaid
those are the people who are at least
likely to be able to afford therapeutic
cannabis and I'm glad to take any
questions thank you questions
I represented palazzov
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh would you be open
uh uh to open it up to provide the uh
write the list of uh paying
um
for pharmaceuticals that help with pain
management uh maybe it's not only uh
opioids or cannabioids we know there's
some over-the-counter pain management
that is not in these two categories
it's a specific need to single out uh
only cannabinoids in this amendment or
if we can open it to avoid the range
thinker
um I don't thank you very much I'm not
sure what needs to because in um lines
uh let's see where is it um
lines 15 to 17 on page one say by first
administering less addictive addictive
non-operated medications the the evil
with making a list in statute is that
the medicine changes statutory changes
of necessity go slowly so we should not
have a list of medications that we put
into statute I don't think but not a
non-opioid medications are included in
this and should be used prior to opioids
all I'm asking is that therapeutic
cannabis which would be a non-opioid
medication would be included in that
list
and but I mean to be explicitly included
because it's not something that would be
necessarily often thought of it's easy
to think of uh Tylenol and Naprosyn but
a lot of people won't think of
therapeutic cannabis
representative Weber
and isn't the reason for uh another
reason for including therapeutic
cannabis specifically as opposed to the
entire range of non-opioids that can
either be bought over the counter or
prescribed is that it's the one that is
still
up in the air is to its legal status and
and so it falls into a different
category than all the other
uh non-opioid medications all of which
are legal either over the counter and by
or by prescription and therefore don't
really need to be listed for exactly the
same reason you were talking about to
list one is to include another yes it's
that easy in the office to quickly write
a prescription for Motrin or something
like that
um it's a little more cumbersome to
certify a patient for therapeutic
cannabis it is something that we are
working in therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board to work on our provider
education to have more people understand
how it can be useful but also the other
reason to explicitly include it is those
other drugs are covered unless they're
over the counter therapeutic cannabis is
not and I think it should be
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
um
do you foresee
um complications and problems with
requiring the insurance companies to pay
for therapeutic cannabis when
as as the representative suggested
um
it's kind of in a gray area between
legal and non-legal and also because
it's not prescribed by a physician it's
um it comes to people through a
different mechanism so this is not a
reason to not pass a bill but do you
foresee
um complications and resistance to
actually doing this
yes of course I do it's that's perhaps
why it hasn't been done before and I'm
certain that Heidi Kroll will make
comments about this in just a few
moments but the bottom line is yes it is
a little bit of a dicey situation the
way I've seen the federal government
backing off from enforcement of federal
rules in terms of therapeutic cannabis
that's been clearly delineated by
President Biden but also by various
other directives and legal issues in
terms of Department of Justice so they
are not pushing to to enforce the
federal rules over so I think the state
might have the ability to request that
this be done
oh thank you representative I'm sorry
did you have a follow-up representation
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question representative knurk
who was unwittingly become my role model
for writing opinions
um
so you and I have had a lot of
discussions about these issues over the
years and and you know I've been
involved with working on these bills for
quite a while this bill itself is really
about non-pharmacologic options I think
a lot of what you raise is really
important but I'm wondering is there a
better strategy to doing this than
incorporating it within a
non-farmacologic bill
I sort of agree a little bit that's why
for example on the on the next one hb66
I chose not to weigh in because that was
purely non-pharmacologic but this one
again in um in lines 15 to 17 does still
make reference to other non-opioid
medications uh less addictive non-opioid
medications so that's the one thing that
made me think it was still reasonable to
attach it to this bill because it did
not appear to be purely
non-pharmacological but non-opioid
that's that was my reasoning
other questions
yes representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here uh it's nice to see you
um I'm wondering do you have any idea I
don't have an updated fiscal note for
this bill
um I'm just wondering what requiring
coverage of these
um alternative
therapies will how that will affect the
insurance rates for private insurance
payers in New Hampshire
do you have any idea oh well I would
defer on some of that too Miss Crowell
who can answer that probably better than
I but there is important to understand
how much impact we may have to be able
to decrease other costs
um there have been some good comments
made earlier uh the addiction issue and
Rehabilitation is a problem but also a
lot of the interventions we use when we
decide to do you know facet block
injections those aren't cheap tens units
aren't 100 bucks either they're a lot
more money than that so the if we can
save those kinds of costs that'd be fine
the patient that I alluded to that was
an old patient of mine uses very little
cannabis but it keeps them out of that
cycle he went through an enormous amount
of other interventions over the years
before he found that that actually gave
him this relief that he needed so there
there should be some real cost savings
clearly though if we do add Medicaid
that will increase in terms of a fiscal
note that would increase the state's
responsibility because that's from us
for the insurers whether there might be
some upward pressure on premiums I'm not
sure that there would be I think it
might be neutral or even positive
follow-up
are you too young for that
well I have a new baby so that's my
thing that's true
um
I wanted to ask you
sure
I'm sorry
I said representative Weber
my question is if you had a choice as I
think as I think we have
between
uh passing a bill
directing people's attention towards
using non-opioids first
and having a bill founder on the issue
of the legality and insurance coverage
and Medicaid coverage for therapeutic
cannabis which would you choose
I would actually choose neither I put a
severability clause in
I would think you know the severability
Clause that that if because this may
change but in in essence in terms of
your question I think it's a great
Devil's Advocate question I would choose
getting this passed without therapeutic
cannabis because it's important that
this be passed and and just as a quick
follow-up
would you recognize that usually
severability Clauses apply to whole
chunks and not
eliminating pieces here and there
um that's probably true but uh you know
I just don't know if it could be
structured that way or not I
yeah thank you but I wouldn't want it
the key is to get where you're getting
at I wouldn't want therapeutic cannabis
to torpedo this bill bottom line
another another question okay
representative uh Cushman thank you Mr
chairman I remember
um are you aware of any funds
um that have come from
lawsuits against those who have kind of
instigated and perpetuated the opioid
epidemic if there are any state funds
that maybe could be used to offset
the costs to either a private insurance
payers or maybe the cost if we were to
add it to Medicaid you know anything
about that I don't have any knowledge of
how the settlement funds are being used
uh
nor do I have any capability to direct
that
sure you know about a lot of things
going on so I just figured maybe you had
some understanding of how that all have
not did thank you
other questions
I'm seeing no other questions okay thank
you very much thank you good to see you
all again
also signed up to testify is Dr Mark
stagnone who is a chiropractor
you have three minutes sir
thank you Mr chairman
um I'd like to get back to the specifics
of this bill
uh and unfortunately it appears that
it's cut into my time uh I am the past
president of the New Hampshire
Chiropractic Association
I'm also from Londonderry as others here
in the room are have been in practice
for 36 years
I've been working on this legislation
and like it for over eight years now I
carry this
headline from the union leader from
January of 2014 with me as a reminder
when I first started testifying on this
type of legislation
I've worked with the governor's advisors
James Vara
um Marty Bolden
and Dave Myra on this uh this effort to
work on these this this crisis and I
know we don't have to talk about the
fact that it is a crisis and you won't
get any any stories for me I believe I
have some answers to Representatives
Weber Murphy uh and cushman's points
earlier as well if I'm given the chance
to uh to speak on that
you I distributed some information to
you
prior to one of them looks like this
studies on non-opioids and the other one
says non-pharmacologics that's just to
give you a sample of the research that
has been ongoing for years now
so oftentimes the question comes up you
know relative to the legitimacy of these
non-pharmacologic approaches and that's
just the sampling and and there's a
couple of these studies that have come
out of New Hampshire one out of
Dartmouth College which is used across
the country I won't go into the details
because it appears I don't have the time
and one actually was commissioned by
this legislature to look into
this this issue in some of our previous
attempts
these Studies have been looked at by
other major organizations for years
the the result that has come out of that
is that the CDC FDA The Institute of
medicine The Joint Commission the
American College of Physicians the
Veterans Administration and the Canadian
Medical Association have all strongly
encouraged the incorporation of these
non-pharmacologic procedures early key
early in the treatment of the patient
and so I think that speaks well to the
science that's behind this in the in in
the need and the necessity for it we've
lost years of valuable time in the state
when other states have moved ahead on
this this legislation as I understand it
is is modeled after legislation that's
been in place in West Virginia for
several years now and it it'll also give
some reason to the need for the
directive as it's combined with the
insurance which I'd like to you know
make sure that we enter to that
appropriately but we have we've lost a
lot of time and and I hope that we
finally are in a position where we can
move forward on this
um
these states was are seeing positive
changes uh and that's not it's Ohio
Vermont West Virginia Rhode Island
Oregon they've all passed legislation
that has moved this type of
um
uh action further forward and and really
it's it's about our patients
um and and it's about getting our
patients the adequate care they need
particularly The Chronic pain patient
um I'd like to just say a little
something about the insurance component
on this uh we've been working on this an
awful long time as well
um
so the the two key components is we've
kind of sat down and looked at this
and one pertains to the directive now
we're not trying to
determine what the directive
specifically looks like this is probably
going to be up to you people to decide
what's the best Avenue but all the
research has indicated and someone made
the comment about the physician it's not
wrapping up but yeah slow to change but
yes Mr chairman thank you but the
directive is to make sure that a
conversation takes place between the
patient and the physician that these
alternative options are available this
has not been happening as a whole
the insurance components of this
legislation and undoubtedly as we've
always seen in the past the insurance
lobbyists are going to come in and
they're going to raise some doubts as to
the the amount of research that's
available of the cost as as it has been
asked you know how much is this going to
raise costs there have been many cost
analysis done on this and they they all
support the savings that is provided but
one of the primary things that happens
in the state of New Hampshire that is
allowed to occur is these insurance
carriers
are allowed to sell a product that
includes Chiropractic services and
they'll say oh you know we we provide it
but then the patient arrives at our
office and their co-pays are 40 50 and
even last week 75 dollar co-pays when
our maximum that we're allowed to charge
is usually somewhere between 27 and 39
dollars for for spinal manipulation
these patients are are forced to first
of all the disillusion because they
think they have coverage when they show
up to our offices and then we we break
the news to them many of them return to
the primary care physicians go to back
to the pharmaceutical management because
they do not actually have Chiropractic
coverage it's a phantom benefit it
shouldn't be allowed to happen it's
deceitful
and it has been going on for years
so representative Weber relative to the
amendment uh the intent of that
amendment was to to clarify that there
was a section in there that made
reference to referred by a health care
practitioner sometimes the insurance
industry interprets that as being a
referral by a medical practitioner we
wanted to make sure that doesn't happen
representative Murphy relative to that
two elements of of this I think you're
actually asking about the two uh
relative to um
uh the conversation it's about the
conversation taking place the directive
between the The Physician and the
patient and this can be in whatever form
you want it to be yeah this I think that
that's the bill kind of says that Mr
chairman thank you thank you doctor
uh questions for Dr stagnone
uh yes representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so um I'm pretty
clear on the alternative treatments I'm
pretty clear on the
um Insurance elements
um on the directive side of this thing
you're starting to fill in some of the
pieces for me is it the intention of
this bill then that uh the
the form is voluntary but that the
communication of the form would be
mandatory and so that's what's driving
the conversation is that the intention
of the bill I I think so I think it's
it's not our intent
to
tell the medical practitioner how to run
his or her business
but one of the clear components of this
problem as we have sat down with the
governor's people and you read these
articles on this stuff is that the
patients as a whole are not aware that
some of these Alternatives exist and
they look to their physician for
guidance on these things and if they're
not being introduced to these other
avenues of care particularly early in
care very important
the Dartmouth study demonstrated a 55
reduction in opioid prescription writing
when the patient was introduced to
Chiropractic Care at an early point this
was based upon over thirteen thousand
New Hampshire
policyholders they redid the study in
2020 and included Connecticut and
they're still over 50 percent reduction
in opioid prescription when these
alternatives are introduced early in the
patients care and the directive is just
is a mechanism and we're not saying
specifically what that has to be but we
need to have some influence that these
conversations are taking place
representative Cushman
how's that okay yes representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question
in reference to your comments about high
deductibles and I think you called it
Phantom coverage which is interesting
description
um
is there something specific about
Chiropractic
um coverage
or is that kind of across the board for
many many medical services and would
this not Bill not really affect that not
to say that it's not an issue or a
problem but
I think what this bill does is and it
uses the ACA act to try to ensure that
there's consistency in a Level Playing
Field there that has not existed for us
in the Chiropractic profession there are
many instances and this is usually the
point in my testimony in years previous
where someone on the committee takes out
their own insurance card and they're
looking at it and they say well my
chiropractic co-pays thirty dollars and
that's not coincidental because the the
better policies
have the the copay that's the same as
the primary care physician but the
majority of the policies we see in our
offices have these what they call
specialist co-pays they they rate us as
Specialists but where from what I told
you earlier we're not being paid like
Specialists okay but we are in we're a
lot we're categorized with the
neurologists we're categorized with the
medical specialists who who's probably
getting three or four hundred dollars
for for a specialist visit that does not
pertain to us and that's the that's the
Dilemma that our patients have are
facing when they come into our offices
of the the look and we have to break the
news to them and some of them just they
say sorry I can't do this and that's and
that's the shame of this and it's been
what has allowed to perpetuate this over
such a long period of time in this state
when other states have actually taken
steps to it right address it thank you
another question representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question and this is an
important issue
um and I I the bill as you know is a lot
broader than Chiropractic and I really
appreciate your your um involvement in
this
um I've been practicing the state for 33
years and I know we're going to hear
testimony from the insurance companies
aft shortly but my observation it's all
about access to care and my observation
is that when I started here there was
substantially greater access to
chiropractic care than there is now
I'm curious if that's your observation
absolutely I've been in practice for 36
years when I started in practice the
typical patient would come in with the
80 20 policy there were there was there
was no there was no shell game as to
what your benefits were going to be you
uh you paid 20 percent the insurance
company colored 20 covered 80 percent
and what evolved over time was this you
know this whole specialist co-pay where
they they decided that they could move
certain professions into different
categories and and in doing so for the
Chiropractic profession and and even
they did they did some of this with the
physical therapists as well where they
could then enhance uh the the patient
responsibility and what they did
basically was they enhanced it to the
point where the patient's fully
responsible for all their Chiropractic
benefits and that the better policies
still have the the co-pays same as the
primary care physician and we feel that
that's a fair you know that's a fair
environment in which the practice but
more and more of these companies using
this strategy to enhance their profits
thank you other questions
saying no other questions
okay thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman
also signed up to speak this morning is
Laura alazam from Londonderry also
welcome
I always like to see Londonderry people
up here
everybody thank you for having me here
today I'm not a doctor or medical
professional I'm just a patient and I'm
going to read so I can go fast and not
take up any more of your time than I
have to
um as a result of an accident over a
decade ago I developed chronic pain in
my back and neck which I successfully
relieved with alternative therapy IT
addresses the pain and lack of Mobility
directly but it also works on correcting
the underlying cause of my pain to
forestall Future issues
although painkillers were always an
option I have been and remain unwilling
to start down this path my reluctance
stems from watching my 23 year old
daughter descend in a few short years
from a straight a high school student to
unemployable and homeless all because of
an addiction to opioids you've heard
more than enough of these stories I
won't tell you any more about that but
it's clear that we can't prohibit our
way out of this societal nightmare
there's always going to be another drug
to fill the demand for a cheap high like
xylazine which is in the paper this
morning it's an animal tranquilizer
that's causing a spike in overdose dose
deaths locally
it's apparently commercially available
for 10 or 15 dollars a pound
instead of that we need to change the
expectations and habits of patience as
representative Cushman alluded to
earlier
by presenting proven reliable
alternative therapies as the preferred
primary option to address pain
HB 554 presents an opportunity or an
off-ramp from a road that too often
leads to abuse and addiction it will
preserve Lives real lives that are parts
of real families like mine
by affording patients a range of
practical proven alternatives to opioids
for pain management I ask that you
please recommend hb554 ought to pass
thank you are you taking any questions
or if anyone has a question anyone have
any questions
okay I see none questions thank you
also signed up to speak is Heidi quo
from America's health insurance plans
try to keep it around three minutes if
you can
I will do my best um good morning
members of the committee
um my name is Heidi Kroll I work at
Gallagher callahanna gartrell and I'm
here today representing ahip which is
America's health insurance plans we are
the trade Association for the health
insurance carriers
um here in New Hampshire
um we did sign in in opposition to the
bill our concerns we don't take any
position on section one of the bill our
concerns really
um have to do with starting in section
two and on which are all of the
insurance coverage sections
um which you know often those sections
or bills with those types of sections
have gone to the house Commerce
Committee
um
so I was I was happy to hear a comment
earlier by the Vice chair that that
maybe those should be
um kind of set aside from the bill
um I did want to say that um health
insurance carriers do provide we do
support alternative treatment options
um both alternative medication options
as well as alternative
non-medicaid options or pharmaceutical
uh pharmacological options
um and we do in fact cover
Chiropractic Care physical therapy
occupational therapy tens units
are all covered under standard plans
there's coverage for acupuncture and gym
membership which could include yoga and
other forms of exercise vary by plan
and massage is covered if it's part of a
Cairo PT or OT Services
carriers do offer different plans with
different different covered benefits
which do result in different premiums
and that's so that members can choose
the plan that best meets their needs and
their budget
um
we have been working very closely on
these issues with a variety of parties
over the years and you've heard this
morning that they're just this year
alone there are two other bills that are
have similar topic
or subject matter one is House Bill 303
on the prime sponsor is representative
Nagel his is relative to insurance
coverage for Pain Management Services
that was sent to the house Commerce
Committee and there is a lot of
similarities starting with section two
on in this bill with House Bill 303
yesterday representative Nagel requested
that the committee retain that bill and
as you'll hear at your next hearing on
House Bill 66 which is establishing us
currently establishing a study
commission but I think it will be
changed to a study committee to try to
look more closely at all of the issues
that are kind of wrapped into House Bill
303 and we are we've had conversations
with representative Nagel and
representative Merchant and we're
um in total agreement to participate in
those uh that steady committee efforts
and try to
um make some progress I think in terms
of what people are looking for in terms
of integrated care around a variety of
services
that could be offered to patients we do
want them to have options and all access
to Alternatives we don't want to see
people
getting addicted to opioids we
understand the costs that are associated
with that you can start wrapping up
please sure yes
um the only other thing I think I was
going to mention
um is just a reminder for people I think
former representative might have
mentioned this
um any of these mandates that do get
passed only will apply to about 25
percent of the insurance Marketplace
um namely the in individual and employer
sponsored fully insured products so a
mandate such as you see in House Bill
554 would not apply to Medicaid Medicare
it's not going to apply to self-funded
employer coverage which is becoming a
bigger and bigger share of the
marketplace so government entities as
well as large and even now medium-sized
employers are offering self-funded plans
um
military coverage of course uninsured so
I just want to make people aware that
this does Target a relatively narrow
sliver of the insurance Market
um
and I'll I think I'll stop there I know
I've hit time and I'll happy to answer
any questions
um thank you thank you
yes representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um I always learned something new every
time you talk so I really appreciate
that
um I'm curious and I should know the
answer to this but I don't
um is workers compensation would they be
included in in this I don't believe so
no thank you
other questions
yes representative McLean thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so
um you say you already cover a lot of
this already so what what's what's new
in this from you say it's a narrow brand
just 25 but for that 25 what does it add
relative to what's already covered
right um well I was you know as an
example
um we do we do have concerns I know yoga
therapy was um discussed earlier
um there's reference
um in here to
um Tai Chi and trying to find where
where it is but some other
um kind of like what I'll call exercise
programs like that and so
um that's an example of where um
insurance is really meant uh for medical
providers that that are licensed and
credentialed so that's an example of a
concern
um there's also language in here about
um uh treatments uh including but not
limited to
um and then there's a you know laundry
list of of coverage so uh part of our
question is well what else besides
what's listed here what's in the
including two
um and there's reference to 20 visits
um
per event and so I think when you start
doing 20 visits and it's per covered
service and then you have an unknown
number of services so it's things like
that that are um just concern Us in
terms of not quite sure what in fact we
would be asked under this to cover
beyond what I mentioned um that we are
covering already follow-up
representative so you're so your primary
concern aside from the licensure issue
is just that there you feel that it's
being overly specific and it's taking
away flexibility that the primary
concern you're saying then well I think
it's overly broad with language like
including but not limited to
representative Palmer
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question my question is about
evidence-based now at the beginning the
prime sponsor talked about
evidence-based treatments
um I'm curious about what criteria your
group uses to decide what when the
evidence base is it reaches the level
where it should be covered by insurance
is it some degree of what Medicare
accepts or or is there a specific
process
um so first of all I'll say that each
each health insurance carrier has a
panel of an independent panel of medical
experts that are continuously looking at
um all forms of coverage not just
specific to this and so that's
um they're always you know looking at
new evidence that's coming along new
treatments new medications whatever the
case may be
um and looking at the consensus around
that and kind of you know um
what a coverage would be appropriate
Medicare is certainly a benchmark
standard that's looked to by commercial
coverage so I think it's it's a
um but you're right in both of those
thank you
other questions
seeing no other questions thank you
thank you very much
and the final press I'm aware of who has
signed up for Testimony this morning on
HB 554 is Sabrina Dunn Dunlap
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm Sabrina Dunlap director of
government relations for Anthem and
um I won't repeat what Heidi said I just
wanted to touch on a few key points if
you could stay within three minutes
that'd be great oh yes yeah
um just really quickly so we were part
of a group that came together last
summer I think it was HB 247 a very
similar bill and
um we are very interested in continuing
those conversations we've talked to
representative Nigel and Merchant and
others about the study commission or
committee that could come out of this
and I think that is very useful because
what we ran into is we do cover
Chiropractic acupuncture
um a bunch of the services listed in
here but one of the issues we ran into
last summer we discovered is I think
there's an issue around provider
education in terms of recommending these
alternative treatments
um and so I don't think this bill solves
that problem
so and Heidi touched on when you get
into other services like yoga Tai Chi
they're not licensed by the state uh
they're not regulated so it becomes a
practical problem in terms of trying to
cover those services and
one other issue I just wanted to mention
Mr signo brought up this issue of
co-pays
um and you really get into benefit
design which gets complicated especially
when so many people have coverage under
employer-sponsored erisa plans which
Again State mandates don't touch those
and a lot of benefit design issues are
determined by the employers who who have
those plans
um
so anyway I think I hit all the points
and thank you for the opportunity to
speak today happy to take questions
thank you yes representative Nagel I
mean um representative Shapiro I'm sorry
thank you Mr chairman
I wonder if you could comment about
um
we heard from a previous person who
testified about coverage for a
therapeutic cannabis and if you could
comment about the advisability or
practicability practical practicality of
insurance companies actually doing that
that is a good question and I was
thinking earlier when it came up I
actually don't know the answer I'm happy
to get back to you my initial response
is I do think it gets complicated
because of
the way cannabis is treated by state and
federal government I think there are
probably challenges there
other questions
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman just a brief question does
Anthem
um do you guys cover naturopathic
Services yes
other questions
I'm seeing no other questions okay thank
you very much
I have no one I have no one else signed
up to testify on this bill does anyone
else wish to testify on House Bill 554.
seeing no one I am going to close the
public hearing and house bill 554.
uh before we move on to the um before I
open the hearing on House Bill 66
representative king would you like to
speak
thank you chairman McDonald now that
everybody unfortunately one just left
everybody was here uh from the committee
that was here yesterday I'd like to take
a moment to apologize to the committee
to the general public and to an
individual named Eric Liu who was uh
testifying yesterday during executive
session I uh referred to his title in a
derogatory way which was beneath my
office and I felt shamed the moment I
said it and I felt embarrassed the last
24 hours so
um I I'd like to extend that apology and
um with the Lord's help I'll never make
that mistake again so thank you again
for giving me this time thank you very
much representative King
okay uh with that I will open the public
hearing on House Bill 66 and recognize
our own representative Merchant who is
the Prime sponsor
foreign
don't forget to do a pink card please oh
my God
you can do it after you testify if you
want
representative Nagle already gave us one
yeah I was good you didn't have an angel
can we just add his my name to his
and you'll only get three minutes
for the record my name is Gary Merchant
I represent Sullivan County District Six
which is the towns of Claremont in
Croydon
and as you heard earlier today through
testimonial previous bill
this is a complex issue
and
haven't worked through this on House
Bill 247 actually worked with
representative Nagel
Dr Nagel at a time and also
representative Koval to try to find ways
to and also with the insurance industry
trying to find ways to try to take the
complexity and make it more simplistic
what we learned along the journey with a
multi-disciplinary group of people
which is comprised of Physicians nurse
practitioners
acupuncturists natural paths patients
the insurance industry is how complex
this issue really is
so
in saying that what we all agree to it
should be a patient-centered
multi approach
and right now we don't have that and
we're trying to figure out how to get
the patient back in the middle and let
the patient Drive the Bus pain is
fundamentally very subjective
it's really determined by the patient
and therefore we have to have multiple
ways to work for the patient and let
them Drive the Bus
House Bill 303 which representative
Nagel put in that corresponded with him
went to Commerce and yesterday you heard
that when you have a commission
sometimes it becomes problematic to have
it staffed it's a lot easier to work
with the committee than a commission so
I have an amendment to
submit to the
to the committee itself
what I want to say at this point in time
is
the intent also with what representative
Lundgren was also part of that work
group is I think there's a lot of
sincere interests by multiple parties to
try to find a way to come up with a
solution or at least solutions to how we
can help patients deal with chronic pain
or acute pain and historically
have worked in the world of Pharmacy
a lot of it was done through opiates
which had its own unintended
consequences we're dealing with today
so the intent of this bill is to really
pull the stakeholders together through a
study committee and say what are the
barriers what are the complex issues are
the solutions that we could work with
there's no easy answer
but I think if we can put us all in the
same room and talk about this including
the patients
we have at least a shot at trying to
figure out how to unravel the knot
and saying that I want to turn over to
Dr Nagel representative Nagel because
he's done a lot of work as well and I
wanted him to take some of my time as
the chairman if that's at all possible
sure perhaps he's supposed to wipe down
the mic
thank you representative Merchant thank
you Mr chairman thank you everybody
um
he already did the third part of what I
wanted to do I wanted to tell you who I
am and why this is important
um you kind of heard some of it you kind
of missed a lot of it in earlier
testimony
representative I'm sorry Gary we're
buddies now
um he he explained why a commissions or
committee is important um this has been
a 33-year journey for me
um my practice is I'm a doc my practice
is I work with people with complex
disabilities very early on in my career
I came to the understanding that pain is
a part of that and in almost everybody
and what I was struck with was what a
poor job we did of handling that
managing that and
um and I I just at that time in my life
I realized this is a vacuum this is a
hole something needs to be done so I
began a 33-year career in advocacy
um and I'm I don't want to go over this
testimony in any great detail this is a
partial list of what I've done but I
started advocating for the right rates
of people and pain
in a nutshell I represent 66 million
Americans who suffer from chronic pain I
I represent 1.5 million Americans are in
hospice or palliative care at any moment
I represent all the people the 50
million people that's kind of doubles
but any 50 million that are going to get
surgery they're going to get
perioperative post-operative care and I
represent the untoward numbers of people
that are going to suffer severe moderate
to severe pain after acute injury all
their stories are really important we
heard some earlier today but there's a
lot more than that as part of that I
initiate and I wrote all the state
policies on opioid prescribing
I wrote this book that deals with
everything we're going to be talking
about this morning and that proud to say
that was sold on four continents so it I
think it has value
I also chaired the NFL players
associations
um pain management best practices
committee for the last seven years and
I'm the lead author of our guide to
managing pain and performance in
athletes but
everything that we did is about what
we're talking about today so what we're
talking about the model exists
we've learned a lot about the opioid
crisis today and we've learned nothing
it's been said a lot everybody wants to
blame somebody for it I blame I mean
we're happy to talk in detail about that
with anybody because I've been involved
with it since day one but I think what
we need to get away from is Magic Bullet
thinking we always think that this drug
or that surgery or this Chiropractic
career that our yoga treatment is going
to cure everything and we know that
that's not true it may be for
individuals but not as a group we need
to get away from that thinking and that
concerns me also about cannabis that
we're going to get into that same Magic
Bullet thinking we've sewn in Western
literature since the 1980s that
patient-centered comprehensive
integrative multimodality care is What
patients need in eastern and thought
we've known that for over 2 000 years if
you go to an Eastern practitioner
they're not just going to stick a needle
in you or give you an herb or tell you
to take up Karate or something they're
going to give you all of that and
they've been doing that for 2 000 years
successfully and we have not and that's
a problem and I'm not gonna I'll leave
it up to your imaginations as to why
that is
this cost is over 650 million dollars
per year by not addressing these issues
and according to the Institute of
medicine so it's a big Financial issue I
know money is really important here
um anyways with that said these are
guides that we're going to go over Page
by page right now if you don't mind I
was actually involved in the authorship
of both of these as the CDC guide to
opioid prescribing this is the latest
version that came out about three months
ago and the interagency task for some
Department of Health and Human Services
created this there's actually a quote in
my um my testimony from the CDC guide
that I think you should read and I'm not
going to bore you by reading it now
basically what we have now
um really I want to just talk about
crazies for a second then I'll wrap up
um we talk about an opioid crisis I will
tell you we have a crisis of over
prescription we simultaneously have a
person prices of under prescription we
have an epidemic of costly
poorly evidence-based procedures that we
pay for and we can talk about
evidence-based somebody asked that
question earlier you can ask me a
question if you want
um we have a crisis of a costly and
efficient Health Care System we have a
crisis of dependency where we force
people into dependency and my goal is to
empower people with the tools they need
to manage this difficult problem all
this is fueled the Mental Health crisis
and my biggest concern is we have a
crisis of patient abandonment and that
really bothers me a lot I run a
non-profit patient advocacy group or we
deal with people that are dealing with
the we call the opioid refugees the
people that have been abandoned by this
system to basically go to the streets
for their drugs or whatever because they
can't get them from a Health Care system
that doesn't seem to care anymore
um anyways there are three models on why
this works the VA has put together a
model that they show integrative
comprehensive management works and saves
money the University of Vermont has a
pilot program that is now a real program
because they demonstrated all these cost
savings already we want to figure out
how to do the same and and Gary
representative Gary Merchant doctor
representative Gary Merchant and I um
both believe that we think that by
putting Minds in a room together we can
solve problems a lot better than just
throwing things out and unfortunately to
date that's really what's happened
um I'm a little sad that my bill got
tied into
um 247 only because they're really very
different concepts they should have been
kept separate I want to finish with a
story
um
so we met with players on injured
reserve a couple months ago and um we
already know how they feel about team
doctors so
um we asked the players they're all in
their mid-20s um you know how did you do
you trust your team doctor and the
answer was an expletive that began with
the letter F no and in a very loud
language and and then that didn't
surprise me I already knew the answer to
that but then one of them said I don't
trust any doctor and I looked at him and
I said what and he goes I don't trust
any doctor he says they're they're
basically more interested in what they
can do for me how much they can make
money off of me how much they're
dependent on a corporate structure that
reimburses them and basically forces
them into an Interventional model an
insurance company that reimburses all
this and he was not talking about him as
a professional athlete he was talking
about his family and experiences that
he'd had so then I asked him well we
know that every NFL player has pain 100
of the time so I go how do you manage
your pain he then proceeded to write
bill h303 for me I mean everything he
said that he uses is an HB 303 and I
looked at him I said you know you're
lucky and he says why is that he goes
you're an elite athlete you can get all
that stuff guess what I work with
retired players more than active players
and I asked him guess what the minute
you retire you're going to have access
to none of that and and he just looks at
me and you know it was really a
difficult moment for all of us but um
we've heard we need to make a big
difference not just for elite athletes
but for people as a whole and I will
answer any questions anybody has
okay representative Weber
thank you both for your testimony and
and maybe you could stay because oh
you're doing the amendment that was one
of my questions so I won't have to ask
for a follow-up but
um
my
question is
very much in the where do we go from
here
uh line
my understanding is that 303 has been
retained and that's happened already we
have before us here two bills uh one of
which is
a study committee so
um
or one of which
has very good intentions behind it but
huge drafting issues in it
so I guess my my first question would be
are you recommending that we retain that
one as well and pass the
um
study Commission representative Weber
thank you for the question yes it's my
recommendation I think also with
represent nego that we would retain that
bill here in this committee to
ultimately look at 303 look at 554 and
then through the study committee to look
at and saying how can either emeld them
together or make them more workable so
it takes care of a lot of the questions
you're asking about and that is how it's
extracted the language within it but
more importantly I think the critical
part to it is getting the stakeholders
in a room particularly insurance
carriers buying into what we're saying
because if we don't have their support
ultimately it's probably not going to go
anywhere
just to follow up on that um the best
second best day of my life was when the
insurance reps you know said that they
wanted to do this obviously the first
was when I got married but that was the
second best so I mean you know bringing
people together is really important to
solve a problem
um as far as I'm concerned um
the re what brought us together was the
flaws of what was 247 and all those
flaws are still in that I would love to
take credit for 303 I wrote that with
Cindy Steinberg from the U.S pain
foundation so it's based on National
thinking it's not based on local
thinking I also wanted to point out that
I forgot to earlier if you look in the
list of organizations that support what
we're doing the alliance to advance
comprehensive integrative pain
management of which I'm a founding
member um has been looking at this issue
for a while it represents 92
organizations Nationwide including
insurance companies so we're all trying
to work together to solve this problem
there's flaws with 303 I'm not that
brilliant there's flaws at 247. this is
the way I think to fix those flaws
and can I have one follow-up follow-up
and would you agree with me that as
frustrating as it is after all this time
and all these studies uh to have yet
another study and not a bill
it's more important to get it done right
yes
I don't know if you can put that on the
record but yeah thank you I think one of
the things we've seen in the past
is we've done things sort of in
different silos and I think we're
pulling together the various silos the
various members and stakeholders in each
Silo to talk about things across the
silos to come up with something that's
probably more workable and again back to
the same thing is it really needs to be
patient centered pain is subjective it's
really up to the patient to determine
what's working for them versus someone
trying to make an artificial guess at
what does work so by keeping it patients
centered
with all of us is important too that we
include patients in what we talk to and
what are the things that they see as
barriers that they run into that we need
to consider as the committee
thank you representative Weber
and I have one last question which is
about the amendment which turns the
commission into a committee
um unlike the approach that we saw
yesterday you have chosen not to
enumerate
the the people who are going to be
consulted by the committee but are you
convinced because I have seen committees
like this work really well when there is
buy-in from
all of the stakeholders are used
sufficiently convinced that the
stakeholders will buy into this process
and work with you despite the fact of
not being enumerated as committee
members
the reason I took it from a commission
to a committee I did not realize we sort
of had a hybrid
which came to my attention with
representative Pearson to list them yes
I believe the
stakeholders we've talked to are
definitely involved with being part of
the process if you think in your opinion
we should list them within the bill I
bill and one last follow-up and then I
promise I will stop that as well so
we've been working on this issue for 30
years we have a collaborative a lot of
the people of our Coalition aren't even
here today because they testified on
303.
um but we have acupuncturists we have
psych we have nursing um
um we have Chiropractic I don't consider
it I mean everybody and we've been part
of this discussion together for a long
time I think this would formalize it um
and thanks to
representative Merchant for putting that
together because um he he started that
and and for a final follow-up and and is
isn't it true that by not using the
hybrid form but and not enumerating
people you avoid the problem that we
heard referenced yesterday where one
Association is favored over another
Association this permits you to gather
all the people who have an interest
and then figure out how to include them
in your structure going forward
so it's probably a better
structure than the hybrid or the
commission I would agree with that thank
you I also don't want to forget we Myra
Christopher wrote the forward in my book
she's one of my favorite people on the
planet and Myra always insisted that a
patient or two or three or four be
involved in this process and it's
important that they be involved as well
we don't want to eliminate them because
they know a lot more about this than we
do representative Palmer
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um this is a sort of a question about
who's going to be involved so one of the
I just had a meeting with the American
college Physicians and one of the
concerns is their their primary goal is
taking care of patients and in the last
years what's happened is that doctors
have really and and other providers have
been really embattled and struggling and
so they've been trying to put a you know
a real emphasis on making sure that the
people who are providing the care to
patients are healthy and happy and
um so my question here is for example in
in and I don't not sure in New Hampshire
because I practice only in Vermont
though I'm here
um
with the prescription monitoring issue
we we have a new form and a whole
procedure we need to follow whenever we
prescribe
um opiates and that has led to a
decrease in opiate prescription for in
from in most cases for better in some
cases for worse that you alluded to I
just want to make sure that on this
committee you have that kind of input so
whatever comes out of it is going to
make it
not a cumbersome process for people to
access whatever modalities they're
trying to prescribe
thank you for the question
representative Palmer as it happens I
also serve on the prescription drug
monitoring program as advisory Council
so yes we will have linkage between that
and what we're doing today
other questions can I answer that as
well sure you're going to get a
long-winded answer and we can do that as
a sidebar I I there's a whole chapter in
my book on what you just asked
um
I'm not convinced that we as doctors
really have our patients best interests
in mind anymore and I'd be happy to
discuss that in Greater deal if you wish
and the whole purpose of everything that
we're doing is to try to bring
everything back to the patient away from
the corporate structure away from
um you know the comp the computer
because my patients tell me that they
don't think their Doctors Care that NFL
athlete said they don't care and it's
usually because of things that are
extraneous to them that's changed all
that and I that's why patients are
important I think we've overemphasized
the problem with opioids and that's a
sidebar discussion too I I'm bothered by
that because I I know of a we have a
list we call it our suicide watch of
patients that have been died because of
being abandoned
um and and those are important issues to
me thank you
other questions
representative McKay
thank you Mr
chair my background is in the mental
health field
I'll make this very short I had some
kind of minor surgery at frankly had
forgotten what it was uh they gave me
these pills I took two
one and two and stopped because I was
looking forward to the next one
now in the mental health field that to
me that smells like addiction
and so nobody told me to do anything I
just did what I thought was important I
went to Concord police station and put
those pills in that container even
though one of my neighbors said those
are worth 75 dollars a piece if you want
to sell them I didn't in other words
what I'm saying is that it's very
important to involve the patient which
we all are pretty much in this kind of
terrible addiction and to uh what I did
was very simple
but I think it probably stopped
something that could have been quite
serious so I just wanted to add that on
okay thank you go ahead representative
Merchant if I could if I'll open
resident McKay
um one of the things that we'd be
looking for on the study committee is
members from this committee are people
within the house that serve and help
walk through it if you be willing to be
part of that I'd be more than glad to
thank you
I'm thrilled to death you said that
that's another sidebar discussion
um we don't manage prescriptions well
and I think we need to do a lot better
job and I that should be part of our
discussion too
thank you other questions
saying no other questions okay thank you
gentlemen thanks thank you
I have no one signed up to testify on
this bill other than these two gentlemen
does anyone else wish to testify on HB
66.
if not I am going to if not I am going
to close the public hearing on hb66 and
open the public hearing on HB 500
and recognize the prime sponsor
representative hacken Phillips
oh just
we just did 66.
500.
okay
good morning representative how are you
good morning Mr chair
um
for the record my name is representative
Mary hacken Phillips I represent Grafton
County District 12 which covers Hanover
and lime
if the committee is ready I'll dive in
sure go ahead so I'm here to introduce
HB 500 relative to prescribing opioids
via Telehealth medicine
I'm here actually today because a number
of constituents who live in our district
that I also serve with representative
Murphy our practicing surgeons at dhmc
in Lebanon and recently
I think it was November they brought to
my attention an upcoming change in the
law that they were going to be required
um to change their current practices and
my understanding is that in January of
this year coinciding with the expiration
of some federal federal
flexibility in regulations related to
Telehealth medicine
that these Physicians were um
being asked to change their normal
practice of prescribing opioids either
new or refill prescriptions of any
scheduled two to four opioid drugs
um just a side note here that's limited
exception for Methadone hydrochloride
and I'll let the experts behind me speak
to that issue
but this change in prescription for New
Hampshire patients affected specifically
telephone and audio visual Telehealth
visits
um with their patients to accommodate a
change in New Hampshire law specifically
RSA 329 colon 1-d related to Physicians
and surgeons and
326-b colon 2 which is related to
nursing this change in law required any
new or refill opioid script to be issued
with an in-person visit with that
patient regardless if the provider had
already established an in-person
relationship with that patient
so to be clear this in-person visit
requirement is a much more restrictive
practice than the past and then our
current New England Neighbors in Vermont
Massachusetts and Maine are practicing
this is bringing this to your attention
because it's adversely affecting our
state's Healthcare systems
so to try to give you an example of what
I'm talking about let's just walk
through a scenario say you've recently
had a major surgery it required you to
be hospitalized for 24 to 30 hours after
that surgery
the good news is that on post-op day two
you are doing well and you're going to
be discharged to go home and conval us
you spend several hours headed home with
the help of your friends or loved ones
and you finally get in your own bed to
rest
but late that night you wake up with
some pain
the issue is that the powerful drugs
used to during your surgery and during
your stay at the hospital are wearing
off
you told yourself and your doctor that
you didn't believe you would need an
opioid to go home when you were
discharged but now that you're there
things have changed and you realize you
need help
you call your doctor's emergency line to
ask for a small script to get you
through the next few days of surgical
recovery before in under current law
um
your doctor will be able to you know
your doctor who just saw you two or
three days before would be able to give
a call to your local 24-hour pharmacy
call on that script and get you that
small prescription
but under this new law your doctor would
have to tell you that you'll have to
return to the hospital and see her in
clinic which may actually be the
following week on a specific day that
that surgeon has Clinic
it may not be right away
this is less than ideal because you have
no more time to take off of work your
friends and loved ones can't help you
with the trip back and frankly gas money
is really short
so meanwhile your pain is not stopping
and it's getting worse so you're gonna
scramble you may seek urgent help in an
ER or
um which first of all we all know that
ERS are overloaded right now just
anecdotally
or you may call your primary care
physician and attempt to get an
appointment there but you may also know
anecdotally that getting in to see a
primary care physician could be more
than a Year's wait at this time
alternatively your provider your health
care physician or nurse May plan ahead
and determine to go against the last two
decades or more of academic research in
the field of studying over prescribing
of opioids and the good work over the
past decade of combating the opioid
pandemic and preemptively discharge
patient patients with an opioid script
and the off chance that they need these
pills once they are discharged
you know thereby flooding our state with
additional opioids that we all know is
not needed
um so this example shows you how current
law creates a very desperate situation
that comes that is completely avoidable
and this bill attempts to do a little
something to try to correct that
situation
I'm happy to walk you through the uh one
page of language here in the bill if the
committee would like so but before I do
that I want to get out of the way so
that the committee can hear from the
experts in this matter
my job to my job today is to briefly
explain a few points of why this
legislation is needed
the first
um
there's a problem with the current law
is economic
we understand requiring patients to
travel
another time is expensive when many
folks already don't have the cash in
their Banks bank accounts to make an
extra trip to see their doctors when
we're talking about confronting soaring
Energy prices and inflationary pressures
and other economic tough times it's
really forcing patients to do without
critical critical pain relief and this
is really cruel
current law also puts some of New
Hampshire's largest employers at a
competitive disadvantage with their
Vermont Massachusetts and Maine
competitors who I'm sorry their peers
who prescribe opioids via Telehealth
when we all know that the marketplace
right now in the healthcare is extremely
tight
this point cannot be understated this is
a competitive disadvantage for our state
the next problem with this current law
is logistic requiring people to travel
again across the state multiple hours
when business can be conducted safely
over the telephone or with an audio
visual
Telehealth medicine visit is just silly
I mean frankly extra chips mean extra
emissions extra costs we don't
logistically we're crowding the roads
and creating more problem that's really
needed
the third issue is Administrative
efficiency requiring an already short
Workforce to duplicate efforts and find
another time for an in-person visit puts
additional stress on a system that's
already experiencing historic challenges
wait times are already extremely a lot
long to just get that first appointment
so let's help our providers out at a
time when burnout is high and stress on
the system is coming out stressing the
system coming out of the corner of
coronavirus pandemic is already at an
all-time high let's do something about
you know a small thing that can help out
the system
fourth Uh current law is problematic
because it's overly paternalistic we
know that there are already Federal and
professional guard rails in place to
make prescribing opioids safe
via Telehealth medicine emits a deeply
concerning opioid pandemic
New Hampshire does not need to pile on
extra red tape and regulations here it
is safely regulated
fifth the problem is a human one
our current law is going to make all of
us suffer whether you're the patient
seeking the actual new or a refill
prescription of opioids or you're
someone else
seeking care with your primary care
physician or in the ER trying to get
emergency care or at some other access
point in a Health Care system
the bottleneck this law creates is a
strain of resources and precious
provider time it's going to adversely
affect our system in all of us who take
part of it
people are going to suffer needlessly
and for the delay and care and sometimes
bypass the care altogether because of
the current law
so what you have today before you HB 5
is a fix on what I believe to be an
inadvertent hiccup in current Telehealth
law
the drafted language was a result of DHS
coordination and Leadership thanks to
Matthew Hood and his team
and others of course I believe this
legislation will make a positive impact
on our state so before I turn over the
hearing to my co-sponsor if he plans to
speak I'm not sure and other
um folks here from Dartmouth Hitchcock
and the healthcare profession
um I'd like to just share that I've
separately spoken to stakeholders at the
New Hampshire Medical Society and the
New Hampshire Psychiatric Society who
are both groups are on board in support
of this legislation and I believe are
submitting online testimony testimony to
that effect
so at this time I'd like to urge the
committee to OTP HB 500 thank you for
your time and consideration and I'm
happy to answer any questions a question
just representative Weber
thank you so now turning to the bill
I've heard a lot of very great policy
but I need to understand how this bill
furthers it and I'm just looking at the
language of the bill first of all on
line one there is a reference to
out-of-state Physicians and I don't see
anything in the bill about out-of-state
Physicians nor does it nor is it
inserted in a place in the statute that
is restricted to out-of-state Physicians
so I if I may ask the first question why
is that there my understanding is that
the chapter RSA 329 colon 1 slash D
regulates
tahov medicine for surgeons and
Physicians I think that the sub chapter
out of state Physicians is just part of
the order that it comes down to the RSA
um so to answer your question I don't
think it only has to do with
out-of-state positions it creates any
physician it creates effect to any
physician that serves in the state of
New Hampshire for a patient in New
Hampshire
okay so I will
may I have a follow-up I guess this is
perhaps um one of the details that
office of legislative Services may have
overlooked
you've answered my my question in that
you wanted to apply to everybody
so we just need to investigate the
drafting uh then
for the follow-up
um
all what you're doing is what you're
doing
the number one talks about what
Physicians are going to do number two
uh talks about the use of telemedicine
for nursing
and
um
and it's just the Physicians and the
nurses that you're discussing here is
that correct yes I think those are the
two major pieces of legislation that
currently control opioid prescriptions
through Telehealth medicine so this is
where we've concentrated the effort on
those two groups essentially and one
final question
thank you
and is this not an issue of uh nurse
practitioners or advanced practice
nurses of any sort
uh because I I know that we've often had
to revise four sections or five sections
and they may just not prescribe this
kind of thing within their scope of
practice and only if you know so um I
can answer this question in two steps
representative thank you for the
question first um if you'll see
subsection B and C under
um paragraph two
um
I'm sorry B also speaks to the APRN
issue that you just brought up but only
out of state
yes
um and then that may go back to the
previous concern you had about the out
of state my understanding is that this
legislation is geared for in-state
provider Healthcare Providers both
Physicians
surgeons and nurses so um I will again I
put that under the first concern that we
spoke to
um thank you and then I guess I would
like to just follow up with the you know
finish that thought and say I am not an
expert in the field of medicine I
I'm an attorney by trade so
um I will defer the more ins and outs
scientific technical questions to the
folks who are going to come after me
today and speak to the issue thank you
other questions yes representative
Shapiro
thank people
is your microphone on
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking this question
um I'm having a little trouble reading
this bill in the context of the RSA so I
may be missing something but much of the
bolded text has to do with
um seems to me maybe I don't understand
it making it unlawful for Methadone to
be prescribed by telemedicine is that
your intention so my understanding is
that there is a that the methadone and
substance use disorder category is
separate from this legislation so
there's a special carve out for that so
it's not included it's my understanding
but we will have folks here who can
speak to those
um ins and outs yeah who follow me
representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for bringing this to us
um
as I was trying to look at this section
um it looks it looks to me I'm not an
attorney but reading through here it
appears that there's already that
section that you reference which is
um 12d that already provides for all of
the non-substance use disorder opioid
uses yeah so that's you're I think you
are correct that that's why it's an
exception from this legislation it's
already there's already special language
for that
um
medicinal prescription
representative Weber
so my might the explanation be as one
who was been involved with this
paragraph for longer than I care to
think about
that the existing Roman 3
uh disallows
prescription of tele of any two through
four drug So currently it's disallowed
um and this allows
everything but methadone and drops
the other things down to paragraph four
which is the allowance part which is not
perhaps terribly clear to begin with but
might be clearer afterwards
your belief is my belief thank you thank
you
other questions yes representative
Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
the part that's referring to the
methadone is really controlled by
federal law versus state law
so that's what you're touching upon I
think but in saying that federal law
through the emergency
orders currently does allow for a
existing patient to be treated with
methadone through Telehealth would you
be opposed by adding that language as
long as it doesn't conflict with the
federal law because many times for a lot
of the patients who are being treated
with methadone
they have traveled a long ways which you
brought it before so would you be
opposed to trying to tailor this to what
the federal law does allow to allow for
people who are getting methadone not not
to do patient but existing patients to
be able to at that point in time not
have to go all the way back two hours
away from zero doc
thank you representative Merchant for
the question I'm gonna defer that
response to the experts at Dartmouth
Hitchcock who are here today to testify
about that issue
so the question just representative
Nagel
um thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question
um
this has been an entertaining discussion
because access to care is really
important
um I when I looked at this bill of media
that tell I mean I work with people with
addiction I work with people in pain
that methadone thing left off the page
at me and our ability to prescribe that
for people with addictions who live 200
miles away from me is a huge issue I is
it possible just get rid of that
language in this bill altogether if it's
covered somewhere else
what
do you have to change the average say oh
I don't mean that what what they've
added
the language they've added to to take
that out of what you've added I don't
understand why that's added again I I
will defer to the folks that Dartmouth
Health who are here today who helped
craft the language of this
um draft so
um they have far more expertise and
understanding than I do of the issue so
I will I appreciate that thank you
other questions
seeing no other questions okay thank you
also signed up to speak is
representative representative Jim Murphy
I'll come to the other side of the table
representative Murphy
and again we can if we can do it in
three minutes that'd be great
thank you Mr chairman and on committee
um uh for the record my name is Jim
Murphy I represent Grafton 12 which is
Hanover and lime along with um Mary Hack
and Phillips and I'm here today to
support
um the bill I co-sponsored with um
representative hacking Phillips uh house
bill 500. so there's a a couple
questions I would I think have to be
answered first I know we have uh um Mr
Matthew Hood from DH as well as one of
the providers from DH that deals with it
specifically but
um one of my first
um uh issues with this bill is I think
it's somewhat of a misnomer the bill
basically says prescribing opioids the
bill really is allowing the prescription
of schedule two to four that's a much
broader and much more important in many
ways
um the other thing I would mention is
that Telehealth is here to stay
Telehealth is grown substantially in the
past 10 years for instance at Dartmouth
Hitchcock in the Telehealth section I
was talking to a doctor um
um
Uh Kevin Curtis I'm sorry uh the other
day and I've known him for a while he
told me that prior to the pandemic this
is amazing we had only 12 outpatient
visits per day in the Telehealth Clinic
during the peak of the pandemic that
went up to 2600 a day outpatient visits
it now currently is plateaued around
five to seven hundred so Telehealth is
here to stay and I would say it now
represents about 10 to 15 percent of the
um tell of the outpatient visits at
Dartmouth at this point in time but this
is not a bill about Telehealth I would
also say it's not just a bill about
opioids it's about schedule two to four
which is much broader and to me this
bill and I know we have experts behind
me that deal with uh on a regular basis
you know taking care of these patients
um this is really a patient this is a
bill to help support patients in very
difficult situations
um
when I talked to Dr Curtis the other day
we what is going on right now is that we
were able to schedule
two to four drugs via Telehealth during
the emergency
um uh period of time that will be lifted
I believe on May 10th or 11th something
I thank you when that happens we revert
back to the rule whereby you are not
allowed to prescribe by Telehealth
scheduled two to four that is not just
opioids when have we ever had a bill or
a policy change come before us we've
actually done the um the trial the
clinical trial before it when I asked Dr
Curtis what happened during the last
past few years when they were allowed to
prescribe opioids in other medications
they actually had absolutely no problems
whatsoever so to me that means that has
already been tried and true
process in the in in management of these
patients they had absolutely no issues
whatsoever
um and one of the other questions that
just came up about methadone my inter my
understanding about methadone is a
schedule 2 drug and it has been carved
out specifically by the feds because
this is what they call a a drug that can
prescribed only through Sam s-a-m-h-s-a
which is Substance Abuse and Mental
Health Service Administration and only
by
otps which are opioid treatment programs
now I'm not sure that could be
incorporated into Telehealth I would
leave that to the folks from DH to tell
me that if that could happen or not but
having said that I would like to speak
mostly to the clinical side of this
which I think is critically important
this is not just opioid treatment in
management it's chronic pain for many
many variety of issues
um representative if you could sure so
the ones that I would bring up would be
palliative care imagine somebody at home
you know under palliative care need an
opioids or any other medications imagine
the Adolescent at home with ADHD that is
on Adderall they don't have to interrupt
a full day of school or work for the mom
or dad they could actually have a
Telehealth visit with Mom or Dad present
with them
um post-op pain changes as was mentioned
by representative hacken Phillips you
could send a patient home and they tell
you because you could put drugs into
their surgical sites that keep them
comfortable for 48 hours but when they
get discharged they then have an
escalation of pain that can change
from a personal experience I can't tell
you how many times I would walk through
an orthopedic you know waiting room
tripping over wheelchairs crutches
Walkers even having patients come from
the nursing homes on on
um on Gurney's through with a uh through
an ambulance which is very costly
they don't have to come to the hospital
to have this taken care of we can
schedule all of these drugs via
Telehealth and I think it would be very
very helpful this is a basically a
patient-centered caring bill and I would
support this Bill thank you thank you
questions representative Weber
thank you so to summarize wouldn't it
be fair to say
that what this bill does in the end is
remove the restrictions that were the
cost of passing any telemedicine bill at
all back prior to the pandemic because
we now know that we can do it we can do
it safely and it provides much better
patient care and patient access so the
barriers that were created as the price
of getting any telemedicine started are
now not necessary because of our
experience with it I couldn't have said
it any better when else do we ever have
a clinical trial that precedes the
institution of a policy thank you
other questions
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman
um
I'm hung up on the language about
methadone okay and early in the um early
in the pandemic we actually passed a
Telehealth bill which was um focused
part of it was focused on um enhancing
mat medically assisted treatment in um
underserved areas in the doorways and
specifically in in jails where there had
been a court case where that that people
were entitled to get that kind of
treatment in jails so we passed a bill
allowing
um those medications to be prescribed to
tell you the truth I'm not absolutely
certain that if if methadone was
included or if it was just Suboxone
maybe there's somebody else here who who
knows the answer you took the words out
of my mouth representative but
maybe you know the answer but I might
but my question is this bill
you
I assume that you wouldn't want to do
anything to
um to limit those kinds of services for
people and I assume that this bill is
not intending to do that is that true
that's true and I would I would defer to
the folks from DH who deal with that
much more than I do about exactly how to
manage that going forward
thank you
other questions
okay
I'm sorry okay representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thanks for you
made me feel a lot better
um with one exception
um and I'm curious about I I still have
to get back to the methadone restriction
um in pain management methadone is an
awesome drug for refractory neuropathic
pain it certainly has a lot of limits
um
um a lot of our patients live a long
distance from where we go you don't need
to be in one of those settings to
prescribe it for pain but you need a lot
of expertise with an established patient
I would still want to be able to
prescribe that by telemedicine and I'm
concerned that this bill takes that out
and I agree with you and I don't
disagree with the the your intention
with that
um but I think that was actually carried
forward from the previous statute but I
can leave that to again Mr hood and
folks from DH to try to explain that
better and any remedies for this going
forward because I agree with you
wholeheartedly thanks yeah other
questions
seeing no other questions okay thank you
I have one editorial comment on the side
I am I hear about the patient's
disappointment with Medical Care in
general I agree with that the sentiment
that I hear it regularly but I would
argue that we have a health we do not
have a health care crisis in this
country or in the state we have a health
care access and Administration crisis
and so I I honestly when I push back a
little bit because providers in this
state give us the best care possible
they are sometimes hackled by outside
forces that we can't contribute which
trickle down to Patient sentiment
regarding the profession thank you thank
you
okay also signed up to testify is
Meredith McMartin from Dartmouth health
can I come up with my colleague
Matthew Hood okay sure if you want to
votes come up that's fine
yeah okay sure go ahead I was just
saying like I'll speak to the corporate
perspective of that representative
Dayton was concerned about uh Dr
McMurray can speak to the patient and
provider perspective I think yeah I
think you both asked for five minutes uh
if you can shorten that a bit uh each
that would be great thank you
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Matthew Hood vice president of
government relations at Dartmouth Health
uh pleased to be here today I think
um representative Murphy answered a
number of the questions that were raised
in the first go-around
um so I will just acknowledge that this
committee has heard a number of bills uh
over the past number of sessions with
respect to Telehealth generally as well
as Telehealth prescribing in particular
and I wanted to thank you for your
taking the lead the legislature for
taking the lead in the sud space
what the what the law currently provides
is that providers cannot prescribe
schedule two through schedule four drugs
via telemedicine with the exception of
sud treatment
carved out of that exception is
methadone we have not changed that
provision
not for any intentional intentionality
to carve that out it's already been
excluded Dartmouth health does not
provide methadone services in our
through our doorway but we're not
opposed to that unless from a very
pragmatic perspective representative
it's going to kill the bill in which
case I would be opposed to to carving
that out
that being said
the during the pandemic the
administrative arms acted as well right
so on the state level there was an
emergency order that enabled the
provision of Health Care via Telehealth
all modes of health care which included
prescribing that has expired that's
going away you also had the Federal
Public Health Emergency that enabled
flexibilities that has been noted before
is going to go away May 11th so what
this bill does
I view it as enabling the flexibilities
that the public health emergencies
provided with respect to Telehealth in
general
and prescribing via Telehealth in
particular
um
there are a range of healthcare services
that would be impacted by this
the utilization of prescribing via
Telehealth and keep in mind medications
for many of these health conditions are
controlled substances regulated by the
DEA that's what we're talking about so I
think representative Murphy talked about
schedule two stimulants for ADHD
behavioral health issues were raised Dr
McMartin is going to speak to palliative
care and oncology space I think
representative Murphy in personal
experience in post-surgical pain
management has raised that as well
we know Telehealth is an effective mode
of care delivery it's also an essential
tool
to address the current imbalance between
demand and capacity
moreover IT addresses the inequity of
care options in a rural region frankly
it's a whole lot harder to get to an
in-person visit in Northern New England
than it is to get to a visit via
Telehealth we've seen that through the
pandemic and we've seen patient
preference for the continuation of
Telehealth
in closing of my portion I would just
note three additional pieces I think
actually and I wanted to thank
representative hacken Phillips for
introducing the legislation the laws of
the states that surround us Maine
Massachusetts and Vermont enable
prescribing via Telehealth if licensed
then in the state and DEA registered the
DEA is set to prescribe issue Guidance
with respect to prescribing both in the
sud space and in Telehealth prescribing
in general if we want to take advantage
of we expect those to be flexibilities
our state law has to accommodate that
too because you have to go to the most
restrictive law
and finally safeguards and I'm going to
leave behind a piece for you uh are a
new that exists with respect to opioid
prescribing concerns generally
remain in the prescribing via Telehealth
space and you'll see the list of
safeguards that exist or I'm happy to
speak to them with their questions thank
you very much Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you do you want to both
speak and then we'll I defer to you of
course Mr chair uh why don't you go
ahead doctor and then we'll we'll take
questions from for both of you thank you
my name is Meredith McMartin I'm a
palliative care physician at Dartmouth
Hitchcock Medical Center I'm an
assistant professor of medicine in the
Dartmouth Institute for health policy
and clinical practice at the Geisel
School of Medicine and I'm the medical
director of the Jack Burns Center for
palliative and hospice care very glad to
be speaking here on behalf of our
palliative care team and our patients
and their families in support of this
bill
for those who may not be familiar with
it palliative care is a medical
specialty focused on improving the
quality of life for patients with
serious or life-limiting illness and
their families and Care Partners
our interdisciplinary team provides
support with care planning medical
decision making navigating the emotional
challenges that come with serious
illness and often the prescribing of
medications such as opioids to relieve
the physical suffering from Pain and
other symptoms
at the beginning of the covid-19
pandemic and Public Health Emergency our
Outpatient Clinic converted nearly
overnight to a primarily Telehealth
model
a significant proportion of our
outpatients continue to receive their
Care by Telehealth by their own choice
for our team we want to be able to
prescribe control Controlled Substances
to patients like ours as a matter of
equity and patient choice
to speak to the matter of equity we know
that rural residents have far less
Access to Health Care in general than
Urban residents and palliative care is
unfortunately no exception to this
during the public health emergency we
were able to provide care including the
prescribing of necessary medications for
patients who are too sick to travel long
distances safely or who are unable to
get transportation for a variety of
reasons
we surveyed Telehealth patients in our
clinic and found that on average our
patients drive 70 miles round trip to
get care with us that's the average
and many identified the cost of travel
and the logistics of Transportation as
major barriers to in-person visits
as an example consider one of our real
patients who has end stage emphysema and
metastatic lung cancer she requires
intensive and high-level respiratory
support to help her lungs function and
has extensive painful tumors throughout
her bones
during the public health emergency our
team prescribed opioids to safely and
effectively manage her pain and
shortness of breath because of the
severity of her lung condition traveling
quite distances is actually quite
dangerous for her and she's currently
without someone locally who can continue
these prescriptions she lives 90 minutes
away from our clinic and she is
suffering
we believe that all patients with
serious illness deserve access to the
high quality medical care that's more
readily available to patients who live
in bigger population centers who are
financially secure and otherwise
well-resourced
regarding the matter of patient choice I
think our state's reputation for
individual autonomy speaks for itself
palliative care is a specialty which
puts the goals and values of each
patient at the very center of our work
we believe that patients should get
medical care that is consistent with
those goals and values whether it's
aimed at Living longer maintaining
physical function or focusing on the
quality of their life it became clear to
US during the public health emergency
that allowing patients to receive
palliative care in the manner of their
choosing was a powerful way to honor
patient choice and autonomy in our
survey of palliative care outpatients
more than half expressed a preference to
continue to receive palliative care by
Telehealth in a state which values
individual choice We believe that
patients in their medical team should
have all the possible tools available to
them so that they may decide for
themselves how best to receive medical
treatment whether it's palliative care
or has been discussed by others Cancer
Care treatment of behavioral health
issues or post-operative care
in summary our section of palliative
medicine at dhmc is in full support of
this bill as a way to help ensure that
the sickest and most vulnerable of our
neighbors and patients are able to
access medical care that is consistent
with their values and alleviates their
suffering thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak on about this bill
and happy to answer questions thank you
questions representative Weber
thank you so much thank you Mr chair and
thank you both for being here and
welcome back
former representative Hood
um
as a matter of drafting
is there any are we creating any
problems
other than issues of political will if
we remove the method on
exception because
if there's no reason to keep the method
on exception in there and we've heard
several people say it might be nice to
get it out of there
uh then one might be able to also
eliminate one section of the bill and
instead of saying uh it shall be illegal
except for that which is illegal except
for this thing which is still illegal
which is really clunky drafting then
then we could actually say it shall be
legal to prescribe and because we got
here because we had to put the
provisions in in order to get anything
passed so is it okay to take out the
method on
special treatment and let that simply be
covered by whatever the DEA requires or
are we creating more problems for
ourselves by taking it out than leaving
it in so thank you for the question
representative I would reiterate my
first answer which is that yes it would
be more neat neater to remove an
exception from an exception
that makes sense that being said
we don't have a position we Dartmouth
Health don't have a position on this
provision we kept it as it was in the
current statute my objection would be
the political one
um and so I would just reiterate that
thank you
other questions
representative Merchant
how to tell which hands
thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking the question
the way I read it right now the
physician can prescribed schedules two
through four as long as they're not an
opiate
according to the statute number two by
May
um would you again
given the fact that there's a 34-day
limit on a controlled drug today that
does limit as far as any kind of abuse
potential in three with methadone
I know you politically were just where
you're going uh representative or
honorable but Senator Matthew thank you
okay is that
haven't been in the world of Pharmacy
and seeing patients travel several hours
to get to a position for methadone
treatments
um I know politically is probably a
concern which I understand would you be
opposed again to following the Federal
Regulations which do allow
for a patient who's an existing patient
to have Telehealth visits
sorry so I heard three questions I think
I wanted to answer them correctly my
understanding is that we're again
talking about schedule two through four
Controlled Substances both opioid-based
and non-opioid-based according to this
if I could if you go back and look at
the statute which you referenced here
um
329 1D 3.
prescribing of non-opiate control
classified drugs schedule three through
four by me to Telehealth shall be
limited
to those prescribers so what we're
trying to do really is add the opiates
but but I'm sorry but can I so
I view
Roman 4 A1
the prescribing of a non-opioid control
drug classified in schedule two through
four by means of telemedicine shall be
limited to prescribers as defined
section B1 the prescribing of an opioid
control drug classified in schedule two
through four by means of telemedicine
shall be limited to prescribers
I think it's both I'm not sure we're
disagreeing here
um to the point it's an artfully done in
the statute and then it listed twice but
I think the point I'm trying to make is
that right now
positions or any prescriber can actually
prescribe two through four for
non-opiate drugs all we're trying to do
is add the opiates
yeah um I'll tell you I'd have to
confirm while I'm having a conversation
trying to help I'm trying to help on the
political side that we already allow for
it we're just trying to take a certain
class of drugs within the substance
tweet two and four we're just trying to
include it comprehensively yeah the idea
is to expand it to both opioid base and
non-opioid base which we may already
will allow
um for schedule two through four and
would you be opposed again if I try to
work on the bill
to amend it to allow for Methadone to be
following the federal guidelines for
State guidelines I'm just going to
repeat what I've said and I'm not trying
to be hard I just I'm not endorsing nor
opposing to that um uh and finally no we
have to comply with we have to comply
with the stricter of the federal versus
state law so I would have zero objection
following DEA
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you both for being
here
um I'm hoping you can help me with my
confusion last year
um the the it was signed in House Bill
503 was signed into law which addressed
prescribing prescribed prescriptions
over Telehealth including opioids that
removed a lot of different requirements
about what face-to-face interaction was
required and referred all of this to 329
colon 1d1 and 326-b to
12a basically that's saying that
Telehealth is Telehealth and Physicians
who are doing Telehealth can do
Telehealth and the same for APR for
advanced practice nurses right now I see
in the statutes around the controlled
Drug Act and prohibited acts that
section
328-b216b permits the prescription
through Telehealth of schedule two
through four drugs and as I'm looking at
this it looks like this was already
addressed last year and I'm trying to
understand why there's a problem right
now for Dartmouth when in my eyes the
statute's already reading as solving the
problem
see thank you for the question if if I
may
because the section that we're proposing
be revised prohibits that so even if
it's enabled in one section it prohibits
prescribing via Telehealth schedule two
through four unless it's for sud care
follow-up in my reading it's a section
right directly below that that permits
that there's the part that permits the
the substance use disorder and then
there's the other if that one section
um
that's
so if you actually go back to the
controlled Drug Act that seems to be the
one that prohibits it if we simply
remove this the specific card at carve
out for substance use disorders would
that solve our problem in a much more
elegant Way by removing the language
that says
I'm trying to find
so there's nothing there's nothing I
can't find anything in the controlled
Drug Act that limits the prescription of
opioids and schedule two this opioids or
non-opioids in schedule two through four
that lemon said only to substance use
disorder can I answer General
I have a point of order for the chair or
a question for the chair and that is
because it sounds to me very much like
all of us who have been speaking or
trying to deal in the same way or trying
to achieve the same end but we're trying
to wrestle with a really mightily
difficult drafting muddle uh based on
historical drafting would this not be a
bill that might Avail itself very well
to the appointment of a subcommittee
specifically to draft a proper Amendment
or failing a subcommittee a small number
of people to work with the folks from
Dartmouth Health to draft
cleaner language
if I'm if I'm understanding that we're
all trying to provide the maximum
flexibility yes representative Leon
thank you my statement is I think that
this is already covered under law I
don't know if we can find out if we can
find out and get some information on
that and then if it's necessary then we
can look to a subcommittee or an ad talk
but it in my reading I think it was
addressed so I'd like to send this to
the committee researcher just for advice
if Mr chair if I could it's in my
wheelhouse um represent a merchant thank
you Mr chair the challenge here is that
the federal law and the state law now
conflict
and the federal law has become more
lenient but the state law has not caught
up with the federal law
so a lot of things are referencing
representatively on is in fact true
based upon the state law but we need to
fix the state law to allow for the
flexibility the federal law does not
allow for and that's kind of where we're
caught into it a lot of times what
happens is at least in the world of
Pharmacy we have a tendency to put into
state law what's at the federal level
and my understanding is why we do that
is that at the state level we cannot
enforce federal law but we can enforce
state law federal enforces federal law
not state law so we have a tendency to
mirror the two together but right now
they're not together
representative Leon
uh
I'll just I'll remain confused and we
can discuss this later at some point
okay
okay any other discussion uh any other
questions for these two folks
I am seeing none
okay thank you both thank you
the final person who has signed up to
testify uh on this bill is Jim Monahan
from New Hampshire APRN Association
thank you
thank you Mr chairman this is my first
trip to HHS this year so good morning I
think in fact the last time I was here I
worked with representative Leon on 503
so I'll address that a bit if that's
okay but I am here today I have a number
of clients that are impacted by this
bill and I wanted to come to the public
hearing uh to hear a little more words
coming home so the pink card I turned in
does Chekhov support but I do think we
want to get it right because of the
um because we want to get it right and I
have at least three clients that are
impacted by this uh that would include
the Community Mental Health Centers
which are involved in the prescribing of
schedule two through four for mental
health conditions
um as well as the advance registered
nurse practitioners section two of the
bill opens up their statute and then I
also represent the um the opioid
treatment programs which are the
methadone clinics in New Hampshire where
most of the uh the methadone-ish most of
the use of methadone probably takes
place
so uh I understand it's that there's
some confusion over the language and a
lot of it is the the need to align uh uh
State statutes uh with the federal
statutes uh and as representative
Merchant observed those are changing and
becoming more lenient probably on a
different piece of legislation we should
deal with that alignment um but I want
to call the committee's detection right
now to section three of the bill uh
which is the effective date and it's 60
days after passage while I know it is
challenging I don't think it would be
impossible to address this issue before
May 11th so we don't end up in a
situation where thousands of people that
are involved in having their drugs
prescribed through Telehealth would have
to have a subsequent in-person follow-up
I don't think anyone wants to see that
happen but there is a there is a
misalignment of the public health
emergency ending in May and these
statutes so my hope is we get it perfect
in the house so when the Senate gets it
they just say great and we can move it
along as quickly as possible and I'm
committed to working with folks from DH
in the department of that a few things
that came up uh today that I uh would
want to work with the committee on uh
the first question out of the box was
the reference to out-of-state Physicians
I think it just doesn't belong there
it's unnecessary it's a drafting error
you can't find that reference in the in
the section would be my observation on
that
um another and and I have had great
conversations with the folks with with
Courtney from Dartmouth to get this
right as well and it might not be a
problem but it's representative Merchant
as well aware and others perhaps as well
that for the opioid treatment providers
they technically don't prescribe
methadone they order it so you go to the
clinic
and you are evaluated by a physician or
APRN and they order Methadone for you
you don't get a prescription and go to a
pharmacist for what I don't know is does
anyone prescribe in that manner or is it
all ordered and perhaps others would
understand that Ben and I but I think
representative Merchant's going to jump
right in and answer that question for me
it's changing
I'm sorry federal law that's governing a
lot of this is under change yes
right
um and so
um I think getting that
um how we deal with uh methadone
exception we want it to align with
federal law uh but we need to be careful
in the way we use the word prescribing
so we don't mistakenly prevent the
methadone clinics from you know doing
what they do I should say with regards
to the travel issues for that uh federal
law and state law does allow uh for uh
take homes
very closely
protected by that work but you don't
have to for some people you don't have
to come to the clinic every day you uh
short durations of take-home drugs are
prescribed but that's not done through
telemedicine that's done through an
in-person because the Federal Law
requires that in the New Hampshire
controlled Drug Act requires that we
comply with the federal laws so
um so finally with regard to House Bill
503 again
it's confusion confusing when you stack
up the controlled Drug Act the
Telehealth act and uh and um and the
practice acts but I think the intention
of 503 in the work this committee did on
it was to create a carve out exception
uh for uh mat and so it narrowed it to a
substance use disorder there is another
bill in the Senate which is working its
way through the process it has a hearing
next week which expands out a little
further to include mental health
conditions
I think House Bill 500 might be more
comprehensive than that and I wouldn't
want to slow the work down on this
because of what the Senate might be
doing but just wanted to make the
observation representative Bloom that I
think we need while the work you did
last year on 503 was important and
helped with regard to mat
um I I do think we need to go further
with this legislation than than we did
last year
so I am happy to work with whatever
process is underway with the
stakeholders with the committee a
subcommittee with the our researchers uh
to
um to try to uh Advance it here I didn't
I didn't hear any opposition
um I think most of what we want to do is
get it right thank you questions yes
representative Nagel thank you for uh Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question I
want to understand the scope of this a
little bit better because the way it was
presented was a very specific scenario
but yeah I'm a provider I have a
relationship with a patient for a long
period of time I can still prescribe by
telemedicine one way or the other what
we're talking about is initiating
therapy is that correct
in other words like I've known Joe Smith
for forever I prescribed from for 10
years I can still one way or the other I
can still write a script it's initiating
therapy are you telling me I can't write
an order by Telehealth for a patient I
already have a relationship with that
I've been prescribing for no I'm not
she's nodding her head so that's
important to me which way is she not
gonna hit it's up and down
uh I don't read this as preventing the
initiation of treatment through to to
Telehealth um those were important
changes made in House Bill 1623 and 2020
but I do know that both that bill and
the current the practice acts require
that that the physician or the API and
use their professional judgment to
determine when an in-person is
appropriate
okay and and follow up
no okay okay other questions
representative Weber
so if we were going to try and align
this as closely as possible with the
Federal
regulations and also to provide the
greatest degree of flexibility
uh would it be a drafting an acceptable
drafting technique to make reference to
the federal regulations in the broadest
possible way
as a as a way of doing that or could we
simply be silent on the Federal
Regulations knowing that if they are
more stringent than ours they control
I guess I don't know the answer to that
and I don't mean to be flip about this
but I'm wondering you know what's maybe
we don't want to get too fancy with this
bill because of the time constraints on
it and if we make a unintended mistake
with regard to those alignments and May
11th comes it's really going to impact a
lot of people so I think the there's
absolutely I think a need to look at the
controlled Drug Act and uh in these
practice acts which are really the only
two that allow for the prescribing 224
and align all of that with what is apt
to be a changing Federal regime
thank you
and I thought I was going to see
representative Merchant volunteer to
sponsor that bill but
the other other questions
if Mr chairman if I can make a comment
yes okay good
um one of the things that he's sort of
touching upon is there's two parties
here one's the prescriber and one's the
dispenser and we have to be sure that
we're in alignment with this fencing
Community understand what we're doing in
the prescribing Community otherwise
we'll probably have some pushback and
with May 11th coming rapidly I think we
need to be sure that the dispensing
communities involved with what we're
doing as well as a prescribing Community
yeah I totally agree other questions
I'm seeing no other questions so thank
you
thanks
um does anyone else wish to testify on
HP 500 I have no other people signed up
representative or something yeah I just
had a quick 20 second follow-up for um
representative Weber's earliest question
about um the reference to the
out-of-state Physicians and the
out-of-state APR ends so I went back and
read both 320 329 and 326.
and it appears that um the first
um line one reference to out-of-state
positions is actually
an error because it's referring to
subsection two which is just above so
that would need to be stricken and then
um to follow up on the question about um
line 13 the out-of-state APRN clause the
larger subsection a to c is exactly
existing law so there is no change to B
that but it's here as a placeholder
showing the changes to a and to C so
there is no change to the the
out-of-state APRN issue it's just here
as a placeholder essentially
does that answer your question thank you
representative hacken Phillips
okay seeing no one else to testify on HP
500 I am going to close the public
hearing on HP 500 and open the public
hearing on HB 325 and recognize the
prime sponsor representative Gary
Merchant
ment
and even here
I can't fill it out right
again we need a pink card representative
Merchant
thank you Mr chair
for the record my name is Gary Merchant
representing Sullivan County
district 6 which is Claremont and
Croydon
I come before the committee for I think
it's relatively simple bill but Others
May don't agree with me
what happened was in the prescription
drug sorry the prescription drug
advisory
program is an advisory Council which is
multidisciplinary with many different
um
Healthcare police force and so forth
that are there along with legislators
one of the issues we run into with Lotto
boards when someone's term comes to an
end is trying to find someone to replace
them
so instead of having an Abrupt and
that's trying to find a way to say if
they're on the advisory Council
they could stay on the advisory Council
until they found a replacement
well it's brought to my attention by rep
attorney Williams from the Department of
healthy human services the way it's
written right now they could be there
until they pass away
that was never the intent so I did make
an amendment based upon his
recommendation to make a change so they
can stay on the advise the council for
up to six months after the term expires
so it's just allowing for a more
flexibility when you have folks that are
hard to find specifically in this case
was Dr Cropper Stephen Crawford who's a
state veterinarian it's a small pool of
candidates his term is coming up it's
what caused it to go forward and we want
to find it at least some time to find
another veterinarian so that's the
intent of the bill
okay questions for representative
Merchant
see no questions wow really was quick we
did get your print card for hb66 I don't
believe we have one for this one I'll
get one thank you Mr chair okay thank
you
okay no questions for uh this bill
okay going going gone thank you all
right uh
with that I will close the public
hearing on HB 325 and we will recess
until
um I don't know it was one o'clock
realistic or 1 15 perhaps at which time
we will resume our public hearings on
hb611. we stand at recessed
please be trained
good afternoon everyone
I'd like to call a meeting back to order
of the house committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs we
have a full afternoon of hearings
scheduled
and the first one is on House Bill 611
and I would like to recognize the prime
sponsor which is uh who is a
representative Sherry Vale
um
thank you Mr chair
good afternoon esteemed colleagues of
the Health and Human Services committee
my name is Suzanne Vale and I'm a New
Hampshire state representative from
Nashua sorry to mispronounce your first
name by the way
I knew I had to speak my name for the
record yes is comparable to mine it's
horrible
I should have been a doctor
that was bad I'm sorry
foreign
to introduce House Bill 611 which is an
act that will remove the language that
states that one must seek traditional
treatments and therapies and one must
also have failed to respond to this
treatment in order to become a patient
of the therapy therapeutic cannabis
program in the state of New Hampshire
I'm testifying as both a lawmaker and as
a patient at Prime ATC in Merrimack New
Hampshire
I did not seek care there until my
health was in a shambles and in 2017 I
walked through this door of the
dispensary for the first time I had no
idea that I had qualified before that
time
the statements to me seemed vague in in
the language in the law and I just
didn't think that I fit I'm not a fan of
spinal surgery I'm not a fan of some of
the treatments that I should have to
consider and fail at
and I would never take a chance on
unless I were unable to completely
enable an incapacitated
in terms of trying to live my life
I had gotten very far afield with
traditional medicines
prescription labels from the dispensary
include every ingredient that is in the
product
while pharmaceutical manufacturers don't
have to use the same compounds to
stabilize medication and deliver it to
you in a form that you can swallow and
ingest
we have to
take a difference and excuse me look at
this versus the um the medication that
we can get through the therapeutic
cannabis program
stabilizers suspensions and all those
things that carry your drug into the
body when you swallow or when you have a
topical or or other route of
administration
is all listed everything in the
ingredients is there the inert
substances that they say
in traditional medications and
pharmaceuticals you should not be as
concerned about particularly in generic
medications are not in the Cannabis
medications that people seek
at a dispensary like at a pharmacy only
better in my opinion inconsistencies in
the medication are right on the label
everything that is in the medication is
right there these capsules are
manufactured they're sourced they're a
hundred percent within the dispensaries
they start with a grow house that has no
pesticides in use they are also no
herbicides in use no fertilizers and
there are known bacteria and viruses
that the plants that can can succumb to
that could wipe out an entire crop and
it is a very sterile environment that
these I wouldn't go as far as to say
clinically sterile but it what like what
I would liken to a sterile environment
in terms of the process of growing in
synthesis of the products that they make
the very controlled process and the
ability to synthesize the flower they
grow into a product that is labeled with
the exact ingredients empowers the
patient to have a sense of direction as
they try to establish their medication
routine it gives them a list of
ingredients that gives them a list of
terpenes cannabinoids and it tells you
the percentages the amounts and it tells
you exactly what the capsule is made of
no matter what the item is all of the
ingredients are listed
there are fast-acting products and there
are products that help you sleep through
the night there are capsules topicals
tinctures
suppositories and many many forms of
medication delivery liquid concentrated
for your own at home
that you can buy a thing of oil that you
can bake your own goodies with if you
want and I call them goodies just
because they're good when you take your
medicine and instead of take trying to
take medicine when you're feeling very
sick or or tired when you don't have
enough saliva you want something sweet
you want something
that is going to be easy to process
I will be sending you an email that has
a picture of the um the medication
labels and also um
the um
excuse me
the link to the dispensary so that you
can see the products that they carry the
folks at the dispensaries are trained to
help you find the correct product for
the symptoms you're experiencing the
feedback that they you give to them
extends all the way back to the grow
house where they try to grow what you
need they ask you questions and they try
to find out exactly what symptoms you
find certain strains helpful with so
that the next person who comes in
doesn't have to do that
as the strains are less available they
are not always
something that can be brought to harvest
people need to know what those
ingredients are in order to seek the
kind of relief that they need for the
specific problem that we're treating
right now we're treating a discrete list
of illnesses that we have come before
this body to ask for permission to treat
again and again since the program was
offered up to New Hampshire residents in
2013.
you will hear more about all of this in
subsequent testimony
so where the law states that one must
try traditional medicines and procedures
has failed
one has to ask what is that failure
is that failure that you had too many
sinus effects and which side effects are
considered to be prohibitive in
interfering with your function
if you have wake up in the morning after
taking opiates the night before you
might notice that your eyes are swollen
and you have difficulty opening them
without having a compress
some people have reactions to things
where they cannot digest the food that
they need to have and where they need to
put on weight because they've been in
treatment for a long time and that many
of these treatments suppress the
appetite and make someone look very thin
and and have difficulty with managing
themselves
when we talk about the medications that
you can get at the dispensary and all of
the forms that they come in you realize
that people get the opportunity to buy
something that is concentrated but only
take a tiny bit of it at a time so I
will use an example of a 50 milligram
THC
that is in an iced tea mix if you would
like iced tea or something to sip and
you want to make sure that you can tell
the difference between one milligram and
50 milligrams this would be a good way
to try
so a tincture would do the same thing
where you have a little tiny dropper
bottle and there's one or two drops and
that may be all you need
personally I have found that the CBD
concentrations that are strictly CBD are
very helpful and at times I wish that
they were in a slower dose so I don't
take them but what would I do about that
I would turn around and say you know
something some of us might benefit from
a two and a half milligram dose I
haven't told them yet so they're hearing
now
if I could ask it appears that the bill
has a very limited scope it's deleting
like a couple of lines could you address
that aspect of it for us
yes I certainly can
the rest of my testimony is just an
impact statement and so and I although I
think that's very important so is this
so when we go through the build line by
line
um online
as you see on line five
we have we're coming to where we're I'm
striking the qualification on severe
pain that says that has not responded to
previously prescribed medication or
surgical measures or for which other
treatment options produce serious side
effects
we are not striking constant or severe
nausea moderate to severe vomiting
seizures and other in reactions that one
could have
thank you
relating to this aspect of the bill does
anyone have any questions
yes representative
um thank you and thank you for taking my
question
representative Vale so you're not
changing
a qualifying condition we were just
removing an obstacle for
a doctor would have already okayed
somebody as having some kind of chronic
pain and that they would be eligible to
go to a therapeutic cannabis dispensary
and get something for pain so this bill
seems kind of simple you're just
removing that line about
has not responded to previous medication
or surgical measures and I wondered how
that would have been measured anyway
the answer to that question is yes
representative upper nutm and the reason
that um that we really look at this is
because
you know there's Untold costs to trying
these medications that cannot be
accommodated in the law and may not be
something that you talk about with your
prescriber
so when we're looking at this what's
preventing and the obstacle was a good
word to use because we're talking about
severe pain we're not talking about
severe pain that the state approves of
or doesn't approve of we're talking
about asking your provider to be able to
say well this is severe pain I'm going
to send you there it may be or may not
be chronic pain but in the case of
severe pain that has not responded
this will make a big difference for
people it certainly would have made a
big difference for me and in fact I
would have been a sooner sooner engaged
in the program and probably would have
resolved some of my issues a lot sooner
thank you representative Leon thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
for bringing this bill to us
um just looking at these and talking
about your history were you under the
impression that you might need to have a
question
I didn't
I just wanted to if I could reframe all
we're doing here is removing barriers
that might be
unnecessary
and which don't need to be enumerated
because if we are comfortable now
because we have more experience than we
did when we drafted this
that Physicians We Trust Physicians to
say you could do A B C or D or you could
try this and you could try this before
you had to do a b and c and d and have
them fail
yes thank you
other questions
I am seeing none
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um I'm just looking at the statute that
you handed out to us the entire
um
126x and on the second page
under Roman nine
then underneath two where it says qual
there's a b it says qualifying medical
condition also means this is under the
paragraph that you're amending with your
bill but the next thing says moderate to
severe chronic pain
and then there's a redundancy it says
that same line severe pain not responded
to should we
okay
um
Okay so
what if we just struck out
chronic
from that part too
that is a i d ICD diagnosis
and therefore and I forget I'm sorry
which version we're on at this point
because I'm not working in a clinical
setting any longer
but um chronic pain is a is a it's a
diagnosis for any kind of pain that
continues on and pain syndromes are
really a different animal than the kind
of thing that someone goes through
um with severe pain and the reason for
that is because there's a feedback loop
when you use some of these treatments
and it's a spiral where you can't tell
what's going on and and side effects are
keeping you from finding out
as we know some of these medications are
extremely
um intoxicating
and we don't want people to take
something that's extremely toxicating
that has things that they don't know
about in it
other questions
yes representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
I'm struggling with this a little bit
not a lot a bit just a little bit maybe
you can help me
um
I personally
um when I we we look at an algorithmic
way of thinking about things when we
treat people
um I don't personally think of cannabis
as a benign drug I think it has a
potential to cause problems in some
people that we need to respect I would
never personally use it as the first
line treatment for any of these things
with a couple exceptions
um with that said and I'm curious how
you would answer that like there's a lot
of benign things that we do that don't
really cause a lot of bad problems and
I'm I'm lost about
really I really need to have a better
reason why we need to get rid of this
restriction
I can give you a better reason as I
conclude my testimony all right and if
it's not a better reason I'm sorry but
this to me is a better reason but I do
want to also say that cannabis is in no
way benign and in no way do I
underestimate what the black market can
do with the medications that we're
talking about we know this we know this
with opiates and we know this with
almost all of the street drugs that we
have now that come from the formation of
other drugs that we had in the last
century that we were Distributing and
that we were freely flowing and we were
being actually wooed into taking
excuse me uh Mr chair may I continue
sure go ahead just take a moment
before I go
I don't want to say anything I don't
want to ever miss an opportunity to tell
the members of this committee
how much stigma presents in the
relationship between a person and their
doctor a person in the pharmacy and how
dangerous that is
years back I had been prescribed a
long-acting opiate as a short and a
short acting opiate at the same time
when I went to the pharmacy to pick up
some education it was for a pre-surgical
issue and the pharmacy staff gave me a
strange look the pharmacist came over
and he said are you going to take all
this medication at once
I said no
I got home I opened up the bag
I had an order for five milligram
percocet pills but I left that Pharmacy
with something that had buprenorphine in
it and something that had was 20
milligrams and this was at a CVS 20
milligram percocet tablets which I
didn't know existed not Percocet I mean
oxycodone and part I'm sorry I'm just
might need to clarify some of these
things I'm extremely anxious I have a
crisis going on at home and I I'm
struggling with that right now so I have
to just put that on the record
um this critical area error of
dispensing that kind of medication
that's a terrible mistake and of course
I pursued it but there is no
accountability I've sat in my my
Orthopedic surgeon's office and had him
tell look at my med list and say what do
you do take pills all day
yes that was the last time I ever saw
that doctor but I wondered how many
times he said that to other people like
me
he did not say to me that he thought I
had a problem or that he wondered if I
had a problem or any of those things and
when I look at that medication list it's
astounding to me that I ever took those
medications and stood up and walked
around let alone functioned as a state
representative and as I sit here before
you I feel like I have to prove to you
that I'm not a stoner and I'm not an
opiate addict but I'm trying to treat my
illnesses and I'm trying to take care of
myself and and the others that are
behind me and I know we have a small
room and we have a small audience today
but there are fourteen thousand patients
in the therapeutic cannabis program so
we are here to say please let's look at
these statutes we're going to be looking
at them over the afternoon so what I've
given you is um
the area of law that we're going to be
talking about and um and we're also
going to be all asking you if you would
be interested in sponsoring some kind of
an educational event so that we can
teach the rest of the legislatures what
we're talking about
other questions
yes representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and make this brief back to
represent Weber's if I understand that's
what you're trying to accomplish through
this bill is what you can do illegally
if you will by going to the street to
get cannabis you just which could be a
funky source of the product to turn it
into a legal way to get it from a legal
Source that's controlled and has better
safety for the patient so you can still
get cannabis all this is doing allowing
the patient to go to some place that has
some sort of assurance about the quality
of their product and safety of it
I find that the 100 I find that I know
every ingredient that's going into my
mouth
that it's you know versus a generic drug
which now I worked in Psychiatry with
doctors for a long period of time and I
won't mention agencies or names or
anything like that but when you look at
the medications and you wonder what the
standard deviation is for the medication
across the board if I if I so for
instance if I had a Latuda then that
pill has a standard deviation of being
the same as another drug of 97 point so
two I think 5 or 2.5 percent I forget
how that goes but 97.5 percent of those
bills are those pills are exactly the
same or 102.5 percent of those pills so
somewhere along those that five
Point deviation you know you're getting
something pure
for generic medications it's 85.
85 percent consistently across the
medications a pharmaceutical
manufacturer can change the compounds
that they use that they add the
stabilizers the the things that keep
that drug in the form that they put it
there and keep it measurable to deliver
it to your body so would you want to
take something that's 85 percent what
you are looking for in a drug that has a
hundred other compounds in it that you
don't know what they are and where they
came from or would you rather take
something that was sourced from a
dispensary up the street that actually
relies on its own grow house and never
accept products from outside of of their
supervision directly
okay oh yes representative Cobalt
um just looking at the bill and hearing
your testimony
um
I I guess I I it looks to me as if this
is really a simple matter of affording
Physicians the freedom to exercise their
practice with their best professional
judgment so I think it's probably a
short yes or no answer uh would you
would you agree with that that statement
that this is really about Physicians uh
being free to exercise their
professional judgment
that's a really tough one to answer for
me because when I tried to get organized
for today I we have a doctor here who's
from the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board
and he can speak to what it's like to
for being what this would
be for him okay so I don't know if what
this is sending doctors I don't know the
message it's sending them but it's
sending the patients the message that
they don't have to try all these other
radical methods and honestly opiates are
radical that's a radical decision to
take and and you never think that you're
going to be taking it for the rest of
your life when you take that first one
and then that's where you could be
heading thank you other questions
see no other questions
okay thank you thank you I'm sorry for
all my stammering and hopefully I got a
point across
also signed up to speak today is
representative Wendy Thomas
representative if he could hold it to
three minutes that'd be great
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm representative Wendy
Thomas and I represent the town of
Merrimack I'm also a therapeutic patient
and have worked with patients in a
dispensary I'm going to focus on the
opioid part of this
oh I'm sorry I'm I'm going to focus on
the opioid um part of this uh problem
that this bill as is be the bill that
stands before this one offers
um when I recently had some major
surgery I was sent home with a total of
seven opioid pills with the instructions
to take two every four hours that was
pain relief for 12 and a half hours
that's following major surgery
when I developed a painful complication
I was told that quote we do not
prescribe narcotics after surgery end of
quote
when I had a second major operation this
time in order to be sent home with pain
medication I had to fill out a
psychological profile and I had to sign
a three-page agreement that said among
other things that I could get addicted
and that I could not sell the pills on
the street
this time I was sent home with five
pills with the instruction to take one
every four hours that was 20 hours of
pain relief again following major
surgery
the issue of under medicating patients
in severe pain is a discussion for
another day
opioids and even small doses have a big
impact on the body symptoms of opioid
use include drowsiness constipation
Euphoria nausea vomiting and slowed
breathing a person using opioids over
time can develop tolerance physical
dependence and opioid use disorder with
the risk of Overdose and death this is
nothing new we especially as legislators
are well aware of the opioid epidemic in
New Hampshire
in the case of severe pain often it is
chronic or lifelong opioid medication is
not going to fix it it is only going to
mask it for a while
the danger of not passing this bill is
that some patients will be asked to use
opioids to prove that it doesn't work
following current trends it is very
likely that those patients will be under
medicated with opioid medication for
their pain
that's when we get into trouble
many of these under medicated patients
turn to alcohol or even street drugs in
an effort to manage their pain
cannabis provides a safe alternative to
pain medication to pain management and
it does not have the side effects or
addictive qualities of opioids
if the largest Health provider in New
Hampshire is so concerned about
addiction and abuse with opioids that
they send their patients home with very
few opioid pills and make us sign
contracts of use the idea of tying
opioids for severe chronic pain before
trying cannabis is illogical and does
not fit with the current prescription
and usage of opioids I urge you to pass
house bills 611 so that our severe pain
patients can if they choose opt for a
safer method of pain management without
having to go through the use of addicted
addictive opioids to get there sorry
thank you I'll take any questions thank
you questions
anyone have any questions
I'm seeing none
hey thank you very much
also signed up to speak is
representative Heath Howard
and again if you could hold the three
minutes please yes of course hello
everyone thank you for having me today
my name is Heath Howard I'm a
representative for Stratford District
Four uh and I'm speaking to you today
about
hb611 uh because I support this bill I'm
currently a member of the therapeutic
cannabis program as I have just recently
uh enrolled in that program
I broke my back first when I was uh 16
years old in 2016. I had an L4 burst
fracture I had a spinal fusion and I was
prescribed several opiates I remember
being in the hospital uh when I was on
uh
medicinal grade Fentanyl and the nurses
would either have to remind me how to
breathe or I'd be screaming in pain
this bill doesn't necessarily focus on
the opiate side of things but it isn't
all it allows for Alternatives I spent
years dealing with my pain
and previously prescribed medications
had not worked I'd gone through several
um and I had gone through surgical
measures such as a spinal injection
those treatments didn't work for me
but medicinal cannabis has uh it's
something where I think that this could
definitely provide a lot of support and
assistance for people who need it thank
you I'll take any questions
thank you questions
I'm saying no questions okay thank you
very much
also signed up to speak is if I'm a
representative Jerry can Eric
foreign
thank you Mr chair um for the record
again Jerry can Eric uh former State Rep
and chair of the therapeutic canvas
medical oversight board which is charged
with the medical oversight of the
therapeutic cannabis program again just
to review 10 medical providers from
different fields a patient
representative
the medical director of the DHHS and a
representative from an alternative
treatment center
um as I said earlier about 70 of our
patients are certified for treating pain
allowing them to lessen or avoid the use
of opioids and about 82 percent of
therapeutic cannabis patients in New
Hampshire report that they have been
able to decrease their prescription
medications a couple of things to
clarify because there's been a little
bit of confusion about how you get in
this program to enroll you have to be
certified by your medical providers
having a qualified medical condition
established in law you don't prescribe
cannabis you can't do it because it's a
schedule one drug but you certify have a
qualifying condition
representative Weber hit the nail on the
head
it's hb611 seeks to remove an
unnecessary and potentially harmful step
in a patient becoming qualified to use
therapeutic cannabis for pain it's
almost like I sent you my my testimony
currently a patient can qualify for
severe pain only after having failed to
respond to previously prescribed
medication or surgical measures or
whether treatment options give
unnecessary or serious side effects
but this barrier is not needed in
December 2022 meeting tcmov voted
unanimously to support HB 611 as it is
written to remove this unneeded barrier
now the statutes are a little confusing
and there were some questions about this
as to how you can how you qualify part
of that is because of the structure and
part of this because of having added in
other standalones over time
you have to have both a both a
qualifying condition and a qualifying
symptom that's the RSA
126x19a1 and 2. but there are also a
number of Standalone conditions that
we've put in over the years one of which
again is severe pain
but one of the qualifying symptoms is
listed as quote severe pain that has not
responded to previously prescribed
medication or surgical measures or for
which other treatment options produce
serious side effects end quote this
exact language is then in the second
Standalone condition as well that is why
you see in this bill that there are two
sets of strikethroughs one strikes the
qualifying symptom for the 126x9 Roman
nine A1 and 2 and the other one strikes
the Standalone condition restriction
now remember that when the therapeutic
cannabis program was established in 2013
our evidence regarding efficacy of
therapeutic cannabis was still evolving
the statute was written to make
therapeutic cannabis an option of Last
Resort in treating pain
we now know that that's no longer
appropriate some of the strongest
evidence we have for the efficacy of
therapeutic cannabis is for the
treatment of pain
and The Landmark National Academy is a
science study in 2016 concluded again
that there's substantial evidence that
cannabis is an effective treatment for
chronic pain in adults
so given the Cannabis has proven to be
effective in treating pain it is not
reasonable at this point in time to
continue to insist that a patient has to
fail other options which may have poor
evidence of efficacy or which carry
risks which actually exceed the risks of
therapeutic cannabis
as I said before I was a spine surgeon
and though there are some spinal
problems that respond well to surgery
most of the time if you got a problem
with your back you should run the other
way from a guy with a knife because many
of our surgical procedures are really
not helpful they're not likely to make
people better so why would you force a
patient to have that procedure before
you could say sure you can have cannabis
or why force a patient to do a trial of
opioids for their back pain before
trying therapeutic cannabis we know that
opioids are not the not often are not
effective for long-term management of
pain and have far more risk of addiction
and impairment than cannabis does
no reason to expose the patient to that
risk of addiction and impairment from an
opioid if it can be avoided and this by
the way doesn't have a whole lot to do
with acute post-operative pain because
first of all it takes some time to be
certified go through the patient or
through the program so it's really
basically not an acute pain issue this
is for somebody yes I've got one more
sentence for somebody who is
um who is uh has severe opinions not for
post-op pain so I urge you to pass 611
to remove an unneeded barrier to a
proven treatment for pain which is just
an historical barrier that doesn't need
to be there thank you and I'll take
questions thank you very much uh
representative Weber
continuing on the drafting theme and
following up on a question asked by
representative Leon
um
to be qualifying medical condition also
means one moderate to severe chronic
pain and then two the piece that we're
modifying the severe pain that has not
responded to prescriptions but as long
as we are putting severe pain that is
not necessarily chronic on exactly the
same footing as chronic pain would it
make sense to delete uh number two
entirely and remove the word chronic
from number one so it just said moderate
to severe pain and then we don't have to
discuss whether it's chronic or acute or
or other things
if you look at my notes from our tcmob
meetings we discussed this these various
structures and ways to do it and that
did come up as one of our options of
just trying to collapse it
we thought that would be a little bit of
a bigger lift because the one was really
speaking about chronic pain and others
speaking about severe which could be
Subacute uh or you know pain that is of
somewhat shorter duration and we decided
that it made sense just to Simply remove
the barrier rather than try to collapse
the categories and get rid of it but I
think that could be done that was one
that we entertained
could I have one follow-up follow-up if
we did that would you see more
um push back to this statute because my
my goal would be to get something passed
but
as we've been dealing all day today with
removing the barriers and inch by inch
statutes that we put in in order to get
something passed at all what I'm trying
to find out is are we at the stage
where we could just consolidate and I
think what you're here I'm hearing you
say is no we're not there yet well
actually
personally I I did like the idea of just
consolidating it but I am here speaking
for the board and the board voted to
support this particular language but I
was very comfortable with just
collapsing those categories and still
keeping it in the uh Roman nine A2
because that one is a separate thing
just deleting it but in the standalones
to combine one and two and then of
course renumber the three four and five
and six
um and I think one could just say
moderate to severe pain
period I I would favor that but that is
not what the board voted on in some
sense speaking for them I need to report
what the board voted on thank you for
making the clarification thank you for
giving us your opinion yes thank you
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative
just so you know you're preaching the
choir here
um I want to imply otherwise with my
previous question I
um what's unfortunate what we're seeing
right now
is not what I see when I certify a
patient
um when you see the form as presented to
us it makes so much more sense and I
actually like the way it is and I would
not like to see it change personally I
really hated it when I first saw it but
now I really like it
yeah may I
okay I want your opinion yes I think in
a way it kind of devolves back to what
representative Koval said a moment ago
it just leaves it that it gives the
provider the opportunity to say I think
this patient's a reasonable person to
consider cannabis and they don't
necessarily have to do a trial of
something else although you know print
off a lot of pain most any provider is
going to try someone perhaps on Naprosyn
or something before they're going to
send them off a therapeutic cannabis and
I think almost all providers would this
just removes a barrier for the provider
as representative Koval pointed out
thank you
anyone else any other questions
seeing none
thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Michael Holt
from the Department of Health and Human
Services
and again if Sarah if you could hold it
to five to three minutes please thank
you Mr chair members of the committee
I'll keep it to one minute
um
I have two points to make one is that
this bill is as straightforward as uh it
appears it removes a barrier to
Providers
um for uh certifying their patients for
the Cannabis program and I would just
like to confirm as the administrator of
the therapeutic cannabis program for the
past you know five six years
um this is a conversation that we have
on a regular basis with medical
providers when they have questions about
certification and they will ask us
specifically according to this standard
do we have to have surgery or a course
of opioids first and technically the
answer the answer is yes
um and that and that does act as a
barrier for some patients certification
I'm happy to answer questions about the
program
um as well but I just want to make the
point that this is uh can be
operationalized by the the the the state
and we have no objections to this uh
this change
okay thank you questions
saying no questions thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is David Landry
again three minutes sir
thank you Mr chairman thank you ladies
and gentlemen of the board
uh my name is David Landry I'm from
Hillsborough New Hampshire I currently
live closer to the microphone I'm sorry
thank you thank you my name is David
Landry I'm from Hillsboro New Hampshire
uh I currently am employed for Prime
alternative treatment center uh in
Chichester and uh
Prime does support this bill however I
am here today to represent myself as a
patient of the therapeutic cannabis
program I support bill hb611 because I
believe that everyone should have
options on how to treat their symptoms
and conditions I became a patient over
six years ago when I first went into the
dispensary I was looking for something
to treat my severe pain little did I
know that canvas would ensure that I
would reach my end goal of detoxing for
opiates and that was a huge Factor uh
in my life and and how great my life is
now I had I had the option of cannabis
or opiates uh my life over opiates would
have been my life would have been very
different uh everyone should have the
ability to decide whether or not they
want to use Pharmaceuticals or
alternative treatment methods no one
should tell you that one treatment
method has to fail before you can try
another another
uh and I believe that
removing the the language from the bill
would help providers uh
have an easier time certifying patients
and I think that right now we're we're
having a really hard time with providers
uh in fear of losing their license or or
things like that any repercussions from
this so this program has changed my life
immensely and and I'm really grateful
for that so I appreciate you all
listening to me today thank you thank
you don't take any questions should we
get a copy of that testimony yes
any questions for this gentleman
yes representative Mr chairman thanks
for taking my question I I'm not totally
sure how to ask this of you because it
just came to my mind so if you come in
to see me with a pain problem I write a
script you go to the pharmacy it's right
there one of the barriers that I see and
I'm curious how this may have affected
you as ice decide I want to certify you
I write a form that goes to HH or
whomever the Cannabis commission they
have to decide blah blah blah we used to
take months to get here back
um you know so now you've dealt with
pain for several months and we're
talking about an acute issue here
um what was your time frame before you
got certified okay so in my in my um
for me I had to have a three to six
month patient doctor-patient
relationship which is now no longer in
existence which I I believe is great for
this program uh so I had to have a
three-month uh doctor-patient
relationship uh at the time I had severe
pain I was also 15 years plus of severe
opiate addiction uh the doctor knew that
I was trying to
um get away from opiates and the doctor
um
told me after three months of of being
her patient that we could then discuss
entering this program which
is
um
is what we ended up going with
um but it was a long time I did have a
extremely hard time uh coping with with
my pain I but I did
like I said I had an addiction I was
using the black market I was gaming the
system uh and
finally ended up in a methadone program
and after
so many years of feeling ill from the
amount of opiates I was taking and
almost overdosing and dying several
times I decided it was time to really
come clean with my provider and really
tell her exactly what was going on with
me in wanting the help now I had gone to
emergency rooms before this and I was
told that it's not going to kill you go
away and unfortunately
the space that I was in I was
I had the
a strong family that was supporting me
and I
I really wanted to kill myself at the
time so it would have killed me had I
not had the support system I have
so I'm really grateful for this program
though and uh you know I think that if a
provider has an easier uh method of of
you know not prescribing this but you
know making this a recommendation that I
think it would be great
thank you other questions
so you know other questions okay thank
you thank you
also signed up to speak today is Heather
Marie Brown
a few minutes ma'am
uh good afternoon thank you all for
being here and willing to listen to this
testimony my name is Heather Marie Brown
I am the patient representative on the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board so basically I am the one person
that represents the 14th approximately
14 000 patients we have in the state and
all of the future potential patients
that we may welcome into the program in
the future I am a thousand percent in
support of this bill I personally think
that this bill is long overdue I think
that we could use some changes and some
loosening of requirements and
restrictions
but in particular
um
taking these barriers away is going to
make a huge difference not only in how a
provider can deal with their patient but
also the type of relationship that the
patient can have with their provider
because as of right now it is still very
difficult to sit down with a provider
and have these conversations we have
very few providers in the state that are
even willing to certify and some of that
is due to lack of Education or lack of
knowledge or lack of understanding as
far as what the qualifications are and
the wording behind it this takes away
that barrier and honestly I do not
believe that we should be forcing
anybody to go through such Extreme
Measures for their health when they
should be responsible for making those
choices on how they deal with their
health care
I myself
had been
dealing with issues due to back injuries
and other injuries throughout my years
throughout my youth I had a very rough
use
um
going through medical professionals led
me unfortunately to develop an addiction
which then in turn ruined my ability to
be a contributing member of society and
almost destroyed my ability to be a
successful mother
um therapeutic cannabis I fought very
very hard for chronic pain severe
moderate pain and PTSD to be added to
the list of qualifications and I was
grateful to see it happen
um I was extremely worried about getting
a therapeutic cannabis card for chronic
pain has a condition on its own because
the medical professionals I was working
with at the time wanted to force me into
surgery that could have potentially
caused me not to be able to walk they
wanted to put me on medications that I
knew would trigger my addiction this
year I am celebrating 23 years of
sobriety so I believe that this is a
no-brainer and I welcome any questions
that the committee may have for me and
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you thank you questions
seeing no questions okay thank you very
much
and the final person signed up to speak
this afternoon is Dr Joe Hannon
again three minutes sir
thank you start the clock
my name is Joe Hannan
um former State Rep I'm a retired Foot
and Ankle surgeon and I was a member of
the New Hampshire study commission for
legalization and Taxation to cannabis
back a few years ago
um I'd just like to start off by saying
you know it's it's actually cruel for
the law to require serious side effects
needless suffering or surgery before
non-surgical options
um for patients and the provider's
freedoms are limited
um so they're they're not they don't
have the freedom to recommend or certify
patients as they see fit
uh I have over 31 years in recovery
myself and over that time I've had
several serious injuries to motorcycle
accidents several procedures where I was
almost forced to take pain medication
and all but one time and that whole time
I took one Percocet and I all those
broken bones and surgeries I said no
because I was afraid of having to take
stronger uh pain medication I muscled
through it don't recommend it was pretty
stupid but uh back then the option for
uh other other non-opiate options Warren
is available Beyond just NSAIDs
um I have many friends in the recovery
community that I've worked with and
spoken with and several have gone
through uh you know cancer serious
chronic pain
and they've all told me they've had
difficulty getting cannabis legally in
New Hampshire for any kind of regular
moderate pains especially and even
severe pain
and they didn't want to use opiates
because of their substance use disorder
histories
it's actually extremely scary the one
time I did take that little Valium and a
Percocet for a surgery I was a mess I
only took it for one time spent the
whole day in bed and I was emotionally a
wreck for weeks maybe a few months
afterwards and that was
18 years ago I don't want to have to go
through that again I don't want anyone
to have to go through that
um
like I said cannabis can be preferred
over opiates especially for people that
have a history of opiate use uh you
can't really cut Percocets and some
other opiates in into smaller doses if
you think that's required it's much
easier to to micro dose or cut a edible
or something uh drops or any kind of
cannabis into a smaller dose where you
may not even have any psychoactive
effects you may just have just enough to
take the edge off and that's very
important
um you shouldn't be cutting up anyone's
listening you shouldn't be cutting up
Percocets or any other opiates
um and when I back when I was
prescribing I would often give people a
Percocet prescription after a foot and
ankle surgery or a broken Serious injury
and you know that back then it was
things have changed we gave like 30 and
here you go that's what you're getting I
know we give less now but uh even when
you give less if they only take one or
two those extra pills are gonna sit in
someone's medicine cabinet and that is
more dangerous it's a more lethal option
to leave around for other family friends
and children than it is for cannabis
so I beg you to please make this
necessary change and I'd be happy to
take any questions or just go back and
sit so we can keep going okay thank you
questions
thanks seeing any questions thank you
I have no one else signed up to testify
is there anyone here who does want to
testify on HB 611 FN
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on HP 611fn
and open the public hearing
on House Bill 610 FN and once again
recognize representative Vale the prime
sponsor
thank you Mr chairman
and The Honorable members of the
committee for the second bill
this is going to be very very brief
I really appreciate this opportunity to
prevent present House Bill excuse me
again for the record
my name is Suzanne Vale and I'm a state
representative from Nashua
thank you for this opportunity to
present House Bill 610 which expands the
definition of provider in the state law
in the section of title X Public Health
chapter 126 section
126-x11 excuse me X colon 1. I filed
this bill at the request of The
Honorable Jerry Canard chairman of the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board and so I'm going to defer to him
to um to go through the bill with you
and to explain what's going on
um and what his thoughts were when he
filed when he planned to file this
I just also wanted to mention that I
think this is a powerful bill and I
think it's really important as I get
back to the stigma of being a
therapeutic cannabis patient and being a
person who has a chronic illness of any
kind and that's that you want to see
your own doctor
you want to see your own doctor and you
want to look at these labels and these
terpenes and these cannabinoids and all
of these elements to see how they can
help and you would be able to work
together with your doctor your own
doctor without looking for someone who
is certified to certify
that you are qualified for this program
and with that I'll conclude my testimony
thank you any questions representative
Vale
say hang on thank you
thank you Mr chair
also signed up to speak is
representative Wendy Thomas
sorry
uh greetings again Mr chair and members
of the committee I am representative
Wendy Thomas representing the town of
Merrimack and I'm here in support of a
house bill 610 which is an act expanding
the definition of providers who can
certify patients of the therapeutic
cannabis program this is yet oh I'm
sorry this is yet another bill that
removes obstacles to the Cannabis
program if we can agree that patients
with severe pain should not be required
to go through a trial of opioid use
prior to being qualified for the
therapeutic cannabis program and if we
can agree that we have an opioid
epidemic in New Hampshire that must be
addressed then we should also be able to
agree that any physician who can
prescribe medications to humans should
be able to qualify someone for the
non-narcotic therapeutic cannabis
program
some patients have a difficult time
finding a provider who is willing to
qualify a patient for the therapeutic
program and some patients prefer to use
alternative therapies this bill would
allow the patient to pursue alternative
therapies and still be qualified for the
program
this would allow say a naturopath who
has a very good understanding of how to
treat humans to be able to qualify the
patient for the program
as long as the state of New Hampshire
trusts a physician to prescribe
medications then they should trust that
physician to be able to qualify someone
for a legal medical and therapeutic
cannabis program
with regard to section two of the bill
many pediatricians are reluctant to
prescribe cannabis some children like my
own kids transitioned from a
pediatrician to a family provider while
still young
we felt that our family doctor had a
better holistic view of their entire
bodies
this bill would not require the parents
who use a family provider to then find a
separate pediatrician simply to fulfill
a program requirement it allows more
flexibility for parents and their
children
I would urge everyone on the committee
to support this bill that brings relief
to many of our most vulnerable patients
and voted OTP out of committee thank you
thank you questions for representative
Thomas
see none thank you
and also signed up to speak is former
representative Jerry Kennard
thank you and again for the record Jerry
can Eric chair of the therapy cannabis
medical oversight board by the way in
the testimony coming around you're going
to notice a few things that I corrected
I found some typos while I was sitting
there so I corrected each of the 22
copies
um anyway bottom line is that HB 610 was
filed that the request not really just
of me but of the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board which voted
unanimously it is December 2022 meeting
to support the bill that is currently
written
the board wishes to expand the types of
providers who can certify a patient to
use therapeutic cannabis just a quick
review again to enroll in therapeutic
cannabis program patients must be
certified by their medical providers
having a qualifying medical condition
RSA 126 X1 Roman numeral seven I had
eight in it it's seven I'm sorry about
that that defines which providers are
able to certify patients to qualify for
therapeutic cannabis and the list has
grown over the years most recently with
the addition of physician assistance to
that list
tcmob wishes to expand the list to
Providers to reflect the practice
environment in New Hampshire especially
in rural areas where many people have a
provider other than a physician or even
a primary uh even a APRN or a PA as
their primary care provider and then to
include other patients or other
providers I'm sorry who may be treating
a patient for example they may be
treating with a naturopath and there's
no reason they would have to go off to
somebody else to get certified
now if we look at it lines one to five
that's the section that expands the list
to include other providers who might
consider certifying a patient when the
board first discussed this we made a
list of providers to consider for
expansion including naturopaths dentists
podiatrists and so on but we always know
the evil of lists it's that issue of who
has been excluded and who's been
included and we ultimately thought it
would be a lot easier and
straightforward just to allow any
provider who's licensed to prescribe
drugs to humans and to possess an active
registration from the US DEA to
prescribe Controlled Substances to be
allowed to certify a patient to be a
qualifying patient we didn't make up
that language that language mirrors the
language that's used already in statute
for each of the other provider groups
that are currently allowed to certify
patients they all have that same
phraseology of License to prescribed
humans and possess an active DEA license
the second part of the bill
line six to ten is also a revision to
reflect the reality of Medical Practice
in New Hampshire
because of the unique risks of
therapeutic cannabis in children and
that's particularly true in adolescence
when the brain is developing uh THC can
have a very distinctive problems so you
have to really weigh the risks and
benefits because of those unique risks
guard rails currently exist in statute
that a child being considered for
certification needs to be certified by
two providers current statutory language
mandates that one of their providers
must be a pediatrician
but you know there's a lot not a whole
lot of Pediatricians up in the north
area where I'm from for example uh many
areas there may not be any pediatrician
a child may have as their PCP a family
practice provider who provides Pediatric
Care
so tcmbb felt it would be best for the
child to have that second certification
for example by their PCP even if they're
a family practice provider who provides
Pediatric Care rather than having to
travel to see a pediatrician who's not
their provider to be certified I also
need to point out that we only have 11
patients under age 18 certified so
there's not a whole lot of patients
anyway that would be affected by this
but it would just make it easier for
those of you who do need it but again we
have strong guardrails about kids in
that so please honor the request of
tcmob and pass HB 610 in order to
facilitate the certification of our
qualifying patients I'd be glad to take
any questions about that statutory
structure or anything okay questions yes
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
I'm
it may be explained for me better I'm
trying to see who's not included and you
mentioned naturopath specifically but I
didn't think that they were licensed to
be able to prescribe not all of them are
but some of them can some of them have
can prescribe drugs that's actually what
we were going through trying to come up
with a laundry list and uh you know we
were going to contact oplc and try to
sort out who can and can't and so on and
that's where we find decided just to set
the simple guard rail if you can
prescribe to humans
that's so that we don't have the vets
and if you have a DEA license then
you're certified to qualify because why
should it matter if you're a naturopath
or a PA or an APRN or a physician or a
do so you're functioning just adding
natural paths
yeah I mean although in dentists as well
because I think dentists are currently
not included and you may be seeing a
dentist for a chronic tooth problem
chronic pain and they may have done
everything they can to try to help it
and it's not working and this would give
them a choice
other questions yes representative
thank you Mr thank you for taking the
question
The Honorable Dr Jerry Canuck it's good
to see you back Jerry thanks would you
be opposed to or it says at the end on
line nine
just simply say
a licensed provider
of which one is
qualified to provide pediatric or Adult
Family Care what I'm trying to get to is
that we have Pas we have nurse
practitioners we have naturopaths why
limited to a physician or limited to
that category when above it for humans
they can actually write for almost all
of the human subjects but below it we're
restricting it to a pediatrician or
Family Practice why not have somebody
that's a PA or nurse practitioner as
well but we did say Family Practice
provider and indeed that does not that
we didn't choose the word physician
Family Practice provider could be a PA
or an APRN who does kids
correct but a pediatrician would be
normally a physician so I want to
clarify that it could be a nurse
practitioner who'd actually specializes
in Pediatrics
or could be but that's why you're saying
a family practice provider provides
pediatric care I mean if you're
you're I think that's clear you're
saying just say somebody who treats
children
just
I misread it
I'm looking for somebody's providing
pediatric pediatrician
is really kind of a physician yes so a
nurse practitioner who's doing Pediatric
Care
it's not a pediatric right
providing Pediatric Care is not family
I see what you're saying because that
that that could be an APRN who doesn't
do Family Practice only does kids
I'm not quite this this may be a
question for oplc as to what kind of
classifications we have there and or
maybe for nursing to know how that is
shakes out because I don't know if
they're still viewed as a family
practice provider and all the practices
I've been working with aprns do adults
and kids but I suppose in a very large
area there could be one who doesn't do
any adults
I'm just trying to remove as many
barriers as possible sure
maybe one could just strike it I don't
think TCM would be able to object to
saying or a provider who provides
pediatric care and get rid of family
practice just in case there may be a
small number of Pas or aprns who are
providing pediatric care but are not
officially a family practice person
correct I think possible Michael Holt
who's here might know a little bit more
about some of that licensure issue
because he's from the department and
might be able to clarify that
thanks
other questions
if I could clarify just put pediatric
provider or Family Practice provider
uh may I yes oh the problem is saying
pediatric provider or Family Practice
provider with the initial language was
or a family practice provider period we
did want it clarified that it was a
family practice provider who does take
care of kids so it we shouldn't use the
oreconstruct there because then that
would put us back to what we had with
TCM would be it sort of objected to
someone could just say or a provider who
provides pediatric care and that would
certainly solve that problem and I think
we would have no objection to that
um because our concern was to make sure
that it's not a family practice and
provider who has never looked at a kid
because there are unique problems in
kids and you need to know those unique
problems
other questions yes representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Dr former rep for taking my question
um I don't have a problem at all with
you know
pediatrician or Family Practice Center
because a lot of family practitioners
take care of kids anyway so to me that
makes sense what I'm I'm struggling with
I mean probably because I don't know
when when I had a DEA number
as you know every two years or whatever
it was we had to check off the boxes
that we would provide scripts for you
know two three or four something like
that never did I check off box number
one
um which is LSD in heroin right you know
so
but my question is you when you open up
this language to be so broad to say that
um anybody that has a DEA number or
license can now you know certify
somebody into the therapeutic cannabis
program which technically you know is
still a schedule one drug even though
it's it's allowed into medical cannabis
my question is do all these providers
that you list
um naturopaths Dennis podiatrist do they
all check off the same boxes as you did
as a treating spine surgeon and if so
how we're going to differentiate their
abilities as well as you know not only
just prescribing or certifying but also
um in evaluating those who are most you
know best served by this program well
the issue is if they are not qualified
to prescribe Controlled Substances then
they're not allowed
so the the the point is it'd be only
those who have a DEA that allows them to
prescribe control of substances and
again important to understand that
precise language exists in uh Roman
numerals seven a numbers one two three
four uh already because that's that's
how we have it written in so we're not
that's why I say we did not invent the
statutory I think it would be simply
mirrored what was already there but the
issue is let's say a naturopath does not
have a DEA they can't do it if they did
not if they cannot do Controlled
Substances they can't do it but if they
are a license to prescribe to humans and
they have a DEA to allow them to do
Controlled Substances they would then be
allowed to certify for therapeutic
cannabis
representative Weber
I'm wondering if we aren't making this
much more complicated than it needs to
be
because what the statute currently
allows
is two providers
one of whom may never have seen or
treated a child ever before but has a
DEA license
already and the other one it looks like
all we're trying to do is make sure that
at least one of the two
has had some experience working with
children
so I'm I'm wondering why we need to make
it more complicated than that if we've
already been comfortable with
virtually the same sort of thing all the
way along I mean one of these people
never has to have seen a kid
may I yeah yes I mean that exactly but
that's that's what's currently in
statute is that we have to have a
pediatrician but the issue is a lot of
kids don't have access to a pediatrician
so we wanted to Simply expand it so that
it would be somebody else as that
secondary provider who does deal with
children
but
it may have followed
my point exactly I'm wondering if we're
not as we're trying to redraft it in
many ways
making something that's relatively
simple which is just expanding it Beyond
pediatricians to other people who have
treated children
um
do do
I'm just trying trying to get around the
if we redraft it six different ways are
we making it more complicated in this
case and I know I try and redraft other
things but here I was
it's such a very clear objective
well I mean one could for example just
change the whole thing instead of saying
either a pediatrician or if a provider
who provides pediatric care you could
just say
shall be a provider who provides
Pediatric Care One could certainly do
that and that would cover them both that
would be a little more economy of words
and I think that would be something we
would still be very comfortable with we
were I think we were being conservative
and not wanting to strike language and
trying to just add language but
sometimes that is a little bit more
cumbersome but I think it would
certainly not violate what the tcmob
feels because it would still honor the
desire that it's somebody who looks
after kids whether it be a pediatrician
or a and that's why you're getting away
from the word Family Practice provider
just in case it's an APRN who does uh
kids only and otherwise doesn't take
care of elderly like us
um that would be pretty reasonable so
that that could make it simpler and I
think that would not violate our
concerns
I think we were just more concerned
about striking language that you know we
didn't think that might be good so but
you know how statutes get cumbersome as
we keep adding just like those
Standalone conditions we keep adding
stuff and then it gets more and more
cumbersome sometimes
other questions
I'm seeing no other questions okay thank
you thank you
also signed up to speak today on this
bill is Michael Holt from the Department
of Health and Human Services
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Michael Holt I'm the administrator of
the therapeutic cannabis program within
the Department of Health and Human
Services Division of Public Health
Services my testimony will be brief it's
mostly to Avail myself the committee to
answer any questions
um this is a this is a straightforward
uh bill that removes barrier to access
it allows more providers to certify
patients for the program I can confirm
what Dr knurk said that is we have you
know 10 or so uh minor patients on the
program it's very limited
population the and I would like to
confirm that this is a call that we get
on a regular basis from concerned
parents who are struggling to get their
kids onto the program you know we're not
talking about a large population and and
the number 10 reflects the the guard
rails but it also reflects you know the
concern that parents have about
um about children using cannabis and THC
products however
kids don't see pediatricians
pediatricians are are difficult and this
would expand it the two suggestions made
in terms of expanding it even further
um you know are consistent with the
goals of this bill
um uh representative former
representative you know rightly says
that uh the approach taken by the tcmob
was a conservative one
um to not strike pediatrician
um the department is comfortable with
this language has no objections nor
would we have objections to further
expanding this um to a more generic
provider who provides Pediatric Care
um
I'm happy to take any questions I would
like to make an aside to representative
Nagel's question about how long it takes
to get um a card from us
um we have a statutory mandate to
approve or deny an application within 15
days and then after approval to get a
card out within five we are well within
our mandates we didn't used to be when
the program first started based on you
know Staffing and resources as a self a
completely self-funded non-general fund
program but I'm happy to report that for
years we have been well within our
statutes depending on volume and current
Staffing levels you know we can get
cards out within a week
um but certainly we're consist uh
compliant with the 15-day statute
questions
thank you yes representative Murphy uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question and again I probably
didn't say it as eloquently to Dr kanerk
as I should have but I'm trying to
understand and I have no problem with
the family practitioner and expanding it
to these folks I I guess when I look at
this bill and it says
uh any provider that has a DEA number
can now certify a patient to be in the
program is that correct
currently the law allows for Physicians
Pas and aprns so and the requirement for
each of those provider types is for them
they must be authorized licensed as one
of those provider types they must be
licensed to prescribe drug to humans
which excludes veterinarians and they
must have an active registration for DEA
support okay go ahead sorry it's
important to know that therapeutic
cannabis is not prescribed in the state
of New Hampshire it is it is a
certification of a qualifying medical
condition and so the DEA is a the
requirement for a DEA number is intended
to mean if you can prescribe you know
Controlled Substances then you can uh
certify for this program
um
uh it is not a requirement for a
reporting of a prescription based on
your DEA number so there's no
requirement for these providers to
engage in the federal government and the
DEA registration system you know to be a
to certify for the the program thank you
and I understand the DEA number and the
different categories you listed I guess
my question is more clearly what other
qualifications do you have to have I
mean what I'm thinking myself as an
orthopedist I would never feel qualified
to certify somebody for that program
because I don't know enough about it so
I'm trying to understand what the
other qualifications of somebody that
certifies r
currently right
there are no the state of New Hampshire
does not require a certification of
medical providers in the state
um other states do require a in order to
be a An approved provider to certify
patients they need to be registered with
the state as a cannabis provider New
Hampshire law does not require that does
not require training it does not require
registration with the state as a as a
cannabis provider
um Etc so there are there are no other
requirements for certification other
than
having a provider-patient relationship
with the patient explaining the health
effects of cannabis to the patient
um
explaining health effects and risks to
certain Target populations those uh
those who are pregnant breastfeeding and
those who are adolescents the
legislative the general court passed the
law two years ago to require special
education to those two populations But
to answer your question there are no
other requirements in order for a
provider to certify their patients for
the New Hampshire therapeutic cannabis
program
so
when I was practicing this follow-up
thank you I'm sorry when I was
practicing then you're saying that I had
a DA number and I had a license that was
active in the state of New Hampshire and
therefore I could have certified a
patient into the program as a physician
yes yes okay thank you representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh would you be able
to tell uh about minus out of those 10
or 11 miners who are currently in the
program uh what kind of uh medical
issues that line to solve with it and
those who were not able to get there you
said you receiving calls from parents as
those medical issues the same or as a
something as a set of medical issues
that they want to solve this program but
they cannot get on this program so far
so thank I do not have the list of uh
minor patients on the program nor do I
have in front of me the the qualifying
conditions that they qualify for uh
based on memory uh the the of the ten
they are pain issues which is a you know
which is as Dr canarka said you know 70
plus percent of our patients are
certified for a pain issue
um the others are epilepsy
um uh childhood epilepsy uh is is
another uh
there's another condition that is it's
hard to say common there's only 10 you
know so maybe two of them have epilepsy
and six of them have pain and others
have an undisclosed condition you know
with uh with with a pain condition
um there's there's no
the list of qualifying conditions that
makes one eligible for the program is
not distinguished between adult patients
and minor patients so the list that you
saw in the last bill of the list or the
partial list is the list that um the
kids are being certified for
is that is that the answer to your
question yeah yeah yes okay okay thank
you
um
any other questions
saying no other questions okay thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is Heather Mary
Brown
good afternoon long time no see
um again I'm Heather Marie Brown I am
the patient rep on the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board I will
not take up a lot of your time but I do
want to express the importance between
these two elements that this bill is
asking to change
I will tell you that there literally is
a handful of individuals within the
state of the New Hampshire that will or
have certified patients for therapeutic
cannabis
the idea behind this is something that I
have felt very passionately about for a
multitude of reasons we held a listening
session where we invited the public
professionals patients Foreigner
patients hopefully new patients to come
in and talk to us the issues that were
raised most were accessibility and
affordability were two of the top things
this takes care of
touches on the accessibility part it is
very difficult in the state of New
Hampshire to be a patient and have to go
and shop around to find literally shop
around make phone call after phone call
after phone call to find a professional
a medical professional that would be
willing to work with you that is
qualified under the statute to actually
give you a certification
unfortunately I've seen several cases
where that has led to
individuals that will certify but
because certification is not covered
under a medical insurance for those that
do have medical insurance they are able
to charge individuals in exorbitant
amount of money just to receive a
certification I've had reports of
patients having to pay in excess of five
to six hundred dollars just to go in and
see a provider to get this piece of
paper signed a piece of paper signed
that says we are certifying you to try
therapeutic cannabis that is absolutely
ridiculous
by opening up the statue and allowing
for any medical professional that
possesses that number to be able to
certify a patient you are taking
barriers away that will allow again for
patients to develop a better
relationship with medical providers to
allow patients to feel comfortable to
have conversations with medical
providers and to allow for the exchange
of information and even to a degree a
level of education for both medical
providers and patients alike
I as far is the second part of this bill
goes it's
I personally myself have always been
against creating barriers whether we're
speaking in regards to Children's Health
Care or adult health care
I was able to develop in my own mind a
compromise by accepting this I
personally wish that we didn't have to
put our children through our families
through the process of trying to find
not one provider but two providers to
sign the certification but again this is
a compromise because where there are so
limited amounts of certifying
pediatricians or individuals in the
state that are willing to certify as a
pediatrician this will allow families
another option another place in another
area to search out treatment for their
children
both of these changes I find are
necessary and long overdue and I look
forward to answering any any questions
that you may have thank you questions
yes representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
you've been involved with this process
for a long time so I'm hoping you could
answer my question
um why two pedia pediatric people why do
we need two to certify
well
um and anyone in the back Mr Holt could
correct me if I am wrong but to my
knowledge that decision was made because
of
probably not going to use the right
terms but you know where we do know that
cannabis can have a potential effect in
adolescence I think the thought behind
it
was so that everybody was making the
right decision for that particular child
I think it was like a system of checks
and balances I
again find that it's a system of
redundancy and maybe could is
unnecessary but
by opening up the statue and and
changing who we allow to certify and
changing that language to a family
practice provider or someone that
provides pediatric care I think that
does help families out immensely
yes representative Weber
would you also agree with me that in
addition to your very thoughtful and
complete answer the other reason for the
two providers there was that we needed
to get this bill not only past the house
but also past the Senate and get it
signed by the governor
whichever Governor it was at the time
which has always been an issue
thank you so much for your question
um
if I can speak honestly yes most
definitely I think fear it has been a
huge driver of this particular vehicle I
think that fear comes from again lack of
understanding education knowledge
whatever you want to label it as I think
that because the program has been so
successful for so many years that you
know we as patience has families has
parents as individuals we have been able
to prove to the state time and time
again that we are responsible with this
program that this program works that
this program helps that it changes lives
for the better
um and that you know maybe it might be
time to loosen up some of these
restrictions and to to make this an
available health choice for those
individuals that choose to access
therapeutic cannabis instead of creating
barriers based on our own lack of
understanding or possibly education of
it
thank you other questions
so you know other questions thank you
and the last person signed up is Dr
johannan
thank you for hearing me today Joe
Hannon I'm speaking for myself I won't
repeat anything that was said previously
but I agree with pretty much most of
what was said
um I I will say that as someone who has
a 16 year old son who is driving to his
first dentist appointment by himself
today it's not and it's his first adult
dentist appointment he's usually going
to a pediatrician he's still going to a
pediatrician but
um he'll be he won't be 18 when he goes
off to college so he's definitely not
going to have a pediatrician when he's
away from home so this is something that
wouldn't just affect my son for a few
months or maybe a little longer for some
uh young adults but many students to go
to school in New Hampshire not
everyone's 18 when they go away from
home
uh I could maybe answer some questions
about being a podiatrist and prescribing
um you know I like our the esteemed
orthopedist on the on the commission
committee uh I studied the whole body
and and I know the purpose of all the
organs I know that the heart is supposed
to pump ancest to the Bone
um and I was fully licensed at a DEA
number licensed prescribed narcotic
medication to patients uh in training I
even gave fentanyl lollipops a pediatric
patients with severe burns to the low
extremities so um I had a DA dispensing
license as a podiatrist so I was able to
I didn't do it because it was not
something I really want to do but I had
the ability if I wanted to to give out
narcotics from my office
so there are other providers who are
more than capable and have the
experience and knowledge to do as at
least as much as a nurse practitioner or
another provider can do that's already
allowed to certify patients um and I'd
be happy to answer any questions and
that's all I have to say
thank you questions for Dr Hannon
I'm saying no questions
thank you
I have no one else signed up to speak
does anyone else wish to speak on HP 610
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on hb610 and open the
public hearing on HB 431 and invite the
prime sponsor representative Wendy
Thomas to come and testify
yes
okay okay great thank you and we don't
time to find responsible
another cannabis bill
Mr chair members of the committee to
remind you I am representative Wendy
Thomas I represent the town of Merrimack
and I come before you today to present
House Bill 431 which is permitting
qualifying patients and designated
caregivers to cultivate cannabis for
therapeutic use
as a reminder I am a New Hampshire
therapeutic cannabis patient I use
cannabis on a daily basis for pain and
illness I take those micro doses that
were referred to earlier
this bill would allow New Hampshire
therapeutic cannabis patients or a
designated caregiver to grow cannabis
plants at their residence it would allow
New Hampshire therapeutic cannabis
patients to have and grow Three Mature
which are flowering plants
three immature which are non-flowering
plants and 12 seedlings which are
defined as six inches tall or less
this bill would allow them to grow
cannabis at their place of residence and
consume the Cannabis that they grow
by growing their own cannabis the
patient can choose which effective
strains to grow and they would say a
cost savings for their medication
recently when the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board met they voted
to unanimously support this bill
so reasons for home cultivation
secure home cultivation is not causing
any problems
14 of the 18 states that have legalized
adult use cannabis and about half of the
medical cannabis states allow for
personal cultivate cultivation
in the states that have reasonable
safeguards home cultivation has not been
a problem no state has repealed home
cultivation
home cultivation is important for
patients about six percent of Americans
use cannabis for therapeutic reasons
insurance does not cover cannabis for
many people with serious medical
conditions medical expenses and a
reduced ability to work make getting
cannabis difficult
by allowing home cultivation you are
giving the therapeutic patients
Financial relief for their non-insurance
covered medicine
home cultivation helps to displace the
illicit Market
some patients need more some patients
don't have the financial means to prep
to purchase tested and measured cannabis
from the dispensaries home cultivation
would allow those patients access to
cannabis without having to use the
illicit Market
home cultivation is consistent with our
commitment to freedom and equality
in a free society and a state with a
motto Live Free or Die adults should be
allowed to grow cannabis plants in their
homes for therapeutic use
a little bit about what other states are
doing in Connecticut it is legal for
patients to have up to Three Mature
plants and three immature plants in
Maine it is legal for patients to have
six flowering plants two immature plants
and unlimited seedlings in Massachusetts
you're allowed six plants per person
person or patient no more than Twelve
Rhode Island it's legal for patients up
to 12 mature plants and 12 immature
plants per patient and in Vermont you
can have two mature plants and seven
immature plants per patient
since 2009 the New Hampshire house has
consistently supported bills allowing
patients with qualifying medical
conditions and their caregivers to
cultivate a limited supply of cannabis
in 2012 and 2019 the Senate agreed
advancing home grow legislation to the
governor's desk both bills were vetoed
and the override efforts fell short in
the Senate
in 2020 the Senate passed a home grow
bill in a Voice vote but the outbreak of
covid-19 prevented it from being
considered in the house
finally there is an amendment for this
bill I've sent it around it is a draft
and it corrects some drafting errors
from OLS first of all it corrects some
outdated rsas that were referenced when
we tighten up the security language the
phrase at the person's residence was
inadvertently removed this is language
that the police wanted in there and it
was an error that it was removed the
amendment would put it back in
the date for the Department to allow
existing and new qualifying patients and
caregivers to to designate a cultivation
location has been moved in the amendment
from October 2023 to December 1st 2023.
this was in
consultation with the department and
gives them more time in the event that
the bill is passed after a veto
the draft I've passed out still has some
errors from OLS and Mr Holt will speak
to those issues when he testifies thank
you and I will take any questions
thank you Mr thank you chairman just out
of curiosity where do you go to get the
the seedlings
for the home cultivation so
first of all you can buy seeds the FDA
has declared that that seeds are
available cannabis seeds because they do
not contain THC so you could buy seeds
and you could grow your own there is
some discussion with the dispensaries
that they will provide seedlings
that's to be developed with each
dispensary but that's that's an option
that could be available but I would
think mostly from seeds you're welcome
yes representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman uh seen an article recently
about Montpelier Vermont there was a
contaminated
um batch of cannabis that was recalled
from their state
um
uh their state program
is this is this bill something that can
prevent people being exposed to bad
batches of cannabis that may be at the
atcs
um theoretically it could but in New
Hampshire all of the Cannabis is tested
prior to it being available to patients
and I'm going to guess that there was a
mold issue perhaps with the Cannabis so
that would be tested for so so you're
not going to see that in in the
dispensaries
um with plants you know this is not
growing your daddy's tomato plants you
know it takes a little bit of time a
little bit of effort mold can be an
issue you know but that's going to kill
the plants uh so you know you're going
to have to to take care of them
other questions
yes representative oh fault
thank you for taking my question so we
we have heard a good deal so you you
talked a little bit about
costs yeah
um we've heard a good deal in when we
hear about other bills about
access and particularly people who live
in the North Country so can you speak to
the location of these dispensaries and
the effect that that has on
um people who may live in the North
country or elsewhere well you should
have been here four years ago when I
presented a bill on that very topic and
because of the bill two more
dispensaries were opened up in the state
of New Hampshire
particularly in the North Country this
this bill would help patients up there
some of those patients have to drive
almost an hour to get to a dispensary
and you're limited in how much you can
get so this would certainly help those
patients and again you know cannabis
is not cheap it's not cheap you know I
take micro doses so a little bit you
know goes a long way but there are some
patients that have significant health
issues that that need a fair amount on a
daily basis and that that can be
expensive
one other thing to remember or to to
know perhaps you don't know this is that
if you grow the cannabis plant it's the
bud it's the flowering Bud that uh that
is used and it has to be decarboxylated
so you can't you know there's no there's
no danger of somebody rubbing against
the plant and getting euphoric there's
no danger of your dog eating the flower
they'll probably be very calm but
they're not going to be euphoric the
reason the way that you decarboxylate is
you apply heat which is why people smoke
cannabis
other questions
I'm seeing no other questions
okay thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Jerry canark
Obama representative Jerry Canary
foreign
okay thank you Mr chair and for the
record again Jerry chair of the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board
um a lot of the stuff in my written
testimony I can skip because you've
already covered it basically the issue
is when a person is approved to be a
qualifying patient there is student
registry ID card that allows them access
to an ATC and that's where they are
counseled regarding appropriate strains
and routes of administration and they
obtain their therapeutic cannabis
currently patients cannot grow their own
therapeutic cannabis
now it's important to realize that
cannabis is not just one compound it's
not one drug it's a botanical
as a result it contains hundreds of
different chemicals different cannabis
strains have different cannabinoid
profiles most notably the concentrations
of THC that's the major intoxicating
component and CBD which is
non-intoxicating
terpenes they're responsible for the
aroma of plants they also vary among
strains and they modify the response to
the cannabinoids and the synergistic
effect of the cannabinoids and the
terpenes is called the Entourage effect
and that gives different strains
different effects upon symptoms so
patients often need to try different
strains for a while to get one that'll
give the desired effect upon their
symptoms once they find what works they
need to stick with it that can sometimes
be a problem because an ATC may drop a
strain due to low demand leaving a
patient without access also there was
that comment a moment ago about access
to in general to the atcs and indeed it
is quite a ways for a lot of us anywhere
but specifically in the North country
so last year the tcmov held a listening
session for feedback from patients about
the functioning of the program the most
common concerns were affordability of
the products accessibility of the atcs
and availability of this specific strain
needed by a patient to treat their
symptoms which may not be available in
their nearest ATC
several patients who spoke to us felt
that home cultivation could at least
partially address many of these concerns
that is January 2023 meeting tcmob voted
unanimously that it agrees with the
concept of Home cultivation of
therapeutic cannabis biotherapeutic
cannabis patients and caregivers to help
with accessibility affordability and
strain availability I do have a few
specific points I'll Express but at this
point understand that I'm now speaking
for myself not tcmob as we voted in the
concept of Home cultivation but we did
not go into the Weeds on specifics of
the language
okay good you're paying attention I I
use the train same trick last year on
the floor too
um anyway the point is that the bill has
a lot of really good features such as
allowing a patient who cultivates to be
able to submit their cannabis to a lab
for testing that's great because it
allows them to get their cannabinoid
profile and to ensure safety with
respect to contaminants the bill also
has robust protections with respect to
limitations and the number of cannabis
plants the registration of cultivation
sites that must be enclosed and locked
these protections will make home
cultivation safe and secure and
controlled and should satisfy the
concerns of law enforcement it's
important to realize that an awful lot
of patients will probably not grow their
own some will not have the space some
will not have the skill I would suggest
adding language also though to allow
atcs to provide seeds and clones it
currently says seedlings but will
provide seeds and clones to patients to
assist them in growing the specific
strain they need for their condition I
do disagree with one issue page six
lines four through thirteen allows home
cultivation for potential qualifying
patients have not yet been granted a
card this could be an enforcement
nightmare again page six lines four to
thirteen could be an enforcement night
Nightmare and I feel that they can wait
that short time until they get their
card and we know their their location
before they would be allowed to do it
now I do not have a copy the amendment
so I will not comment on that again and
I'm speaking for tcmob primarily and we
talked about the concept not the
specific wording I will defer to my cult
for a discussion of the particular
problem so in summary allowing home
cultivation of therapeutic cannabis by
the therapeutic cannabis patients will
be very helpful for our patients and
addressing affordability accessibility
and the availability of specific strains
and uh Mike Holt and I would be glad to
work with the committee on any needed
amendments thank you thank you questions
yes sir representative King
thank you chairman McDonald when it
comes to the and thank you by the way
when it comes to the reasonable
precautions and uh enclosed spaces that
doesn't preclude being able to grow
outdoors does it
um well I for example I have a
greenhouse I don't grow because it's not
legal but I have a greenhouse if I could
if I wanted to do so and I were a
patient as long as I had a way to lock
that that would be an enclosed it would
be not visible without somebody ripping
the plastic off and it could be locked
so that's the whole issue it could be
done outside and indeed it is a problem
growing inside requires really high
intensity lighting and a lot of costs
that are there it's probably a little
easier to control the environment than
it is inside of a greenhouse but you're
not going to see Farms or I mean big you
know just out in the field somewhere
because that's not enclosed and uh so on
and so forth follow up follow up what
about just a fenced-in area with
sunlight but no Greenhouse is that okay
oh
[Music]
see
um
I'm sorry can you remind me which which
line that's on because I want to make
sure that's in um
that's uh lines five through nine on the
first page
um yeah okay
yeah an enclosed lots of space I mean if
it's just fenced that's I guess it could
be locked but it would have to be not
accessible so you'd have to have a
pretty high fence
um and you know but barbed wire or
something like that probably
I mean that could certainly be tidied up
to make it enclosed and non-accessible
if one wishes to add just a little bit
more language to that thank you
representative Murphy did you have a
question or
thank you Mr chairman and thank you um
Dr X rep you know connect
um a simple question
um we had a similar Bill last year in
front of us about legalization of
cannabis and one of the big concerns was
that the availability would potentially
compromise the therapeutic home or
therapeutic cannabis program and the
reason being was you know the the whole
idea about counseling and education do
you have any concerns that this would
detract from that or be would would
patients be less likely to participate
in the education in counseling part of
the program you know it's interesting uh
when I first was thinking about this I
did have some concerns about that that
it would drive patients away from the
atcs it turns out our atcs actually
support this because they have a solid
goal of trying to be sure that patients
have access to therapeutic cannabis and
they uh you know they're not just there
to make a bunch of money they're there
to actually make sure people have the
access and they realize this may be a
good way to do it
um I can't speak for them but I know
that um one of the representatives from
Prime is here Matt Simon and we'll speak
to their point of view on this
um I think though probably patients will
still start in the program so they can
get counseled try find out what the
strain is that works for them maybe find
out that that's only available in some
other part of the state and they don't
want to go there so then they might get
some seedlings or clones from that ATC
which would be a way to still reimburse
the ATC for their work and then start
growing on their own so yes it might
have them
out of Constant Contact but they
certainly might still touch back if they
are having some issues
other questions
representative Nagel feed your hand up
would you believe
[Music]
in all full disclosure I'm on the board
of Temescal and we are non-profit we are
not for-profit right so in the end um in
theory the goal is the benefit of
everybody yes that's what I mean these
these are not people who are trying to
gouge the patients these are these are
organizations who are trying to do a
good job of providing therapeutic
cannabis and they see this as best I
understand as a way to expand that but
Matt Simon can discuss that better
other questions representative whoever I
would just have one other question
because there was the concern that was
uh asked about and that representative
Thomas spoke about with a a batch of
um therapeutic cannabis in Vermont was
recalled but is it not true that just as
there are potential issues that we have
taken better steps to guard against here
that it's also perfectly possible that
somebody who is home growing can can
wind up with mold or or some other
uh thing so it's it's not
a be-all an end-all Panacea it's another
route to be explored with all the others
yes I think so and indeed that's why I
say a lot of people don't have the skill
set I mean I I get problems with my
plants that I grow both in my garden
into my Greenhouse it can be a real
nuisance sometimes they're recognizable
but that is one of the good features of
allowing the patient patients who are
home growing to be able to take in for
testing if they wish to do so so there
is that tremendous Safeguard and so they
look at their plan they go well I wonder
if that's really okay they can go check
it also I would assume that the atcs
will get involved in some decent
counseling about how to safely grow so
people aren't growing in lead-filled
soil with a bunch of pesticides that
they're then going to combust and inhale
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
honorable Dr knurk for being here today
my question comes to the idea that um
one of the cult the one of the people
who's a caregiver would currently be
limited to just one patient and I'm just
curious about says curious about the
situations where you may have say two
patients in a household and if that
would be something that would be
reasonable within your experience if
we'd be able to expand it to a certain
number of people in a household and not
just one individual or a caregiver yes I
think that could be a little bit of an
uncertainty in other words if you do
have let's say two people in the
household do they each qualify for the
same to each by themselves have a
certain number of plants so the number
in the household would be more than the
qualified amount but they would each be
responsible for one half of that I don't
see why that couldn't work uh that I
would think that it would be okay they
just happen to be residing together
thank you
other questions
seeing no other questions
okay thank you thank you very much
also signed up to speak is Dr johannan
hello again uh johannan uh like I said I
was on the marijuana study commission
years ago and one of the things that we
did talk about was home grow in general
for adult use not just medical and that
was the issue of that commission uh it
didn't seem to be a very uh
controversial issue there were some
members of the commission who obviously
didn't agree with it or legalization in
general
at all but uh a vast majority of the
people in the commission realize that
homegrow was akin to home brew of beer
and wine you know we're allowed to brew
you can grow you can have 100 gallons of
beer or wine if you have two adults in
the house you can have 200 gallons a
year that's a good amount
um and in this bill it does talk about
more than one certified provider for a
cannabis patient or two cannabis
patients living at home you can have if
you have one provider and a patient you
can have 50 square feet of canopy and if
you have two either providers or
patients in the same in the household
you can have up to 100 foot canopy so
that is in the bill already
um
and as far as protections
um the the home home brew law is really
simple I'm sure I don't know if well I
don't know if you read it much in this
community I was on Commerce we had to
read it all the time but um
it's real short it's a couple paragraphs
and it just says you know you it's for
personal use is really what it's you can
grow this much for this much it's for
personal use there were no requirements
for uh you know locked doors or keeping
it from public view although it's
probably a good idea with some of my
neighbors they're very nice but I
wouldn't leave it still out in the yard
or whatever but um you know as this bill
does have uh
parts that talk about you know not being
able to be seen from public view uh one
thing I'm not really sure is necessarily
with or without the use of optical AIDS
if someone's using a telescope to look
into my yard that's a little intrusive
so I think it'd just be from Plain View
would be a nice change
um and really that's about it it's a
pretty straightforward Bill and
otherwise um if I could make my own
medicines at home I'm sure I would for
most things I've actually gone to the
pharmacy several times in the last month
for my family my children and I myself
and there are three different
medications in my family that we have
not been able to get a hold of not that
there's a shortage of cannabis right now
but if you can't get a medication I
would have loved to have been able to
grow you know blood pressure pills or
whatever it is at home so
um thank you questions
I'm saying no questions okay thank you
also signed up to speak is a Matt Simon
um from Prime ATC
in three minutes sir
thank you Mr chairman honorable
committee great to see you again
I don't have written testimony instead
I'm going to refer to two one-page
documents that representative Thomas
presented with the package she gave you
earlier one of them is home cultivation
legislative history one is cannabis
cultivation laws in New England I
mentioned these because before I work
for primeatc I've been for the last 15
years advocating for
cannabis policy reform in New Hampshire
and in particular legal home cultivation
for both patients and for adults prior
to working for Prime ATC a job I took
about a year and a half ago I worked for
the national marijuana policy project
for 10 years in that role I advocated
for this therapeutic cannabis law in
2013 back when representative McKay was
chairman and spent a lot of time with
this committee back then and even before
that in 2007 was when I started
advocating for this stuff in New
Hampshire so I really sincerely hope and
cautiously optimistically perhaps
believe that this will be the 15th and
final year that we all have to come in
here and ask this committee to do what
it is in fact done many times in the
past to prove limited home cultivation
of therapeutic cannabis so I'm not going
to go through all this but this is the
document I created five years ago and
I've updated each year as for their
development moments have happened now it
takes two pages to tell the whole story
but I'm really hopeful this is the last
entry that HTTP 431 will be the bill
that that passes into law and you can
see just how close patients have come
two votes in 2009 were the difference
between this passing and not and
including home cultivation
again in 2000 multiple times it's been
within three votes in 2019 it was a
three vote veto override that the house
override The veto and the Senate didn't
so
the other document is just laws in New
England I made this a few years ago when
it wasn't complete but I'm I had fun
updating it last week and now showing
that every state in New England cannabis
is now legal not only for medical use
but for adult use and patients and
adults in every state are allowed to
grow cannabis for their own
limited use so the Live Free or Die
state is yes the only state in New
England where it is a crime to grow
small amounts of cannabis for registered
patients and for adults Connecticut's
the only one that hasn't taken effect
yet for adults patients can grow there
and they've passed it for adults so July
1st of this year
that will take effect and we will be
truly an island of
home cultivation Prohibition in New
England
so I'll leave those
aside I do want to note briefly
on the affirmative defense provision
that represented a former rep Connor uh
mentioned so the bill does two things
one one is that it adds
possession of plants to what's legal for
patients the second part is an
affirmative defense so this doesn't in
my view create chaos this means that if
somebody happens to be arrested and
could be charged with a crime for
possessing a few plants before they
receive their card that they would have
an affirmative defense that they could
take into court they could still be
arrested they could still be charged but
their attorney could walk into court and
say hey my client has a card now it just
arrived in the mail yesterday and do we
really want this person to face felony
penalties which is what the penalty is
for home cultivation so it's not
wrapping up sir absolutely I haven't
even gotten to my employer Prime ATC
supports this I would not work for any
cannabis business that opposed home
cultivation
we understand it's not a bottom line
issue for us at all as as representative
Nagel mentioned we are non-profits in
New Hampshire our mission is to serve
patients and
I have never been able to understand any
argument that says exposing patients to
felony penalties is in any way
beneficial for their health and
well-being so most patients won't want
to grow their own for those that do our
staff members are excited about the
possibility of being able to help
educate and provide support in any way
that we can if that's you know selling
seedlings or whatever we're totally open
to that we want to help our patients uh
live their best lives so have you take
any questions thank you for considering
my testimony representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my testimony uh Mr Simon one of
one of the things you mentioned in your
testimony was some of the history and
some of the barriers to passage in the
past
um I I've noticed today with with all of
these bills I haven't really seen a lot
of law enforcement presence
um as part of these discussions and
maybe uh you know former representative
could could give input as well
what has been the feedback from the law
enforcement Community with respect to
this legislation has they been consulted
they've given you any feedback at all
thank you for the question
representative so over 15 years I've had
many meetings and conversations with
various members of law enforcement I
would not paint the law enforcement
Community with a broad brush and say
that law enforcement thinks this or law
enforcement thinks that because I think
they're
hundreds thousands probably of law
enforcement uh professionals who have
their own opinions I will say the New
Hampshire Chiefs of Police Association
in particular has weighed in very
strongly on this bill and on this issue
all along they posed therapeutic
cannabis uh no matter how it was written
no matter how restrictive it was even if
it was only for cancer even if it was
only going to help one patient they were
absolutely opposed to passing this law
in 2009 and 2013 they've been absolutely
opposed to decrim for that matter to any
form of legalization to any form of
cultivation they've been reliably
vigorously opposed and unwilling to
negotiate I remember in a two-hour
meeting at a certain police chief's
office with their lobbyist and and a
state senator trying because the Senate
asked us to negotiate well we all sat
down for two hours they were not willing
to negotiate there was no version of
this that they were ever going to be
comfortable with and for that reason the
legislature ultimately decided Well
we're going to do it anyway
I've also heard the state police major
testify publicly that there have been no
problems associated with this law in the
years that it's it's been implemented so
the chiefs of police very opposed I
think a silent majority of law
enforcement professionals probably do
not have any issue with this and do not
want to bust people for a few plants
other questions
yes yeah could I just make a public
comment about so you about the you said
any police officer there was one
actually in here previously he had to
leave I noticed because we are quite
over time
um with when this was supposed to go up
but he was I know the only reason I know
that is because I've known him since he
was a teenager when we walked in so he
is a high-level police officer so there
was someone here but he did have to
leave because of time
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Simon for being here and the
knowledge you bring
um my question is going back to the
definitions of seedlings and immature
plants
um I don't see any definition of
immature plant although as somebody
married to a gardener it it's obvious
when it actually comes to gardening when
it mature and immature is and I didn't
know if that would be a point of
confusion for anybody so I'm just
curious as to whether we would need to
look for a definition of immature plant
now that that classification is added
thank you for the question
representative so I'm looking at the
bill I'm on the first page
I'm looking at line 24
and I see a definition that appears to
be a definition of immature cannabis
plan it says immature cannabis plant
means a cannabis plant that is not
flowered and which does not have buds
that may be observed by visual
examination and which is at least six
inches tall
the next line is the definition of
mature plant that's a female cannabis
plant that's flowered and that has buds
that may be observed by visual
examination so now that I'm reading this
I'm remembering like five years ago when
we worked out these definitions and they
made sense to me then they still do does
that make sense to you you're right I
should have put these on I apologize
very well thank you other questions
saying no other questions thank you
thank you
I also signed up to speak is Michael
Holt from the Department of Health and
Human Services
hello again thank you Mr chair my name
is Michael Holt I'm the administrator of
the therapeutic cannabis program
um my major point of testimony is that
uh this uh the amendment that was
circulated by uh the sponsor Wendy
Thomas is a is is a needed Amendment
um the amendment passed out needs
further work
um and I am eager to work with the
sponsor in the committee to make that
Amendment
um accurate um so that it addresses the
issues in the in the bill
um itself
um the the committee has has asked very
excellent questions about this bill
um this bill has been has been around
the block for years
um we have uh we have worked with the
sponsors in years past
um to identify obstacles for
implementation there are none for the
Department to implement this uh this
bill
um some of the highlights and the and
the and the
and the precautions built into this bill
I just like to highlight
um
this bill allows either the patient or
their caregiver to cultivate not both
if the caregiver cultivates that means
that that caregiver can only serve one
patient and not the normal five it is
true that the majority of patient
caregiver relationships are one to one
and there we do we have very few uh
caregivers that serve multiple patients
but this limits uh that caregiver to
only having one patient if they're
cultivating
um the uh whoever cultivates must report
the cultivation location to the
Department of Health and Human Services
so that it's in in the record one of the
things that the amendment does that is
critical
um for a security and Public Safety
standpoint is to require that
cultivation location to be at the
individual's residence so that it is not
in a factory warehouse down the road
um it is it is a location reported
um and it must be at the at the
residence
um currently under under current law the
one testing laboratory in the state can
only accept cannabis samples from the
atcs this bill has a provision that
allows that one laboratory or any future
Laboratories to accept samples from the
public uh the public being a therapeutic
cannabis patient or their caregiver um
to bring in samples to have that tested
certainly doesn't address the issue of
you know a patient using you know uh
pesticides that are bad for them to
inhale perhaps but it does allow for the
the opportunity to have that tested for
contaminants
um and the cannabinoid profile to
identify the potency of the product
um another critical provision is that it
does allow for a source of of ceilings
the atcs are permitted to uh sell a
limited number of seedlings uh to their
patients
um uh within a within a certain time
period that's consistent with the the
plant limitations and the seedling
limitations uh in in the law as as was
stated seeds are legal uh federally so
people could grow their own but that
allowance that allows the atcs to engage
in this process with their patients
allows the education you know that to
happen based on that that developed
relationship
um
and yes again to be to be clear about uh
the the the grow whether indoor or
outdoor uh the bill does not say does
not restrict indoor or outdoor grows it
is presumed to allow outdoor grows uh
and uh but it does require them to be
enclosed locked and later on on page two
um the um it requires them to be out of
public view so these are standard
precautions and other uh home
cultivation States
um but again to to conclude I would say
that um
the an amendment is is important for
this bill and I'm eager to work with uh
representatives in the committee to to
nail that nail that down representative
Weber
in the interest of time we've normally
gone through the Amendments needed but
in the interest of time would you be
willing to email to the committee
members who will not discuss as a whole
uh because that would violate 91a but
could you email each of us your specific
concerns with the bill as amended by
representative Thomas's Amendment yes I
can and will thank you very much welcome
representative McKay thank you Mr
chairman
over the five years that I was chairman
working to develop this program
and I feel a bit of emotional but
surprises me the the one person that
held me together and I think the
commission which was not always easy was
Michael hope
And he as you can see today is a
reasonable human being and in a very
difficult
position
so that it's kind of nice that after all
these years we can say something
positive about this person in the
Department of Health and Human Services
who desires a great deal of recognition
and support for his great work thank you
very much
well thank you sir
other questions
seeing none so thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Heather Marie
Brown
good afternoon Heather Marie Brown
patient rep therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board I'm not quite sure if
representative knurk mentioned it I
didn't hear him but it could just be the
Acoustics but I do want to tell you that
the medical oversight board did vote
unanimously to support patient home grow
which is a huge accomplishment and I'm
very excited about that so I'm glad to
be able to tell you all that I'm just
going to give you a little example my
income is eighteen thousand dollars a
year
I can barely survive as it is take care
of my children pay rent electricity
especially with the way that electricity
rates are now heating fuel food you name
it all right I'm very limited on that
um if I were to purchase the Cannabis
that I use throughout a month from a
alternative treatment center I am
looking at spending approximately ten
thousand eight hundred dollars a year
now my income is eighteen thousand
dollars so guess what I'm not doing I am
not getting all of the Cannabis that I
need from the alternative treatment
centers
unfortunately I am not the only patient
in that situation we have many patients
that are in that situation they are
forced to do one of three things either
live and suffer
acquire their cannabis from a
unregulated black market it or risk
their safety and their health by
traveling over state borders to other
states in spending their money in those
States because they can they can acquire
therapeutic cannabis so much cheaper uh
well I'm sorry they can acquire cannabis
for so much cheaper Maine is the Wild
Wild West when it comes to cannabis and
they don't necessarily have some of the
rules and regulations in place that
prevent
bad cannabis from getting out to the
public so that is always a risk medical
home grow in my opinion is a necessity
it allows a patient to be able to help
supplement their supply that they are
already currently receiving from an
alternative treatment center
and help defer costs for that patient
for me I prefer to grow outside so sir I
already have a 10 foot high 10 by 10 dog
kennel at home waiting for this bill to
hopefully go into law and that puppy's
mine but for approximately a hundred and
fifty dollars I will be able to grow a
batch of cannabis and it could
potentially give me even under the
stipulations of this bill could
potentially give me the enough cannabis
to last me for three to four months out
of the year
you know this is a long time coming
again we have a well-established program
our patients have done absolutely
nothing but prove time and time again
how serious they are and how responsible
they are in regards to their health and
in regards to following the rules and
stipulations of the program I think it's
a no-brainer and that we should
definitely definitely push for this bill
to go into law I have I am aware of some
of the Amendments that have
requested and I agree with those as well
they are just little changes but thank
you very much thank you questions
yes representative Palazzo thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
uh I agree with General uh premise that
a home cultivation will help especially
uh people on low income but my uh I
wonder since you gave us an example with
certain uh in income level
is it true that people on low income or
like have some kinds of assistance with
basic basic needs like Snap programs
some have subsidized housing some might
qualify for housing assistance or
daycare assistance so do you see any of
it and what other needs you see
competing with the need for marijuana
thank you
I'm going to try and answer that as best
as I can I
I believe that even if a individual if I
understood you correctly
a low-income individual is receiving
some sort of Public Assistance that that
assistance is definitely not enough to
offset the cost Associated around
therapeutic cannabis I think that
regardless of those individuals are
still being forced to pick and choose
between paying a bill buying food or
in my case being able to walk and
function daily
I hope that touched upon your question
and answered it correctly I
yes representative Shapiro I would just
like to suggest that we given the time
and all the bills we have left that we
really try extra hard to keep focused on
the bill itself and not extraneous
issues okay thank you
okay any other questions for this
individual
seeing none okay thank you
also signed up to speak exactly uh that
um yeah Zach Williams
uh good afternoon committee members I'm
here to express my full support for HB
431 as a medical cannabis patient I have
seen firsthand the positive impact that
access to safe and affordable medicine
can have on individuals living with
chronic conditions and disabilities
where medical homegirl is permitted
medical homegirl offers patients like
myself the ability to control the
quality safety and cost of their
medicine
with my cannabis res with my cannabis
regimen and the prices at the local atcs
I am looking at spending around 700 plus
dollars a month for two ounces of
medical cannabis
furthermore we have seen over recent
years how other states have expanded
medical patient home growth rates due to
the importance of such programs I urge
you to support medical home growth
through House Bill 431 and allow
patients like myself the basic ability
to access safe and affordable cannabis
thank you thank you uh questions are you
taking questions sir any questions for
this gentleman
seeing none thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Derek Shirley
I believe he's representing 19 medical
patients
again three minutes sir
thank you
oh sorry did not sorry
so uh first off good afternoon everyone
my name is Derek Shirley I'm a medical
cannabis lobbyist living in Maine I'm
here today representing about 20 medical
patients 19 and residents in New
Hampshire that are in favor of HB 40 or
HP 431 a little background about myself
I am a cannabis patient who practices
the right to home grow I'm a proud
cannabis felon for four ounces of
cannabis in Maine I sat on my main
cannabis Coalition board a little over
four years where we wrote laws passed
laws through our vla committees and
later on to our Senate I sent on my town
zoning board of appeals and I Lobby in
the Maine state house and local levels
to protect and preserve medical rights
as patients and caregivers I too
personally am in favor of
4th 431 a little bit input from the
patients from New Hampshire quality
control affordability access increasing
access convenience personal empowerment
privacy rights and production from the
illicit market now living in and I have
a pretty great patient rights to home
grow I have to make a little bit
correction we actually have six mature
plants 12 immature plants and unlimited
seedlings and we Define our seedlings by
24 by 24 inches wide an inches tall
compared to HP 43 section 11a line three
New Hampshire patients are allowed Three
Mature plants three immature plants and
12 seedlings and defined by six inches
tall while we're for this and we love HP
43 we would really really recommend uh
that you maybe look based look at look
at popping seeds as a statistic if you
have 12 seeds to pop maybe they all
don't pop maybe then you put them in the
ground wrong maybe that only four come
out of the ground so let's if we're
going to get these people the home grow
rights let's set it up correctly again
this is your state though I'm not
telling you what to do to be clear just
a recommendation
um same thing with immature plants I
mean these people aren't getting high it
takes eight to 13 weeks to flower a
plant so it's like again these plants
are just kind of Sitting In Limbo
they're not causing any harm again you
your state I'm not telling you what to
do to be clear there's just
recommendations
I'm a patient I want to thank all the 20
patients that let me represent them
today and I personally want to thank you
guys for listening driving out to Maine
I'll take any questions and most
importantly I am a person not a party
thank you
questions
yes representative King thank you
chairman McDonald you've been doing this
for a long time I think you know what
you're doing yes sir um
do you think three plants mature and
three immature is enough because it
sounds like it's not enough and you have
um you have experience with this sort of
thing yes would it be better do you
think for us to just get something
through anything through now or should
we just go right for the jugular and say
12 plants mature 12 plan plants immature
or or better I mean we are delivered
just a second just to go on I don't know
any of your names by chance so I
apologize you made a good point about it
depends do you guys want to slam this
through or get it done right
you know what I mean because like at the
end of the day when you are limiting
like in here in Maine right now I'm
actually fighting to bills to eliminate
plant Cal that's what I'm doing in my
state house right now
um so I'm again not recommending that
for you guys but I think you should
absolutely think about the not even how
you feel about cannabis just think of
the statistics of making a popping a
plant growing a plant don't care what it
is think about the statistics of the
plants seedlings aren't hurting anyone
you can't even sex a plant at six inches
tall you can't even sex a plant so even
then after that let's just say all the
seeds pop let's say you well for your
law pop twelve seeds you know eight come
out of the ground cool and then I have
to wait till their past six inches to
sex them so then even then I might have
five males that are useless and then
then I leave the next next to one plant
one in mature plant and then whatever so
that's all my point is I don't want to
sit here and tell you how to run your
program because this is not my state I
just listen to patients that love
Maine's program and
um yeah that's all I'm here to do
because I think it's really important
that if you guys want to pass a home
Grill bill right you give these patients
the access give these people what they
want and not let them fail because right
now you will be back here again if you
pass it as is but again my patients just
want home grow right so they really care
how it's written but that's where I step
in and understand the bill a little bit
more than the average patient but I am
just a patient at the end of the day
um but the big thing is let's set these
people up to fail let's do it right the
first time I know it's hard to get
through this Senate I thought my Senate
made many years I'm a cannabis felon I'm
proud of it and that's why I wear my
handcuffs today because I will fight for
these rights for these patients until
I'm blue in the face I don't care what
state I'm in but when you're when you're
affected by a felony in Camp sorry I'm
sorry so I'm getting off topic but yes
to answer your question if you want to
get it through get it through and just
do it as is but if you actually have the
the power the actual numbers to get it
done right get it done right that's my
just my recommendation do whatever you
want in your state Live Free or Die
other questions
I'm seeing no other questions all right
thank you thank you for your time
final
person who has signed up to testify this
afternoon on HB 431 is Danielle McQueen
hello
my name is three minutes ma'am
I'm sorry what uh three minutes please
oh that's fine I think I can make it
um thank you for your time I'm here to
support the bill my name is Danielle I'm
a Danielle McQueen I'm a resident of
Belknap County New Hampshire
award-winning New England New England
cannabis activist but first I will
always be a mother and one to a cannabis
patient
on this journey of fighting for cannabis
laws I'm honored to say I dedicated my
life to the medical form and cannabis
education and development I developed a
company that has been nominated 20 plus
times won three awards for cannabis
Innovation and most recently I was
awarded East Coast woman role model for
my work in cannabis I have seen it from
both parts and I've seen this state from
the start almost a decade ago a New
Hampshire resident had to sue the state
to get medical cards available to her
it's too many years now that have passed
to continue this delay in developments
the delay in developments has affected
my daughter my daughter has an
autoimmune disease in a form of epilepsy
at one time opiates and sedatives the
only option given for her after failed
pharmaceutical options cannabis was
suggested but in this state when she was
an infant there wasn't a
well-established medical cannabis
program similar to now sadly and as a
family we had to move to Maine who had
already developed a medical cannabis
program having to move my daughter to
get care still seems unfair so I ask you
see the delay in changes in New
Hampshire is keeping walls in place that
need to come down in Maine as a mother a
patient a caregiver and a business owner
in the Cannabis industry the past eight
years I have seen both sides this year I
brought my daughter home to New
Hampshire as soon as I brought her here
though I saw all the same things I stood
and fought for so long ago
the medical program needs to be Advanced
I just want to share a very short
scenario with you for most of us when we
go to get a medication we go to a
pharmacy but for a lot of us even being
able to pick up our medication at that
Pharmacy sometimes it's gut-wrenching
because of the high cost but available
to all of you is the access to that
correct medication Insurance help and
sitting in the counter right there in
front of you an RX discount card for all
medication to help with that cost that
medication for me that's not how it
works with the Cannabis Medical
certain patients like my daughter
require certain strand of cannabis there
is a different plant with a different
compound for certain illnesses and that
strand isn't even available in New
Hampshire and I want to say I want to
substitute it like you could generically
at a pharmacy
I'd need amounts that cost in the
thousands because of the prices and the
lack of development here regarding
cannabis education and development these
limited state-run dispensaries for some
patients are hours hours away so highly
priced because our state refuses to
allow residents doctors parents to be
involved in cannabis education expansion
this is what our program needs education
what I learned going through this
process in another state there were
States who faced this battle to make
this decision and with growth mindset
had developed and have put in place
guidelines and Guys these guidelines are
simple
this is simple grow the plant that the
doctors were teaching us about just like
any new medical device or medication so
many states have been proven and had
positive outcomes advancing their
medical cannabis programs in most staged
medical patients are given the
opportunity and education to be able to
grow their own cannabis this is a very
important part like New Hampshire who is
not fully established like the
surrounding programs speaking as a
mother I will always pick a plant versus
pain medication who is proven to be
addictive an opiate addict can go into a
pharmacy and get in a free needle to
ingest an illegal deadly substance but
yet I can't grow my daughter's
plant-based doctor-prescribed medication
with guidance he could stop wrapping up
ma'am absolutely I want to end this by
one more important fact with the new
practice guidelines the CDC updated last
year regarding new guidelines and
prescribing doctors giving them uh
giving them guidelines to follow like
Oxycontin the CDC established this
trying to curb the epidemic of addiction
and abuse and I support it but now we're
going to be seeking seeing more cannabis
patients and doctors to seek Alternative
Care and that is going to be cannabis
all states will see an increase in
patients looking to find a replacement
to treat pain with the new CDC
guidelines don't let that replacement be
an illegal deadly less priced drug on
the street let the doctors help them to
learn to grow and a healthier
plant-based way to treat their pain and
thrive
that's all I got
thank you questions for this lady
no saying no questions so thank you very
much
I have nobody else signed up to speak on
HP the 431 does anyone else wish to
speak
seeing no one I am going to close the
public hearing on HP 431 at this point
we have no other bills notice to for
public hearing today so the public
hearings are concluded for today and we
will be going into executive session
would you want to announce which ones
we're not going to do
sorry bye uh yeah we'll we'll take uh
what 10 minute uh 10 minute recess
representative we'll have a 10-minute
recess
I'd like to start in a couple minutes if
members could start taking their seats
please
yes
hey ladies and gentlemen I know there's
a couple of members we're still waiting
on so we're not going to go too far but
I did want to um number one recognize uh
representative Howard as Heath Howard
who was sitting in as a substitute so
thank you and welcome
um given the hour and we as we
um sized up the afternoon earlier
representative Leon and representative
Weber and I we all realize that um it
was going to be we were being very
ambitious and trying to exec 10 bills
this afternoon so we are going to exec
some uh three that will hopefully go
fairly quickly we are going to continue
the others to next Wednesday the 15th
and I'll leave the name the numbers of
those
HP 299 prohibiting discrimination and
Medical Care HB 322 relative to
establishing a committee to study the
New Hampshire Board of Medicine HB 323
relative to establishing a committee on
emerging medical Technologies HB 454
relative to the membership and Reporting
responsibilities of the Examining Board
of Medicine HP 582 requiring the
division of Vital Records to collect
induced termination of pregnancy
statistics
hb614fn directing the Department of
Health and Human Services to develop a
Health outcomes repository related to
per and polyfluorinated alkyl substances
at HP 65 yeah hb615 FN requiring
independent audits of reproductive
Health Care Facilities
the three that we will be considering
this afternoon
again this is in consultation with um
both parties
um HB 397 relatively the prohibition of
the possession of hypodermic dermic
needles for minors
HB 338fn relative to prescription drug
assistance for individuals with diabetes
and HB 262 relative to Laboratory
Testing by licensed naturopaths
and with that are we all assembled is
everything
okay do I have a motion on do we want to
consider the amendment first is that
yeah we do have an amendment on HB 397
representative Leon is going to
distribute that
um thank you I'd like to and I have it
right here it's Amendment uh
2023-0459h it's an amendment to 397.
um I may I wasn't sure if it was better
to include representative merchant after
without having an exact perfect sign off
or not include him so I apologize for
leaving him off I just thought it'd be
worse to include him if he did not want
to be part of it
thank you
okay thank you
the audience is a lot smaller now DHHS
it's a big department
and it works
representative McLean we are about to
consider an amendment to fortnite to
house bill 397.
thank you
it's fine and you left one for Mark
McLean yes I did
speak to sure
representative Leon is recognized to
speak to the amendment
um thank you Mr chairman as as we were
looking at this bill it seems pretty
clear that people had there was some
concern around having the needle
exchange program included in this
because people are worried about misuse
of needles and misuse of drugs
that part was removed from
so that part is missing when you look at
this at line 10 of the amendment and
line 20 of the amendment in both of
those sections
another change to this was that there
are a bunch of innovative drug drug
delivery Technologies which DO
Incorporated hypodermic needle but
they're Incorporated in such a way that
the FDA doesn't allow them to be
approved if they can be used to misuse
drugs if you can substitute another drug
into a pain patch or anything else it
would not be approved by the FDA and it
would not be allowed this is actually an
area where I had quite a bit of
knowledge working with insulate and
other couple companies on drug delivery
and avoiding misuse of them so for that
reason the statute is being changed to
talk about controller possession of a
hypodermic syringe or hypodermic needle
because when you include any instrument
adapted for the administration of drugs
by injection you're looking about
looking at Innovative Technologies that
really don't present a risk here and it
just just confuses the issue this would
then mean that if somebody had an EpiPen
and you handed off the EpiPen the EpiPen
wouldn't be
you could even make the case that that
an EpiPen it does have the have the
hypodermic needle in there but this
protects a lot of those other uses where
you're going to be going astray
um the other part is that it adds under
direct supervision so that if they were
in position in possession of the
hypodermic syringe or hypodermic needle
the authorized agent that's a youth
would be need to be under direct
supervision that's something where a
babysitter wise you can figure out how
that would be interpreted but this
provides a lot more interpret a lot more
protection and protects those uses where
you're asking a child to hold your bag
and somebody doesn't like you they know
you're a diabetic and they choose that
moment that that's the thing we've dealt
with all sorts of excess and policing
and we just want to remove each of those
opportunities for misuse and lastly it
adds the phrase use of a hypodermic
syringe or hypodermic needle contrary to
the antenna the prescription is not
permitted under the statute so if
somebody's misusing their parents
insulin syringe it's not protected so I
think that this addresses everybody's
concerns I'd love to hear if there's
anything that wasn't addressed in our
Amendment but hopefully this is good
so you're moving the amendment I take it
representative Leon yes so I move this
amendment is there a second to the
motion yes representative
yes I know
well for the purposes of a second
all right so do you have any further
comment on this representative Leon or
um I I think I said what needed to be
said any other okay any other discussion
Mr chairman just wanted to thank
representative Leon for working with me
on this amendment uh does dress the
concerns that I heard the ones I had
specifically and that dealt with
needle exchange program that a miner
could have access to a needle that was
not prescribed to them or prescribed to
somebody so took care of that concern
and the other one when talked about
contrary to the intent of the
prescription is the antenna by the FDA
but also the intent of How It's
prescribed so therefore takes care of
the issue of using it in some manner
that was never intended but by the
describer
so I totally support the amendment
thank you other discussion
yes representative King thank you Mr
chair
um so we added under direct supervision
and I'm concerned that maybe somebody
like the mother who testified she might
keep needles in her car all the time
daughter borrows the car she's not under
direct supervision now all of a sudden
she's potentially having life ruining
felony charges
I don't know I don't understand why we
why we put that in there I'd rather that
not be there personally so I don't know
I'm just curious why
um thank you I definitely understand
that point and I do think that there
could be a risk of not removing those
needles from a car but there are certain
situations where we're taking certain
instruments with you makes sense I
wouldn't leave my firearm in the car
obviously hypodermic measles are a
longer term risk for similar for similar
potential outcomes
um but if you have a bag full of
hypodermic needles that are a part of it
I would think that that
foreign
I think that that's when we're also
looking at do we have at 16 and older
for the delivery and all of this this is
where I was trying to get for the
compromise this may be something that
would be a good thing to bring even into
the senate for us to for them to take a
look and see I know it's best if they're
the same but I don't this is an early
bill so it would be good to get it out
early
um I believe it's going to criminal
justice so we can probably take another
bite of the apple of that of trying to
make it so that it has that correct
intent I don't know if there'd be desire
to change that direct supervision or if
this is something that gets the general
intent of this bill out
um while meeting meeting most of the
need while it does leave some potential
exposure but we've reduced a lot of
exposure to risk here
can I follow up with that follow up um
so I like the fact that you mentioned
that it later with the joint session
with the senate or something that it
could potentially be taken out and I I
just I would like to see it taken out
because I know for example my sister was
type one is type 1 diabetic and um
there's been times let's just say where
you know she has to throw away her
needles in like a specific way and lots
of times it ends up in a huge garbage
bag in the back of her car and she
drives on her for three months before
she I mean and so it's just brutal that
somebody else could borrow that car and
have their life completely ruined
because of some let's just say
delinquency of my system you know what I
mean so I don't know I just I I I
personally hate the idea of people going
to jail for something they did nothing
wrong and to me putting that back in
there just it just allows them oh you're
not under direct supervision the other
person's in the other room we're going
to ruin your life now so I would just
like to see it gone but I will vote for
the amendment but I just want to get as
few people in prison as possible and
that just adds potentially more people
in prison that's how I see it thank you
representative Weber
so I have two comments to make and reply
to that one of which is although I
really truly understand the discomfort
that led to the bringing of this bill
um
I my initial reaction was this is a
solution in search of a problem I don't
know of people who are going to jail for
appropriately helping
uh people when they are ill
but secondly I will also say that you or
anyone else can approach your Senator or
testify at a senate hearing and ask them
to do whatever changes you want and
people from this committee have done it
all the time sometimes to the
gratification of the committee and
sometimes to the intense annoyance of
other members of the committee so that's
always a process that's available
of the discussion
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chair um this looks good to me but I I
on line 19 unless the recipient is
acting as an authorized agent for
another is defined by RSA 318
um colon 42. I'm I have that up but it's
a it's a long section is do you have a
reference to where it actually defines
what an authorized agent is
um thank you it's actually in the
section above I did not see that they
deleted the comma I
that is in the section above that
um
that maybe I know that occasionally
those minor clerical things like that
can be cleaned up hopefully that's
something that we can move forward with
this even with that missing three okay I
just thought you might be you might have
on the on line 20
it's on it's on line 10 but not line 20.
representative Weber do you
oh yeah so now I was going to State
about the cleaning up of the clerical
errors I did check with the clerk when
we had our issue about section one and
section two and he did confirm that that
is the kind of thing that we could have
passed that with the error and it would
have been in changing the amendment into
a committee Amendment it would have been
taken care of we could have noted that
so I think in in this case that's also
something that can be noted and taken
care of when it becomes a Committee
Member if the committee votes it thank
you
any other discussion
okay if there's no other discussion I
will ask the clerk to call the wall so
the motion is ought to pass on Amendment
2023 hyphen zero four five nine h
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative mazur yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosov yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard
yes
and representative McDonald yes
and the vote is 20 to zero on the
amendment
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
pass as amended by Amendment
2023-04598 with those clerical cleanups
I'll second that okay motion's been made
in second of any discussion
seeing none I'll ask Clark if he's ready
to call the wall
okay representative land yes
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofault yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard yes and
representative McDonald yes
vote is 20 to nothing ought to pass with
Amendment consent yes if no if there's
no objection that will be recommended
for the consent calendar
okay next up is uh HB 338fn relative to
prescription drug assistance for
individuals with diabetes do I have a
motion
uh representative Leia um thank you Mr
chairman I move an expedient to
legislate on House Bill 338--fm
is there a second
I'll second that
uh representative King okay
representative of South King seconds uh
representative Leon do you want to speak
to your motion um yes thank you Mr
chairman uh looking into this bill it's
it's clear that what we found out that
the section that this refers to has
never been stood out it's not funded so
it would require
creating a whole new board and a whole
new requirement there would be a lot of
work a lot of money to try and make that
happen this is something where there's
other issues as well around it with
making sure that
uh the I there's no generic insulin and
if there was still generic insulin that
might be an easy change but we need to
look at all the different insulin types
this would be a very large very big
change in order to get the sponsor's
intent
um to actually come to fruition so by
itl in this bill it would need to come
back and substantially changed form so
there should not be a problem with it
coming back in the second year of this
session additionally I listened to the
State of the Union Address and 35
insulin co-pays is a priority out of DC
so trying to recreate and stand up a
program that doesn't exist and isn't
funded when there is a federal effort to
do this and we would need to rewrite the
bill just doesn't seem like it's the
most appropriate use of committee time
given everything else that we're trying
to handle this year and this coming
summer and fall therefore since we would
be able to change things up and and
somebody could introduce a different
Bill to achieve this aim for next year
within this term I believe that
inexpedient to legislate is the the most
appropriate given time constraints
representative Weber
thank you Mr chair and I will say
regretfully that I I agree that this
bill
and this program is not workable
although the intent of the bill is very
admirable
and I'm very glad that we have the
opportunity now with cameras to say on
the record that
if this bill is itl'd we are only it
yelling
the use of a very problematical vehicle
and not precluding the entire
spectrum of things we might be doing for
people who need a insulin to make it
more available and more affordable that
we're just restricting this one program
so with that having been said in that
caveat I'm I am sadly but
realistically going to vote for itl
of the discussion yes representative
farmer
thank you Mr chairman I I think
representative Weber has sort of
addressed my concern which is that what
I've heard before is that if a bill is
itl that you can't bring up the the
overall
issue again easily but if this can come
up particularly in the if if there is we
hear that there's Federal changes that
would make it easy for us to enact
something in New Hampshire then yeah
then that makes sense to me
thank you of the discussion yes
representative Nagel thank you this is a
little bit of a tongue-in-cheek thing
but I did not watch the State of the
Union Address
um when that point was brought up did
both sides cheer or did just one side
I I didn't watch it either so I don't
know I wasn't watching that carefully
for it I just noted oh this is what
we're trying to do in New Hampshire
maybe they're going to look at it
federally
representative Shapiro
um yes
um I I understand and
um regretfully agree that this bill has
brought to us is really flawed and is
problematic and among other things it
doesn't have any
um Financial note about who's going to
pay for this and how it's going to be
paid for still in principle I
I would have a tremendous amount of
difficulty voting to itl so I won't vote
to itl and I would hope that it could be
retained I think I noticed also that
during the State of the Union speech
that that was proposed by the president
um but clearly the State of the Union
speech is a place where a lot of ideas
are proposed and they don't necessarily
come to fruition
I hope it does then we can
just
end this bill
of the discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll motion is itl on HB 338 FM
representative land yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosov yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative Freitas no
representative Cannon
yes
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro
no
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
yes
representative Howard no
and representative McDonald yes
I have 16 to four
16-4 itl
okay do we know if there's going to be a
minority report at this point or
thank you
that looks like no no Minority Report
um but it would have to go I believe on
the regular calendar with four with four
no votes okay
right two is the limit right I believe
two is the limit if it's it can't be
more than two if it goes on consent
under the speakers that I worked on it
was two it's a speaker's policy I have
seen as many as four but I don't think
that's
really sensible I mean we have a
significant difference of opinion about
the ultimate way to deal with the bill
so okay all right thank you
all right uh next for our consideration
House Bill 262 relative to library
Laboratory Testing by licensed
naturopaths do I have a motion yes
representative Cushman
uh thank you I move that we recommend
House Bill 262
ought to pass
okay to pass is there a second to that
second
uh representative Merchant seconds
uh representative Cushman do you want to
speak to your motion yes thank you
um there was some confusion during the
hearing I think on the
um on the reasoning and and what this
bill does
um but I hope that it was clarified that
this is really a technical change I
think it's it's just it's kind of like
being polite to just include the
naturopathic
um
doctors in this this lab testing
um statute it doesn't change anything
that they're able to do
besides clarifying
that along with all the other medical
practitioners they don't have a duty to
care for someone who brings them Labs
that they ordered themselves
I think that's the only real
impact of the bill it just clarifies
so I hope you'll all support the
autopaths
discussion
yes representative Weber
well I started out as a solid itl on
this one but having looked at
what already exists
it does seem that we have
a
real glitch between the issues of
reporting and interpreting and who does
it and maintaining that given that the
practice is already allowed
seems like removing removing that
problem is a good idea so I'm going to
vote in favor of the ought to pass
representative Nagel
um for my following comments I'm going
to be kicked out of the medical society
but I'm going to make them anyways um we
won't tell them thanks I mean in terms
of scope of practice I have serious
problems but it exists and I brought
this up at all of our discussions on
this it already exists in scope of
practice that they are allowed to order
and interpret these tests and I think
it's impossible to not acknowledge that
and vote against that
and representative Merchant
what I initially was looking to not
support it but then when I went back and
looked at it
the naturopath can actually order
interpret their own Labs but they only
can interpret the labs they order
so if a patient wants to bring something
to the naturopath that they didn't order
they can't interpret it so all this does
is allow the natural path the ability to
interpret an order brought to them by a
patient or bought to them by another
provider so I think it's kind of
extension logically to say if you can
interpret your orders that you order but
you can't interpret someone else's lab
that's kind of doesn't make any sense to
me
representative Shapiro yes I'm I'm going
to vote for this and I think that um not
only does it change nothing or very
little as representative Merchant said
but I think you know it's an opportunity
just for us to vote for people to have
the most diverse choices in terms of
making their own medical opinions
without hurting anybody
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman I I also was in the same boat
initially to itl right from the get-go
but the testimony we heard yesterday
specifically from Dr Lou was one that
really I thought attacked more of their
historical background the standard of
care their training that's not the scope
of this bill this the scope of this bill
as everybody else has mentioned is
basically allowing them to do what they
already do and it was a technical era a
year ago not to include them so I will
vote
ought to pass
as well
thank you another discussion is
representative Cushman I have one more
piece of information to offer the
committee although it seems we have good
support
um I spoke with Courtney Tanner earlier
because I think um from Dartmouth
Hitchcock I think it was
um there was a little uh it was a little
unclear if Dartmouth Hitchcock was
opposed to it because Dr Liu works there
but Dartmouth Hitchcock is not opposed
they're neutral on the bill thank you
did I see your hand yes representative
Palmer
yes and actually Dr Lou himself said
that he was neutral on the bill and I
think the concerns I had had to do with
finances which has actually nothing to
do with this bill and would have to be
addressed elsewhere so I'm in favor of
this
thank you of the discussion
seeing no other discussion I'll ask the
clerk to call the roll motion is ought
to pass on HB 262.
representative land
yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative coppol yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pollazzo yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard yes
and representative McDonald yes
20-0
consent uh yes uh there's no objection
we will put this on the consent calendar
and that concludes uh the
um the bills that we
announced previously for this executive
session so I will adjourn the meeting
until next Wednesday